Hallo Wolfgang, hallo Stefan.
Heute stelle ich dir eine Frage, die dich betrifft. Was soll denn aus dem Rhein-Main-Gebiet werden, wenn die Banken wechseln?
Eine Party, Opern und Cocktail-Szenerie?
Prima. Na ja, Ulrike Herrmann sagt, wir brauchen dann bald keine Banken mehr, beziehungsweise Banken können keine großen Gewinne mehr machen, da kaum noch Kredite aufgenommen werden, denn wir schrumpfen ja, wir wachsen nicht. Wenn man wächst, dann nimmt man Kredite auf. Das heißt, erhebliche Bankgewinne fallen weg. Auch Investmentbanking lohnt sich da nicht mehr. Was passiert dann mit dem Rhein-Main-Gebiet, das so sehr geprägt ist von den Banken? Diese Frage stellt sie und viele weitere Fragen. Es geht hier also gar nicht darum, dass sie uns ein Deutschland ausmalt, wo wir eine Verdichtung unbedingt haben, eine Flächenverdichtung, dass wir ganz uns im urbanen Raum ansiedeln, sondern vielleicht stellt sich auch die Frage, ob man das, was schon gebaut ist, nur anders nutzt und ob man dann nicht doch aufs Land gehen muss, weil da eben schon die Flächenversiegelung stattgefunden hat. Das ist jetzt etwas, womit ich schon sehr weit vorgesprungen bin, aber wir wollen uns ja dem langsam nähern.
Das passt genau zum Buch, es geht runter und drüber.
Es geht runter und drüber, findest du. Zunächst einmal ist es ja sehr strukturiert. Zunächst einmal erzählt Ulrike Herrmann uns in ihrem Buch ihre Geschichte des Kapitalismus. Und ich sage bewusst ihre Geschichte, weil sie ein paar Thesen aufstellt, die gewisserweise kühn sind. Also ihre These beispielsweise ist, dass der Kapitalismus sich in England so früh und so stark entfalten konnte, lag daran, dass in England die höchsten Löhne bezahlt wurden. Dadurch lohnte sich sehr früh, Maschinen einzusetzen, wo man ja weiß, Maschinen werden nur eingesetzt, wenn Arbeitskräfte teuer sind, wenn es sich lohnt, Maschinen einzusetzen. Sicherlich stimmt es, dass es diese Lohnunterschiede gab, wenn man das mit anderen europäischen Ländern oder gar mit außereuropäischen Ländern vergleicht. Aber hier würde ich gleich schon mal anfügen, ja, es ist aber sicherlich nicht der einzige Grund, warum der Kapitalismus sich da so prächtig entwickelt hat, zumal ja diese Lohnentwicklung auch irgendwo herkommt. Also, die ist ja nicht einfach da, dass man sich mal entschieden hat, jetzt zahlen wir allen bessere Löhne, sondern das kommt schon auch aus dieser ursprünglichen Akkumulation. Marx hat das ja sehr genau beschrieben, wie gewaltsam sich der Land angeeignet wurde und dass sie da so darüber hinweggeht oder sogar sagt, dass die ursprüngliche Akkumulation nicht stimmt. Das würde ich doch in Zweifel ziehen. Auch, dass sie sehr stark ausblendet, dass England nun mal ein Weltreich zu damaliger Zeit war und als große Weltmacht und Kolonialmacht über ganz andere Möglichkeiten verfügte, Kapital einzusetzen, Konkurrenten wegzudrängen, einen Welthandel mitzubestimmen. Sie hat dann immer sehr konkrete Zahlen für Dinge, die zeigen, dass es gar nicht so wichtig war, ob man Kolonien besaß oder nicht. Aber dennoch kann man sagen, die politische Macht war derart stark, dass es kein Wunder ist, dass sich dort dann auch ein Fortschritt im Sinne einer Industrialisierung bahn bricht.
Es ist ja ein bisschen so, diesen Teil, den du jetzt nennst, also sie beschreibt uns das England, als die Löhne dreimal so hoch waren und die Automatisierung sich durchsetzte, die Industrialisierung so eine Co-Evolution aus technischem und sozialem Fortschritt bildete und wir immer nur die Technik beobachten, aber nicht die soziale Seite, die da auch zu beobachten ist. Sie kommt ja dann auch mit so Spezialthesen irgendwie. Keine Ahnung. Der Wohlstand ging der Industrialisierung voran. Also man brauchte erst Wohlstand, dann kam die Industrialisierung, so wie heute wir der CDU wieder sagen wollen. Nee, du brauchst erst die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft und dann bist du auch ein guter Arbeiter, was ja Studien belegen. Pestwellen reiten durch das Land, dezimieren die Bevölkerung, dadurch steigen die Löhne, weil weniger Menschen sozusagen nachgefragt sind. Ist ja auch wieder so ein Verknappungsargument, wie wir es heute durch geburten- schwache Jahrgänge sehen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wir gehen gleich noch mal mehr darauf ein. Das ist ja so ein Textteil, in dem uns Ulrike Herrmann ihr England erklärt. Und zwar ein längst zurückliegendes und vielleicht auch so vergessenes England, dass ich hier den Verdacht habe, ja, das ist das England, wie uns Ulrike Herrmann das beschreibt und wie es vielleicht zu ihrer Anlage des Buches passt. Und die Anlage des Buches, die sie vorher nennt, die ist ganz schön extrem. Und das kann man ja auch noch mal sagen. Sie beginnt ja mit so Sätzen wie Klimaschutz ist nur möglich, wenn wir den Kapitalismus abschaffen. Das ist ein Zitat. Und da frage ich mich natürlich Klimaschutz. Was genau ist denn jetzt Klimaschutz? Also, dass wir das Klima retten oder Klima so in Abstufungen schützen. Also, in welcher Dimension ist das denn gedacht? Dafür, dass sie den ganzen Kapitalismus abschaffen will. Kapitalismus wird sich auch später dann nennen. Er ist eigentlich so ein Selbstläufer, stellt sich immer ein, wenn irgendwie mit Geld zu tun hat und so. Das Abschaffen allerdings ist ja ein großer politischer Akt. Also hier ist ja, hier muss ja sozusagen ein, eine Selbstläuferentwicklung unterbrochen werden durch eine politische Entscheidung. Und es könnte nicht schicksalshafter sein, als können wir uns echt darauf vereinen, also hinter dieser Meinung versammeln, wir müssen jetzt den Kapitalismus abschaffen, dann machen wir es und zweitens, was heißt das dann genau? Das können wir dann gleich überprüfen, ob sie uns da die richtigen Anmerkungen machen.
Und die These ist ja zugleich auch, wenn wir den Kapitalismus nicht abschaffen, dann wird er sowieso abgeschafft werden, etwa später dann, weil alles klimatisch so verheerend sein wird, dass man überhaupt nicht mehr profitabel produzieren kann. Es wird dann alles dadurch so teuer, dass wir Dürren haben, dass wir Brände haben, dass wir kein Wasser haben, dass der Kapitalismus überhaupt nicht mehr am Laufen gehalten werden kann. Ich finde es sehr sympathisch, erst noch mal zurückzugehen an die Ursprünge des Kapitalismus, um damit auch deutlich zu machen, der Kapitalismus ist menschheitsgeschichtlich eine wichtige Epoche, aber doch eine sehr kurze Epoche, wenn man es vergleicht, wie lange es die Menschen denn schon gibt. Die Thesen in diesem Buch sind, wie du sagst, sehr, sehr drastisch. Wir werden in einer Gesellschaft leben, in der es keine Autos mehr gibt, in der man nicht mehr fliegen kann. Eine Gesellschaft, in der Güter verteilt werden. Wer etwas braucht, das wird zugeteilt. Es wird davon gesprochen, dass wir eine Kriegswirtschaft brauchen. Darauf kommen wir gleich noch zu sprechen, wie das aussehen soll. Die Politik steuert dann, was wem zugeteilt wird. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir eine Planwirtschaft haben. Denn das Ganze soll zugleich noch privatwirtschaftlich organisiert sein. Auch darauf müssen wir eingehen, was das bedeutet und ob das umsetzbar ist. Die nächste Epoche sagt, sie wird die Epoche einer Überlebenswirtschaft sein. Und der Kapitalismus hat, das müssen wir auch zur Kenntnis nehmen, einiges gut gemacht. Vieles ist dadurch besser geworden. So gibt es keinen Hunger mehr. In Industrieländern sind viele Dinge immer günstiger geworden. Aber wir stehen jetzt vor dem Dilemma, wenn wir den Klimaschutz haben wollen, den wir brauchen. Also den Klimaschutz, der so radikal ist, dass man sagt, wir dürfen das 1,5-Grad-Ziel nicht reißen. Wir müssen eigentlich sehen, dass wir jetzt in den nächsten Jahrzehnten, ja eigentlich das ganze Jahrhundert durchweg fast gar nichts mehr imitieren, dass wir 1, noch was Tonnen CO2 imitieren dürfen pro Mensch, aber pro, nee Moment, wie war das, 1,5 pro?
Eine Tonne pro Person statt wie jetzt aktuell in Deutschland so 10.
Und in den USA sind es dann 24 Tonnen. Das heißt, wir sind dann dabei, dass wir auf ein Zehntel zurück müssen. Was heißt das dann eigentlich für unseren Wohlstand? Für Ulrike Herrmann jedenfalls ist ganz klar, man wird viel investieren müssen, aber man wird auch mit noch so klimafreundlicher Technologie und mit noch so vielen Innovationen keinesfalls es schaffen, den Klimawandel aufzuhalten. Das geht nur durch Schrumpfen. Das ist die Prämisse ihres Buchs. Und da müssen wir uns jetzt gleich mal die einzelnen Thesen ansehen.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt schon... Dieses Klimaschutz ist nur möglich, wenn wir den Kapitalismus abschaffen. Also Klimazerstörung ist Kapitalismus. Kapitalismus ist Klimazerstörung. Wenn wir Klima retten wollen, müssen wir den Kapitalismus abschaffen. Auch Fridays for Future täuschen sich, wenn sie immer auf korrupte Politiker oder gierige Unternehmer abstellen. Es ist der Kapitalismus selbst, sagt sie. Wir können also weder die Politik einzeln verändern oder unternehmerisches Handeln, sondern nein, das ganze Gefüge muss auseinandergenommen werden. Grünes Wachstum ist eine Illusion. Sie kommt mit der Dunkelflaute. Auch die erneuerbaren Energien nützen uns nichts im Winter oder in der Nacht. Wobei, ich sage, Claudia Kämpfer hat die Dunkelflauten-Mythos schon vor Jahren eigentlich auseinandergenommen. Und ihr Anliegen ist jetzt, der Rückbau des Kapitalismus muss geordnet vonstattengehen. Dann kommt sie relativ zügig schon mal begrifflich auf die britische Kriegswirtschaft. In der Klimadebatte wird stets suggeriert, dass wir die Lösung schon hätten und allein der politische Wille fehlt. Doch tatsächlich gibt es bisher kein Rezept, wie sich der Kapitalismus friedlich beenden ließe. Das ist mir zu... Keine Ahnung, wir haben bisher noch kein Konzept, wie wir das Klima retten. Okay, aber wie wir den Kapitalismus friedlich beenden, also wollen wir den friedlich beenden, denn wenn wir uns jetzt sachlich und historisch, also in Sach- und Zeitdimension, die Lage der Welt anschauen, Amerika und Europa haben das Klima zerstört. Wir sind verantwortlich für 90% der Emissionen. Der Rest der Welt ist aber auch noch da. Und lebt der Rest der Welt gerade jenseits des Kapitalismus, weil Kapitalismus wie sehr Umweltzerstörung, aber hat Pakistan die letzten 100 Jahre das Klima zerstört? Haben die afrikanischen Länder das Klima zerstört? Würden wir sagen, dort gilt gerade nicht die kapitalistische Logik als primäre Ordnungsprinzip der Wirtschaft? Würde ich sagen, nee, das stimmt ja gar nicht, dass diese eins zu eins, diese kongruent so gegeben ist, dass Kapitalismus gleich Klimazerstörung ist. Deswegen ja auch so Plädoyer wie von mir. Wir müssen halt in Afrika, wenn wir jetzt die demografische Welle haben mit einem Plus, dass wir dann in Wirtschaftswachstum, dass da automatisch kommt, weil auch ohne Kapitalismus wollen die Menschen ja überleben. Das ist ja ihr Anliegen. Wir brauchen eine Überlebenswirtschaft. Die muss ja irgendwie funktionieren. Die kommen nicht drumherum, Energie zu verbrauchen. Die Frage ist dann, was kann die Energiequelle sein? Sollen sie Kohle-Löcher buddeln oder eben die neuen Möglichkeiten annehmen? Und es wird bei ihr alles ausgeblendet. Der Kapitalismus ist Klimazerstörung und muss deswegen beendet werden.
Es ist eine nationale Perspektive. Sie berichtet zwar von der britischen Kriegswirtschaft, aber worum es ihr geht, ist, was wir in Deutschland tun können. Sie hat nicht die internationale Perspektive im Blick, denn es ist ja definitiv so, dass viele andere Schwellenländer jetzt einen Aufstieg erleben werden. Die kommen dann nicht bei unseren 10 Tonnen CO2 an. Aber selbstverständlich wird es möglich sein, ein bisschen mehr Fleisch zu konsumieren. Wird es möglich sein, vielleicht auch eine Urlaubsreise ins Ausland sich zu gönnen? Wird Individualverkehr möglich sein? Das heißt, diese Perspektive klammert sie aus. Darum geht es jetzt nicht, sondern wir sollen als Deutschland jetzt mit gutem Beispiel voranschreiten. Wir haben viel angerichtet, was ja definitiv stimmt. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt eine Wirtschaft entwickeln, die möglichst kein CO2 mehr emittiert. Denn wenn wir weiter CO2 emittieren, auch wenn wir nur so bleiben, wo wir gerade sind, oder wenn wir es halbieren, dann reicht das eigentlich nicht aus für das, was wir tun müssten. Das ist ja zunächst einmal eine These, der ja zuzustimmen ist, wenn man der Klimaforschung glaubt. Es ist ja keineswegs so, dass man sagt, wenn wir noch ein paar Panels uns aufs Dach montieren und wenn wir hin und wieder kein Fleisch essen, dann wird das schon geregelt. Also die Ausweglosigkeit, wenn man diesen Zahlen, die sie da alle zitiert, glauben kann, ist ja sehr, sehr groß. Die Frage, die du jetzt aufstellst, ist, müssen wir dafür den Kapitalismus abschaffen? Und ich würde zunächst einmal sagen, Ulrike Herrmann schafft gar nicht den Kapitalismus ab. Ulrike Herrmann reformiert den Kapitalismus. Sie will eigentlich das Primat des Politischen stärker drin haben. Während wir lange Zeit die Märkte haben machen lassen, was sie ebenso machen wollen. Wir haben hier eigentlich das Plädoyer für eine Industriepolitik, wie Biden sie zum Beispiel auch anstrebt. Sicherlich in einer sehr radikalen Ausprägung. Aber was ja hier nicht passiert ist, dass zum Beispiel Unternehmen vergesellschaftet werden, das Privateigentum abgeschafft wird. Jetzt ist es auch so, dass in realsozialistischen Staaten nicht grundsätzlich das Privateigentum gänzlich abgeschafft wurde. Aber hier geht es überhaupt nicht darum, mal an Eigentumsverhältnisse auch nur zu tasten. Ich würde jetzt schon mal als These aufstellen wollen, Kriegswirtschaft ist ein Begriff, um erst einmal das böse Wort Sozialismus nicht sagen zu müssen, um weiterhin diskursfähig zu sein. Und die Kriegswirtschaft ausagiert bei Ulrike Herrmann, bedeutet dann aber, dass man einen Weg finden will, dass man auf keinen Fall eine sozialistische Wirtschaft haben möchte. Denn tatsächlich würden sich ja einige Ableitungen dahin ergeben, dass man sagt, warum vergemeinschaften wir nicht sehr viel mehr, wie zum Beispiel Wohnen genossenschaftlich organisiert, Energie, warum müssen da irgendwelche Privatkonzerne noch mal dran verdienen, wenn du zu Hause die Heizung aufdrehst und Spekulanten noch dazu. Warum eigentlich haben wir es zugelassen, dass unsere Pflege, dass ganze Sektoren privatisiert werden, die Mobilität, wo man eigentlich das viel besser vergemeinschaften könnte und auch genossenschaftlich organisieren und auch mit Partizipation ausstatten könnte. Diese Fragen stellt sie interessanterweise nicht. Das heißt, die eigentlichen Eigentumsverhältnisse bleiben stark unangetastet, wenngleich den Privatunternehmen dann blüht, dass die Regierung ihnen sagt, was nun produziert wird. Das heißt dann keine Anzüge mehr für mich, sondern denen wird dann gesagt, ab sofort macht ihr irgendwelche Planen zum Sonnenschutz.
Und das ist doch ein mega Problem, weil ich wollte es im Grunde genauso scharf sagen wie du. Das Buch hat einen Titel, der irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein bisschen fehl platziert ist, das Ende des Kapitalismus. Ist es das Ende des Kapitalismus? Nein. Die Eigentumsfragen bleiben unberührt und Geld bleibt auch vorhanden. Also, und da würde ich sagen, meine Kapitalismusdefinition beginnt bei, wir haben Eigentum und das verbrieft über Geld. Also, wenn wir das vorfinden, haben wir es mit Kapitalismus zu tun. Und dann ist nur noch die Frage, in welcher Art und Weise, in welcher Ausprägung, in welcher Dimension haben wir den politischen Planung innerhalb dieses Gefüges? Und da würde ich nämlich sagen, wenn sie so eine Definition macht von, jetzt erleben wir gerade so einen Turbokapitalismus, in dem wir es irgendwie hinbekommen haben, diese aus dieser organischen Ära der Selbstgenügsamkeit in dieses fossile Zeitalter reinzustolpern. Und dann ganz wichtig bei ihr, diese Finanzierungsfragen. Also wir leihen uns mit Krediten Geld aus der Zukunft, um Öl aus der Vergangenheit, also die Energiereserven aus der Vergangenheit, ins Jetzt zu holen. Also wir holen mit dem Geld aus der Zukunft und die, also damit bauen wir die Löcher und holen dann die Energiequellen, das CO2 aus der Vergangenheit alles ins Jetzt. Und da finde ich, das Bild ist irgendwie ganz schön. Macht zum Beispiel alles Mögliche auf, was man so diskutieren könnte, wie wo kommt denn das Geld her? Ach ja, BlackRock, die haben ja so Briefe geschrieben. Ach ja, die hatten ja schon so Pläne wie 25 Prozent Umsatz bei Unternehmen mit Kohle. Dann fliegt er bei uns aus dem Index. Also dann finanzieren wir das nicht mehr. Wo ja das eigentlich in Nuancen schon so eingearbeitet wurde, was politisch planbar ist, sogar wenn noch nicht mal die Politik selbst plant, sondern nur die Unternehmen. Weil, wie wir damals sagten, BlackRock gerne auch in 30 Jahren noch was zu investieren hätte, statt einfach nur verbrannte Erde. Und da finde ich diesen Anspruch, das Ende des Kapitalismus. Und dann schlägt man so auf und denkt sich, nee, es wäre eigentlich klüger gewesen, wenn das so eine Anlage gewesen wäre von Diffetspezifikationen im Kapitalismus, die zu seiner Selbstzerstörung führen, es sei denn, wir greifen politisch ein oder sowas. Also sozusagen mit etwas nuansierter reinzugehen als jetzt das Ende des Kapitalismus, wo völlig unklar ist, was heißt das Ende, was heißt der Kapitalismus. Und an solchen Sachen verliert mich so ein Buch. Und hat es dann auch schwer, mich wieder zurückzuholen. Also da ist dann einfach, wenn es im Titel schon so losgeht, wird es dann schwer, insbesondere wenn dann diese englische Wirtschaft, in dem Falle noch diese Industrialisierungswirtschaft vorgestellt würde, in der natürlich andere Arten von Externalisierung drinstecken. Denn, wie sie schreibt, die Zahl der Einwohner stieg zwar durch die Entwicklung, wie sie halt waren in England, man ist zum Imperium aufgestiegen, der Durchschnittslohn aber auch. Und da fragt man sich, naja, dieses Argument, zuerst kam der Wohlstand und dann die Industrialisierung, erstmal wollten die Leute Sachen kaufen und dann wurden sie für sie hergestellt. Das geht natürlich wirklich nur, wenn man in der ganzen Welt einmal plündern geht. Und Sachen zu verteilen hat. Dann kann man auch noch gerne eine Gönnerkapitalismus-prinzipielle Funktionsweise obendrauf legen. Aber, und das ist ja genau das, was wir jetzt auch erlebt haben.
Mit den Preisdeckeln, das können wir uns ja nur leisten, weil wir von den anderen nicht erwarten können, dass die sich das leisten können.
Genau, wir plündern ja die ganze Welt aus und lenken erstmal alle Gasschiffe hier nach Deutschland und so weiter. Und ja, dann gibt es halt eine Diskussion.
Also man muss sich ja nur mal ausmalen, es hätten jetzt nordafrikanische Länder gesagt, ohje, es gibt Krieg, es ist Krieg, die Energiepreise gehen nach oben. Wir werden da jetzt mal mit Hilfen, mit Rettungspaketen unserer Bevölkerung zur Seite stehen, sodass die weiterhin die Energie verbrauchen können und wir kaufen mal den Weltmarkt leer. Also nehmen wir mal an, die nordafrikanischen Länder hätten diese finanzielle Kraft gehabt. Ja, dann wäre hier ausgewesen. Also das funktioniert nur, weil wir ohnehin immer eine Vormachtstellung haben, was sicherlich stimmt, ist und da muss man jetzt auch fair bleiben, dass Ulrike Herrmann einen volkswirtschaftlichen Blick auf die Dinge hat und sie auch immer wieder deutlich macht, Volkswirtschaft ist nicht Betriebswirtschaft, was wir hier auch tun. Nun ist es so, sie hat die These, dass der Kolonialismus nicht entscheidend dazu beigetragen hat, dass die westlichen Industriestaaten so reich geworden sind. Zwar gab es dort Importe, Exporte und ja, da gab es schlimme Unterdrückung. Nichts leugnet sie davon. Aber wenn man die Gesamtbilanz sich anschaut, war es keineswegs so, dass die Länder England, Frankreich, Deutschland durch die Kolonien, die sie unterhielten, reich geworden sind. Im Gegenteil, sie haben zu viel Geld gekostet. So ist eine Schlussfolgerung dann von Ulrike Herrmann. Die Kolonialstaaten sind nicht wegen ihrer Kolonien so reich geworden, sondern trotz ihrer Kolonien. Ähnliches sagt sie auch zum Krieg. Es gibt ja eine sehr vulgäre linke Auffassung zum Krieg. Davon profitieren die Kapitalfraktionen. Sicherlich profitieren einige Rüstungskonzerne erheblich davon, wenn es Krieg gibt. Aber auch schon Eric Hobsbawm hat ja in seiner Geschichte zum ersten Weltkrieg aufgezeigt. Es waren nicht die deutschen Unternehmer, die für den Krieg trommelten. Als der Krieg dann erklärt war, hat man sich patriotisch eingereiht. Aber man hat sehr klar die Kosten eines Krieges gesehen. Das heißt jetzt aber, wir haben volkswirtschaftlich gesprochen, eine Misswirtschaft, wenn wir Kolonien betreiben, wenn wir Krieg führen, aber betriebswirtschaftlich kann es sich natürlich trotzdem für einzelne Unternehmen sehr lohnen, in Kolonien zu investieren, sogar Sklaverei und was weiß ich zu unterstützen. Das heißt, wir haben es im Kapitalismus mit, wir sprechen häufiger am Podcast darüber, mit Partikularinteressen zu tun, die nicht den volkswirtschaftlichen Interessen eines allgemeinen Wohlstands entsprechen. Aber das ist ja etwas, was Karl Marx niemals leugnen würde. Er sagt, ja, das sind ja Widersprüche, die der Kapitalismus stetig produziert. Und deswegen ist es so ein intrikates Unterfangen mit dem Kapitalismus, weil man natürlich, wie Ulrike Herrmann sagen kann, höhere Löhne bedeuten mehr Kaufkraft, also müssten doch eigentlich alle Unternehmer für höhere Löhne sein. Sie sagt ja, wir müssen die Unternehmer vor sich selbst schützen, zu ihrem Glück zwingen. Sie müssen alle höhere Löhne bringen. Das stimmt volkswirtschaftlich kainsianisch betrachtet. Da ist sie ja Kainsianerin in Reinform. Aber trotzdem betriebswirtschaftlich, also wenn ich jetzt ein Unternehmen habe, wenn du ein Unternehmen hast, versucht natürlich jeder, möglichst wenig Löhne zu bezahlen und denkt nicht an das höhere Prinzip in der Volkswirtschaft, weil alles mit Einzelinteressen geregelt ist, weil alles marktwirtschaftlich geregelt ist, weil man keinen Sozialismus hat. Und was bei manchen radikal Kainsianern immer so anklingt, ist, dass sie glauben, man könnte eigentlich eine sozialistische Organisation des Kapitalismus gestalten. Das ist aber nicht möglich. Und dadurch kommt sie dann auch zu sehr zugespitzten Thesen, dass sie dann sagt, Kolonialismus und so, das ist alles gar nicht so wichtig gewesen. Volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet kann man das so sehen als Bilanz, aber es ist zugleich die DNA des Kapitalismus, dass er sich so verhält. Wir können ein Beispiel aus der Gegenwart bringen, nämlich der Bitcoin, die ganzen Kryptowährungen. Volkswirtschaftlich, reiner Blödsinn, die Leute, die all das betreiben, würden sich lieber morgens hinstellen und Brötchen schmieren für die Kinder, die zur Schule gehen. Aber trotzdem ist es im Kapitalismus für die Partikularinteressenten sehr reizvoll, das zu machen, statt Brötchen zu schmieren.
Du hast wieder genannt, was ich auch schon sagen wollte. Diese partikularistische Zersplitterung der Welt, über die wir analytisch, begrifflich einfach sagen können, das ist der Kapitalismus. Aber da kommen wir dann nicht weiter, wenn wir Probleme lösen wollen. Weil, wenn sie dann kommt mit, wir müssen den Kapitalismus abschaffen, kann sie das nur runterbrechen, macht sie auch ganz explizit. Alle Branchen, außer die erneuerbaren Energien, also diejenigen Industrien, die uns eben die Anlagen bauen, die uns mit Energie versorgen, mit grüner Energie, die wachsen, alle anderen müssen schrumpfen. Und da denke ich mir, das ist viel zu radikal gedacht. Wir haben auch bei der Verkehrswende, da wollen wir uns das so vorstellen. Volker Wissing hat ja gerade große Probleme, seine Verkehrsziele, die eben dann nicht sektorübergreifend verrechnet werden dürfen, sondern er muss selber im Verkehrssektor Klimaziele erreichen. Und er schafft es aber nicht. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass es nicht möglich wäre. Denn man könnte auch, und das ist dann eben, muss man sich dann trauen, die politische Ansage zu machen. Man kann auch einfach sagen, wir reduzieren, also die 400 Brücken in der Autobahn, die sind alle kaputt. Die 4000 Brücken, die in Deutschland repartiert werden, wir lassen sie, weil sie kaputt gehen, da investieren wir nicht rein. Wir bauen nur noch Gleise. Wer von Stuttgart nach Berlin fahren will, muss den Zug nehmen. Die Letzten, die noch meinen, ich muss das mit dem Auto fahren, brauchen dann wirklich ein SUV, weil die Straßen in einem Zustand sind, wo man einfach einen Geländewagen braucht. Nur solche Schiffs sind ja denkbar und damit auch nicht völlig ausgeschlossen. Wir machen es halt aus Gründen, die auch wieder praktikularistischer Natur sind, machen wir es halt einfach nicht, weil die politische Entscheidung anders läuft. Und hier fällt man immer wieder auf dieses Gefüge, Unternehmen machen etwas, nämlich den Kapitalismus partikularistisch runterbrechen, sodass wir das gar nicht mehr verstehen, warum die das machen. Ist doch Quatsch mit diesem Bitcoin, das ist ja meine Zukunftsanlage, meine Altersvorsorge. Man macht doch volkswirtschaftlich gar keinen Sinn, aber man macht es trotzdem, weil da gewisse Werte drinstecken. Das kriegt man einfach nicht zusammen. Und ich falle immer wieder auf dieses Gefüge zurück. Ja, da wo die Übersetzung eines partikularistischen Interesses in eine volkswirtschaftliche Vernunft nicht hinhaut, muss man eben politisch eingreifen. Und dieses politische Eingreifen, Planung ist nicht Planwirtschaft, sondern kann man auch in kapitalistisch verfassten Demokratien einfach mal noch ein bisschen weiter treiben, als wir es bisher gemacht haben. Das findet bei ihr so nicht statt.
Na ja, es findet schon statt, es ist ja viel radikaler. Sie will ja, dass die Politik alles bestimmt. Sie sagt, wir haben zwar noch eine Marktwirtschaft und wir haben auch eine Privatwirtschaft, aber die Politik, so ja der Ausblick, ich würde sagen, wir kommen da erst gleich zu, geht ja dahin, dass man sogar sagt, wir rationieren die Nahrungsmittel und sagen, der erwachsene Mann und die erwachsene Frau brauchen so und so viel Kalorien am Tag. Und da gibt es Zuteilungen. Sie sagt dann, das wurde im Krieg gemacht, das müsste vielleicht nicht ganz so happig sein. Aber es wird schon zugeteilt, wer jetzt gerade neue Klamotten braucht und wie viele Hosen produziert werden müssen. Es geht sicherlich nicht darum, jetzt nur noch so Einheitskleidung oder so zu machen. Aber es ist ein Konzept, das sich hier vorstellt, das weit über das hinausgeht, wenn man jetzt das vergleicht mit so Ideen wie, naja, wir müssten ein bisschen sozialistischer werden und versuchen mal zu überlegen, auf welche Güter können wir verzichten. Sondern es geht hier ganz klar darum, dass die Politik in das Leben der Menschen hineinregiert. Insofern, als sie nicht mehr sagen können, ich habe jetzt 2000 Euro verdient, ich kauf mir davon jetzt fünf Hemden und fahr danach mit meinem Auto in den Urlaub. Oder kaufe damit andere Produkte. Sie sagt ja auch, es kann keine Umverteilung, also kein Shift gehen zu Dienstleistungsgesellschaft komplett oder zu einer Gesellschaft hin, die nur anderes produziert als jetzt, also die zum Beispiel Dienstleistungen anbietet oder die irgendwelche energiearm Dinge produziert und die verkauft. Denn die Leute, die durch diese Wirtschaft wieder Geld verdienen, können dieses Geld wiederum nehmen und investieren, beziehungsweise ausgeben, verkonsumieren für Produkte, die auch wieder viele Emissionen produziert haben. Das heißt, es geht definitiv darum, zu schrumpfen. Und schrumpfen meint, dass weniger vorhanden ist an Geld, also dass der Kuchen kleiner wird, sowohl der Kuchen der Produkte, der Waren, die man kaufen kann, als auch das Geld. Das heißt, wir alle, wir können ja nachher mal reden, wer dann davon betroffen wäre, wir alle hätten weniger zur Verfügung. Sie meint, wir würden dann auf einem Standard etwa sein, wie in der Bundesrepublik 1978.
Wo es ja auch nicht schlecht war, wie sie dann immer in Interviews wieder anfangen. Aber wir schaffen den Kapitalismus ab, ersetzen ihn durch Politik. Der gibt dann, wie in dieser britischen Kriegswirtschaft, einfach Vorgaben, also er teilt Personal zu und fordert Produkte, die aus dem rausfallen. Alles andere wird dann managementmäßig von den Unternehmen selber gemacht. Da würde man doch relativ früh, wie so ein Chinese heute, sich fragen, läuft das noch unter Corona-Politik oder ist das schon Repression? Denn dieser Absolutismus, der dahinter steckt, alle Branchen müssen so reguliert werden, weil sie ja alle bisher im Kapitalismus organisiert waren und Kapitalismus automatisch Klimazerstörung bedeutet. Wir haben ja schon öfter hier so Branchen genannt, wo man sich denkt, ne, also die laufen jetzt nicht unter Klimazerstörung. Die ganzen Dienstleitungsbereiche zum Friseur gehen, beim Bäcker nicht nur das Brot zu kaufen, sondern dann auch drei Stunden gesellig darum zu sitzen. Muss das wirklich alles jetzt politisch rationiert und zugeteilt, als wäre es ein Krieg laufen? Oder sollte man nicht sozusagen mit dieser eine Stufe zurückgehen? Nein, wir schaffen den Kapitalismus mal nicht ab, sondern wir lassen immer mit überprüfen, zerstört eigentlich dieser Teil, den wir meinen, gerade das Klima, ja oder nein. Und der Kapitalismus zerstört nicht in Gänze das Klima. Das sind Fehlspezifikationen, die sich einstellen, weil zu wenig politische Planung und zu viel Profitinteresse, der sich einfach durchsetzen konnte, rücksichtslos stattfand in der Geschichte. Ja, aber damit kann man kein Buch so anlegen, so schreiben und vor allem nicht so betiteln.
Die Argumentation ist ja, dass der Kapitalismus grundsätzlich wachsen muss. Und das ist ja richtig. Also es gibt keinen Kapitalismus, der stagniert, oder einen Kapitalismus, der dauerhaft schrumpfen kann. Man kann mal zwei Jahre eine Rezession haben und kommt da recht gut wieder raus. Aber man kann jetzt nicht sagen, wir schrumpfen im Kapitalismus. Das ist nicht angelegt. Kapitalismus funktioniert nur, wenn er wächst, denn sonst wird nicht investiert. Ich würde ja niemals in ein Geschäft investieren, wenn ich sage, das Schöne ist ja, die schrumpfen ja um zehn Prozent jedes Jahr. Da wäre ich ja irre, wenn ich da mein Geld verbrenne. Also ist Kapitalismus nur mit Wachstum denkbar. Dieses Wirtschaftswachstum ist gekoppelt sehr stark nach wie vor an einen Ressourcenverbrauch. Du hast jetzt natürlich einige Branchen angesprochen, wo es kaum Ressourcenverbrauch und kaum klimaschädliches gibt. Wenngleich man aber sagen muss, das sind Branchen, die nicht besonders relevant sind für die Volkswirtschaft, dass man daran gesehen hat, dass man diese Branchen ja mal schnell dicht gemacht hat. Während der Lockdowns, während die Industrie weiter lief, das heißt Chemie, Stahlproduktion, viele andere Konsumgüter, die produziert werden. Da geht es ressourcenreich zu und da muss man selbstverständlich anders mit umgehen. Und da ist die Frage, wie soll das funktionieren? Also ich finde die Zahlen, die sie da nennt, in denen sie sagt, wie dramatisch die Lage sein wird und wie wenig getan wird, beziehungsweise wie viel getan werden müsste, damit wir in eine Klimaneutralität gelangen. Also was da für Schritte vonnöten wären. Und da geht es ja wirklich nicht darum zu sagen, wir müssen mal irgendeinen neuen Hybrid auf den Markt bringen oder ein bisschen mehr E-Mobilität oder was weiß ich. Und da geht es auch nicht darum, dass man versucht, noch ein bisschen CO2 wieder aus der Luft abzusaugen oder abzuspalten. Sie stellt ja diese verschiedenen Modelle vor. Sie sagt, all diese Dinge gehen nicht weit genug für das, was wir eigentlich erreichen müssen. Also es ist ja ein bisschen so, wie man es jetzt an sich selbst festmacht, wenn man sagte, ich würde gerne drei Kilo abnehmen, dann wird das vielleicht nicht reichen, wenn man den Zucker im Kaffee weglässt, sondern man muss wahrscheinlich auf sehr viel mehr verzichten. Und eigentlich so ein Bild bedient sie ja da. Und da fand ich die Zahlen nochmal sehr erschreckend, auch die sie da aufruft. Denn es ist ja doch... Also, in gewisser Weise könnte man... Also, ich glaube nicht, dass sich die Vision von Ulrike Herrmann, ob ich die jetzt wünschenswert finde oder nicht, finden sie sie nicht wünschenswert, aber ist auch völlig egal. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir diese Kriegswirtschaft bekommen werden. Aber dann stellt sich für mich gleich darauf die Frage, wenn wir die nicht bekommen und wahrscheinlich auch keinen Sozialismus bekommen, dann sind wir doch geliefert.
Wir sind ja auch geliefert. Das ist ja bei der Demografie auch. Man beginnt diese Gespräche immer mit, wir reden jetzt über ein Problem, das wir vielleicht nicht lösen. Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, was das im Alltag so bedeutet. Weil du immer die Zahlen ansprichst. Ich will mal zwei Ausschnitte vorlesen, in denen sie Zahlen nennen, die uns etwas verdeutlichen sollen. Ich lese es ausdrücklich dazu vor nur aus Amüsement. Aber in den vergangenen 25 Jahren haben wir den mehreren Wärmeenergie im Maßstab 3,6 Milliarden Hiroshima-Atombomben zugeführt. Wer weiß, ist das ein Maßstab? Und sie versucht dann in einem zweiten Fall es nochmal zu illustrieren. Deutschland verbraucht momentan gigantische 12.779 petajoule an Energie. Diese Angabe klingt sehr abstrakt, weswegen vielleicht ein kleiner Vergleich hilft. Diese Menge an Energie wird freigesetzt, wenn hierzulande jedes Jahr 13 Asteroiden einschlagen würden, die so groß wie die größte Pyramide in Ägypten wären. Diese Vorstellung mag absurd wirken, lässt aber er ahnen, wie sehr Deutschland auf Energie angewiesen ist.
Ja, mit solchen Formulierungen kann ich auch überhaupt nichts anfangen. Das ist so, wenn du sagst, ja, und wenn man eine Million Bücher übereinander stapelt und damit bis zum Mars kommt, und was weiß ich, wie groß die Pyramiden sind. Das ist natürlich diese journalistische Sehnsucht nach Veranschaulichung, die aber eigentlich es nur noch viel komplizierter macht.
Energie, die freigesetzt wird, wenn ein Asteroid in der Größe einer Pyramide hier in Deutschland einschlägt. Das ist keine Illustration, das erklärt auch nichts. Das ist nur Humbug. Und das Problem ist aber...
Es sei denn, man hätte es gestern Abend noch erlebt, dass da so eine Pyramidengröße...
Sobald es anschaulich vorgeführt wird, ist es eine andere Szenerie, das ist klar, aber wir haben es hier doch mit einem kleinen Erklärungsproblem zu tun. Was ja immer wieder bedeutet, wenn sie jetzt mit 13 Asteoroiden kommt, da würde ich sagen, ja. Es gibt aber eine politische Debatte in Deutschland, die sagt, wir haben das jetzt mal in Sektoren aufgesplittet, die sind auch ein bisschen verrechenbar, aber es gibt erstmal eine politische Verantwortlichkeit, einzusparen. Diese 13 Asteoroiden verteilen sich ja dann. Also ich finde, 13 ist sehr viel handhabbarer als Zahl, als jetzt irgendwas Großes überbordendes, schon Megatonnen irgendwas, keine Ahnung, an CO2. Diese 13 Asteoroiden bezogen, sagen wir mal, auf die großen 6 Sektoren, die man so analytisch jetzt mal aufschließen kann. Ja, Verkehr, Bau, Industrie, PIPA und PO. Das kann man doch alles mal zuteilen und ein bisschen in dieses Partikularistische eintauchen, in diese Segmente uns erklären, was ist denn jetzt usw. Denn wenn wir in Deutschland feststellen, wir leben hier historisch auf sehr großem Fuß, also wir sind für 10% oder so aller Emissionen jemals verantwortlich und wir wollen aber das Klima schützen, dann wissen wir doch, 60% davon entfällt auf Kohle. Und es wäre doch durchaus möglich, und wir waren ja ganz kurz davor, dass die Bundesregierung sagt, wir verzichten jetzt auf russisches Gas und wir kaufen auch nirgendwo anders. Dieser zweite Schritt, der fehlt doch. Wir könnten doch, statt es einfach den Kapitalismus abzuschaffen, sagen, wir schauen uns an, 13 Asteroiden sind 12 zu viel. Und diese 12, die wir vermeiden wollen künftig, ist die Kohleverstromung. Also sagen wir, egal was kommt, und sei es ein Krieg am Rande Europas, wir machen einfach keine Kohleverstromung. Und da ist doch das Problem, dass dann Marco Buschmann bei Anne Willsitz sagt, wir haben doch eine Ausnahmesituation, wir müssen doch jetzt das Klima zerstören, weil wir können doch nicht zulassen, dass die Leute nachts frieren. Und da finde ich, ist das Einfallstor, was man dann machen kann zum Thema Rationierung und Erfahrung aus Weltkriegen oder Wiederaufbaumaßnahmen. Das lesen wir nachher in Frankreich nach dem Krieg. Das lief ja auch, wir haben ja auch in Deutschland nach dem Krieg Wohnungen zugewiesen und so weiter. Die politische Handhabe ging ja sehr weit. Also da fehlt mir so eine gewisse Rigorosität in Spaten, in diesen Segmenten, auf die es wirklich ankommt.
Nur sagt sie ja, dass wir das nur schaffen, wenn wir von dem Konsum runterkommen. Also es ist ja vollkommen logisch, dass wenn wir sagen, wir wachsen weiter und wir haben entsprechende finanzielle Mittel zur Verfügung und verkonsumieren die, dann verbraucht das so und so viel CO2. Wenn man sagt, alle Leute wollen auch mal einmal im Jahr wenigstens eine Flugreise machen, dann sagt Ulrike Herrmann, nein, das ist einfach viel zu viel. Ich hatte eine schöne Debatte mit einem Freund, der sagte, na ja, aber es müsste doch schon so sein, dass jeder Mensch einmal im Jahr fliegen kann. Also so wenigstens einen kurzen Flug. Und dann habe ich gesagt, na ja, die meisten Menschen fliegen nie. Und dann sagt sie auch, 90 Prozent der Menschen steigen kein Flugzeug in der Welt, nur in Deutschland und in westlichen Ländern und natürlich auch in eigenen eigenen Ländern jetzt ist es so, dass geflogen wird. Und das heißt, diese radikalen Einschnitte, die sind ja nicht einfach dadurch wettzumachen, dass man sagt, man geht jetzt da in die Kohleverstromung oder so rein. Also ich finde, lass uns nochmal einen ganz kleinen Schritt zurückgehen, bevor wir jetzt zu diesen konkreten Beispielen kommen, um das nur kurz abzuhören. Also sie geht auf den globalen Süden ein, sagt da ziemlich richtig, finde ich. Das Problem ist, dass diese Staaten kaum die Möglichkeit haben, anfangs Investitionen zu tätigen, wie das in England dann sehr bald möglich war, als die Industrialisierung richtig ins Rollen kam. In Deutschland auch. Man brauchte ja eine Eisenbahn. Und für die Privatwirtschaft ist das zu riskant, das zu machen. Und deswegen dümpeln diese Länder oft sehr da herum und kommen nicht voran. Sie können keine Kredite im Ausland erhalten, weil da keiner das Risiko eingehen will. Und deswegen sind viele Länder in diesem System geradezu verdammt immer schwach zu sein. Es gibt dann aber Ausnahmen. Es gibt zum Beispiel Bangladesch, wo sehr viel sich passiert hat. China hatte das Glück, sich abschotten zu können. Man hat also genügend Volkswirtschaft, mit der man, Binnenwirtschaft, mit der man arbeiten kann. Bei kleineren Ländern ist es so, dass sie in der Falle stecken des Freihandels. Das beschreibt sie sehr richtig. Was könnte man tun? Da sagen ja dann Konservative gerne Bildung hilft. Da sagt sie, Nee, Bildung hilft nur dann, wenn der Staat auch Innovationen investieren, da rein investieren könnte. Also muss es um höhere Löhne gehen. Also ein weltweiter Mindestlohn ist das Entscheidende. Sie kommt auf das Lieferkettengesetz zu sprechen. Solche Initiativen sind wichtig. Genauso wichtig ist es, Steueroasen auszutrocknen, damit nicht gerade eine Steuerflucht aus armen Ländern passiert, beziehungsweise arme Länder zu Steuerparadiesen werden für westliches Geld. Das sind zwei Maßnahmen, das finde ich sehr gut. Dann geht es auf diese Ausbeutung an. Sklaverei war an sich unrentabel, also volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet. Moderne Sklaverei sagt, sie war ein mörderisches Verbrechen, aber sie war ökonomisch nicht zwingend. Ich glaube, dass wir da aus dieser Kontraintuition der Keynesianerinnen einiges rausziehen können. Ich finde das ganz gut, weil man sehr schnell da dabei ist. Kapitalismus, Kolonialismus, alles gerade so zusammen zu rühren. Und dann hat man das. Da finde ich, ist sie differenzierter, wenngleich sie, glaube ich, diese imperiale Macht und das damit verbundene Geldverdienen zum Teil ein bisschen ausblendet. Sie schreibt, alle werden umso reicher, je reicher jeder Einzelne ist. Denn Kapitalismus ist kein Nullsummspiel. Ja, stimmt, volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet. Betriebswirtschaftlich habe ich eben geschildert. Sieht schon anders aus. Und dann geht sie dazu über, dass ein Umsturz nicht nötig ist. Reformen reichen schon. Und dann schildert sie aber uns ein Konzept der Kriegswirtschaft, wo ich sagen würde, ja, das heißt dann nicht Umsturz. Aber als Reformen ist das auch nicht mehr zu bezeichnen. Also hier blendet Herrmann auch die widerstreitenden Interessen aus. Inwieweit es tatsächlich dann zu einigen, sagen wir, Komplikationen im öffentlichen Nahverkehr kommen würde, wenn man das umsetzt. Und dann ist diese Idee, dass wir vom Wachstum loskommen müssen. Sie kritisiert auch die Postwachstumstheoretiker, weil die immer auf den Zinsen rumreiten. Sie will uns aber deutlich machen, dass wir erst einmal erkennen müssen, wenn wir sparen, wenn wir verzichten, dann wird die Volkswirtschaft ärmer. Das ist das Gebot der Stunde. Das bedeutet aber, dass wir dann ärmer werden. Der Kapitalismus, wenn er so weitermacht, dann zerstört er sich selbst. Dann werden wir halt irgendwann nicht mehr irgendwas produzieren können, weil wir die ganze Zeit nur noch Brände löschen. Und wir können aber bei ihr nicht erleben, dass sie versucht mal, uns zu zeigen, was ist denn jetzt mit dem Klimawandel gemeint? Damit habe ich, du hast ja eben schon gesagt, ja, aber was meinen Sie mit Klimaschutz? Sie sagt, wir müssen das und das jetzt in möglichst schnellen Schritten tun, sonst passiert. Und wenn ich aber dann mir ansehe, was sonst passiert, dann sind das zum einen Szenarien, die optimistisch oder pessimistisch sagen, in 30, 40 Jahren wird der Meeresspiegel so und so weit steigen, das und das wird passieren. Und dann sagt sie, ja, auch in 80 Jahren wird Hamburg nicht untergehen, aber was ist in 750 Jahren? Aber dieser Long-Termism, der da drin steckt, der ist doch ein sehr, sehr schwieriger. Also ich glaube, dass man eine Gesellschaft dahin bringen kann, dass sie für die nächste und übernächste Generation, für die Enkelgeneration etwas in den Blick nimmt. Aber dass ich mir jetzt Gedanken mache, was in 750 Jahren mit Hamburg ist, das finde ich ein bisschen eigenartig. Und da frage ich mich, von welcher Art des Klimawandels sprechen wir? Also das wird sich alles weiter verändern. Und man kann aber ja auch ganz schwer Prognosen jetzt für die nächsten 500 Jahre stellen, wie sie auch selbst sagt. Aber deswegen müsste man jetzt auf jeden Fall so viel wie möglich tun, damit es nicht zu diesen platzartigen Regenfällen schon schneller kommt, als wir denken, der Tod der Fichte ist besiegelt. Aber mir ist nicht so ganz klar, was jetzt genau erreicht werden muss, um was zu verhindern.
Wie gesagt, mir auch. Es beginnt bei den Begriffen, die sie wählt. Und es steckt eine gewisse Konzeptlosigkeit hinter. Vielleicht wollte sie noch mal so ein Schockerbuch schreiben. Bei Jungen AI hat sie ja dann auch nochmal den Kapitalismus gelobt. Nachdem Tilo anfing, vielleicht wollte sie sich nicht zu vereinnahmen lassen. Die Frage ist dann, von wem? Von Tilos Fragen oder von ihrem eigenen Buchtitel. Da er dann auch so nicht mehr geheuer war, nachdem er dann so auf dem Markt war plötzlich.
Also es war ja ein sehr eigenartiger Auftritt. Da sagt sie ja, Kapitalismus braucht keine Ausbeutung. Und das ist wieder diese volkswirtschaftliche Denkweise. Höhere Löhne tun alle gut, denn das steigert die Kaufkraft. Ja, aber in einer privatwirtschaftlich organisierten Ökonomie zählt nicht das Volkswirtschaftliche an sich. Die Menschen gehen, die die Unternehmen haben, nicht morgens in den Betrieb und sagen, toll, wir tun was für die Volkswirtschaft, sondern die sagen, wir müssen den Umsatz für dieses Unternehmen steigern. Ich möchte gerne reicher werden, ich möchte gerne mehr verkaufen. Und deswegen achtet man darauf, dass Kosten niedrig sind und Löhne sind Kosten, die man niedrig halten will. Und sie sagt dann, der Ausbeutung muss nicht sein im Kapitalismus, zumal sie da auch fahrlässig mit dem Ausbeutungsbegriff von Marx umgeht. Marx redet nicht von Ausbeutung im Sinne von, da wird jemand aber schlimm behandelt und noch geschlagen bei der Arbeit, Ausbeutung meint, dass der Arbeiter mehr arbeitet, als er ausgezahlt bekommt. Das heißt, er erwirtschaftet in acht Stunden, sagen wir, 200 Euro, bekommt aber nur 150 Euro Lohn. Was passiert mit den anderen 50 Euro? Das ist der Mehrwert, den der Unternehmer bzw. der Kapitalist einbehält. Das ist Ausbeutung. Wenn jemand Manager bei Siemens ist, dann ist er im jetzt ganz orthodox-marxistischen Sinne auch ein Ausgebeuteter, denn er erwirtschaftet mehr als er als Lohn erhält, selbst wenn er drei Millionen im Jahr verdient. Man muss jetzt mit denen nicht allzu viel Mitleid haben. Ich denke, das Schmerzensgeld ist hoch genug. Aber grundsätzlich meint das Ausbeutung bei Marx.
Genau. Ausbeutung muss ausbuchstabiert werden, wie jeder Begriff, gerade wenn man ihn so grundbegrifflich oder titelleitend benutzt. Du hast ja jetzt ihre Zahlen, wenn sie ihre Zahlen nennt. Sie hat ja zum Beispiel bei dem Aufstieg des britischen Empires darauf hingewiesen, England verfeuerte schon billige Kohle, als die Franzosen noch Holz verfeuerten. Und würde man heute den ganzen europäischen Energiebedarf aufgrund von Holz, also fossilen Energien, die noch über der Erde, also die noch nicht als fossile vorliegen, aber wir wissen, was ich meine. Das ist eigentlich eine Frage. Ist Holz jetzt schon regenerativ, weil es nachwächst, oder schon fossil, weil wir es sozusagen verfeuern, ohne dass direkt aus dieser Verfeuerung wieder ein Baum erwächst, auch wenn wir wissen, dass das Kohlenstoffzeug dann schon vom Baum wieder sozusagen eingeatmet und verwertet wird. Aber in dem Moment, wo England billige Kohle verfeuerte, haben die Franzosen Kohle und bitten wir davon nicht abrücken, bräuchten wir heute, um den europäischen Energiebedarf zu decken, die 20-fache Holzmenge, die in Europa gerade steht, oder die Fläche Europas, also selbst das abgeholzte Norddeutschland und so müsste auch bewaldet sein, also exorbitant viel. Wo ich mir wieder denke, okay, wir haben also von Kohle, die fossil gebündelt, wie beim Öl auch, uns sozusagen die Vergangenheit aufschlüsselt. Also wir können heute mehr verbrennen, als gerade aktuell wächst. Und dann haben wir dieses, okay, wir sind selbstgenügsam Kohle, wir beuten die Vergangenheit aus, Kohle und Öl, und dann aktuell oder zukünftig wollen wir es mit regenerativen Energien. Wie sind denn die Perspektiven? Also diese Zahlen nennt sie dann gar nicht. Und das finde ich ziemlich schade, denn wir ja dieses Investitionswunder immer wieder erleben, dass die von Siemens oder wer auch immer, bei Siemens wird es dann gekauft, die Turbinen, in der Nordsee eine Anlage planen, dann dauert das alles drei Jahre Bürokratie und in diesen drei Jahren Bürokratie können sie bei Siemens schon die doppelte Energiemenge zum selben Preis bestellen. Also ein unglaubliches Wachstum. Wir wissen noch nicht genau, wie die nordafrikanischen Länder, wenn sie dann ihren eigenen Energiebedarf über Solar und so weiter machen, was da noch zusätzlich abfällt. Die Kataris und so weiter haben ja da echte Vorstellungen, wie sie das so machen wollen. Und die sagen ja auch nicht, ne, wir haben eigentlich zu wenig Sonne, wir werden diese Hydrolyse, wie ihr das wollt, dann nicht schaffen oder so, sondern die gehen ja da irgendwie all in. Dann hat sie ihr Zahlen zum Rebound-Effekt. 1990 bis 2005 wächst die Weltwirtschaft um das 23-fache und der Rohstoffverbrauch um das 8-fache. Da steckt ja schon drin, dass wir irgendwie effektiver mit Rohstoffen umgegangen sind mit der Zeit, dass wir da so ein paar Synergieneffekte irgendwie genutzt haben und dass wir es offenbar mit so einer bescheuerten Fehlspezifikation zu tun haben, dass der Straßenverkehr in Deutschland zwar immer effektiver hätte werden können, wären nicht die Autos immer schwerer geworden. Und beim Zug ist völlig normal, dass da einfach ein Unternehmen, das in Staatseigentum ist, Siemens eine Vorschrift macht, wie der neue ICE zu sein hat und so weiter. Bei den Autos, was die Leute halt kaufen wollen, wenn sie SUVs kaufen wollen, dürfen sie es halt machen. Das verstehe ich dann nicht. Wir haben doch Länder, die uns vorbildhaft Singapur oder so sagen, du kannst gerne Auto fahren in der Stadt, aber das kostet nicht dreimal so viel, einfach nur Lizenz zum Autofahren wie das Auto selbst. Und zwar als jährliche Kosten. Also es gibt doch unendlich viel Handlungsverboten.
Oder man kann Auflagen machen, wie Autos zu produzieren sind. Du hast es ja gerade angesprochen, bei der Bahn kann ja auch nicht jetzt jemand kommen und sagen, wir machen den Waggon einfach mal drei Meter breiter, dann geht es halt nicht. Und ich hatte ja einmal eine Begegnung ganz kurz mit Habeck, mit anderen Journalisten zusammen, aber ich bin ja kein Journalist. Und dann habe ich, da ging es nämlich auch um diese Preise, und dann habe ich ihn ja mal gefragt, aber warum machen sie denn nicht Auflagen der Automobilindustrie, dass sie einfach keine Autos mehr produziert, die so und so viel verbrauchen. Es ging da wieder um Tempolimit und all das. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, das habe ich denen ja auch schon mal so intern gesagt, wenn so was, da war er noch nicht Wirtschaftsminister, wenn denn so was kommen würde, aber das war für ihn auch gar keine Option. Also es ist interessant, dass Politiker überhaupt nicht daran denken, während wir ja sonst ganz viele Auflagen haben. Zum Beispiel Reinheitsgebote, was da für ein Zigaretten drin sein. Da haben wir ja ganz viele Maßstäbe, auch bei der Autoproduktion, aber da dann nicht. Und da, glaube ich, hat dieses kriegswirtschaftliche Denken auch etwas für sich. Mir ist aber nicht klar, ob ich diesen Zahlen vertrauen kann. Nicht in dem Sinne, dass ich glaube, dass Ulrike Herrmann schwindelt, aber ob es noch andere Zahlen gibt, die auch noch relevant wären. Denn diese Geschichte des Kapitalismus, die sie da erzählt, ist ja eine sehr Keynesianische und sie macht das auch gar nicht so transparent. Es ist also eine sehr ausgesuchte. Jede Geschichte, die man erzählt, ist etwas ausgesuchtes und selektiert. Aber ich weiß nicht, inwieweit die Selektion hier auch dazu führt, dass ich, wie du eben angesprochen hast, einige Faktoren gar nicht berücksichtigt sehe. Sie geht in diesem Kapitel, warum es grünes Wachstum nicht gibt, darauf ein, dass Direct Air Capture, das Sequestrierung, das CO2-Versteinern, dass man CO2 an der norwegischen Küste versenkt, dass man CO2-Filter produziert, dass das zwar mehr oder weniger gut ist, sie stellt das kurz vor, aber sie sagt auch, es ist zu teuer, es ist zu aufwendig, es hilft etwas, es ist gut, dass das probiert wird, aber es wird nicht schnell genug kommen, es wird sich auch nicht schnell genug lohnen. Insofern ist es nicht ratsam, darauf zu setzen. Das Ganze wird nicht ausreichen für das, was wir eigentlich tun müssen. Weiter geht es ja dann mit der Atomenergie. Da müsste man tausende neue Reaktoren in der Welt aufbauen, damit das wirklich funktioniert. Außerdem gibt es die Gefahr des Super-Gauss, das sehen wir ja ähnlich wie sie. Sie sagt dann auch mal, so ein Super-Gau in Deutschland kostet 6 Billionen Euro. Da kann man sich überlegen, ob sich das lohnt. Offenbar. Mini-Reaktoren, also das, was Bill Gates vorschlägt, diese Kraftwerke in der Kiste. Das gab es früher schon mal, sagt sie, also diese Idee. Das hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Was ich jetzt etwas merkwürdig finde, und sie geht da einmal ganz kurz drauf ein, aber kann sich dann selbst auch nicht, kann das Argument gegen sich nicht wirklich entkräften, sie hat oft, wenn es um technische Innovationen gibt, und wir beide sind ja weit weg von unserem Finanzminister, der einfach sagt, wir brauchen Innovation. Wir wissen, dass diese Innovationen politisch gesteuert und auf den Weg gebracht werden müssen. Wir wissen, dass das nicht die Unternehmen aus sich heraus machen, weil die plötzlich die Weltrettung erkannt haben, es sei dann, es wird ein Geschäft draus. Aber was wir ja doch sagen würden, dass man überrascht ist über die Plötzlichkeit, mit der Innovationen auftreten, an die wir nicht gedacht haben. Wir bekommen im Buch gesagt, da gab es den Film Ball Street mit Gordon Gekko, der hat dann noch so ein riesen Apparat in der Hand gehabt, das war das Handy. Und wenn wir sehen, was wir heute mit dem Smartphone machen können, Podcasts aufnehmen und gleichzeitig noch einen Hollywood-Film streamen. Ich weiß von einem Freund, der so mit den ersten Livestreamen von einem Konzert gemacht hat, das war damals bei Rock im Ring online etwas, die saßen in einem Container, der aufgrund der Computer, die da drin waren, so heiß lief, dass draußen der von der Feuerwehr immer wieder abgespritzt werden musste mit Wasser, damit das nicht explodiert alles. Und heute gar kein Problem, Livestream kann man mal schnell mit dem Smartphone machen, und zwar jeder Zuschauer. Das heißt, wir haben eine unglaubliche Rasanz an Fortschritt. Und sie bringt dann immer Beispiele. Na ja, Kraftwerk in der Kiste. Ich bin Gegenatomkraft, will das nur sagen. Aber Kraftwerk in der Kiste, das hatte man früher schon die Idee, hat schon damals nicht geklappt. Und sie bringt ganz oft Beispiele. Man hatte Visionen in das und das wollte man. Und dann wurde das nichts. Dann sagt sie, na ja, es gibt natürlich auch diese Gegenbeispiele. Leute, die glaubten, Computer, das ist nur was für fünf Leute in einem Land interessant, und der Rest braucht keine. Und da hat sich das dann als Gegenteil herausgestellt. Aber woher weiß ich, dass es diesmal so ist, dass das alles, was da versucht wird, technisch nicht sein kann? Oder woher weiß ich, dass nicht eine technische Produktion ganz anders geartet aussehen könnte, wenn man nur mal entsprechend in Forschung investieren könnte? Ich kann das nicht als statthaft ansehen, wenn man sich einfach nur auf Vergangenes beruft und sagt, hatte man damals auch schon mal so eine Idee, hat aber nicht geklappt. Da kann ich bei vielen Dingen sagen, ja, hat man auch nicht gedacht, dass wir mal miteinander hier live einen Podcast aufnehmen, ohne dass da ein Fernsehsender dazwischen geschaltet ist.
Genau. Als die Queen ins Amt kam, das war die erste Fernsehübertragung, die stattfand in England, ihre Krönung. Und was allein für eine Mediengeschichte seitdem und darüber hinaus. Also es sind alles Entwicklungsprozesse, die sie so gar nicht wahrhaben will. Deine Frage ist, ist das alles eigentlich nicht statthaft? Sie kommt ja mit einem einfachen Satz. In der Vergangenheit waren viele Untergangsszenarien tatsächlich falsch, aber diesmal wird der Kapitalismus wirklich enden. Also er wird an eine Grenze stoßen, die sie jetzt sieht. Das hat man auch 1972 damals gesagt, Grenzen des Wachstums usw. Und dann ging es trotzdem immer weiter.
Und Bevölkerungsexplosionen, sie geht ja selbst auf diese Diskurse ein. Und das finde ich erstaunlich, dass sie da nicht reflektierter ist. Ich glaube, dass sie in gewisser Weise absolut recht hat, dass es ziemlich desaströs wird. Und mich haben viele Zahlen hier nochmal schockiert. Ist ja nicht so, dass der Klimawandel für mich jetzt eine neue Info wäre. Aber einiges nochmal so durchgerechnet zu bekommen, wie drastisch manches verlaufen kann, das finde ich dann doch erstaunlich. Nur muss der Kapitalismus nicht dadurch enden. Und da würde ich mal gerne die Perspektive weiten, wenn wir immer nur hier schauen in Deutschland. Und ich bin ja auch der Erste, der brüllt, wenn die Bahn nicht fährt. Wir kennen nur kapitalistisch geführte Länder auf der ganzen Welt. Nordkorea wissen wir nicht so genau, aber alles andere ist kapitalistisch geführt. Wir wissen, dass es dort desaströse Zustände in Krankenhäusern gibt, dass Mobilität eine Katastrophe ist. Wir wissen, dass es da in all diesen Ländern auch sehr Reiche gibt, die sich mit dem großen SUV möglichst noch verpanzert dort bewegen. Wir haben es permanent mit einem, wie ich es nennen möchte, Ruinenkapitalismus zu tun, der auf den Ruinen auch immer noch funktioniert. Nicht volkswirtschaftlich für alle gesehen, aber betriebswirtschaftlich für einige, meist die Mächtigen. Das heißt, es ist überhaupt nicht ausgemacht, dass, wenn all diese Horror-Szenarien, die hier beschrieben werden, tatsächlich eintreten, der Kapitalismus endet. Und das ist eine schlechte Botschaft, die ich jetzt hier habe. Ich lehne es nicht euch zurück, sondern es geht auch ganz ruinös. Es geht auch ganz ruinös, dass Leute noch weniger Geld haben, um irgendwo sich die Wohnung mieten zu können. Noch weniger Geld haben. Wir haben ja jetzt schon solche krassen Erscheinungen. Also ein Altenheim hier in der Nähe, da sind Patienten gestorben. Und die Zimmer sind jetzt renoviert, werden aber nicht besetzt, weil kein Personal da ist. Das heißt, die Warteliste ist extrem lang, weil das ein sehr luxuriöses Haus ist. Und trotzdem können die Leute nicht da einziehen, weil kein Personal da ist. Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass aber immer noch auch Profit gemacht wird. Wir haben damals, als wir über diese Waffensprachen an amerikanischen Schulen Adam Toos gehört, der sagt, na ja, es ist auch zugleich eine Wirtschaft entstanden, die prächtig verdient mit diesen Gefahren durch Amok läuft. Nämlich die Firmen, die die ganzen Schulen jetzt wie Festungen ausstatten. Und die haben gar kein Interesse daran, dass es jetzt eine regressivere Waffenpolitik in Amerika gibt. Das heißt, der Ruinenkapitalismus kann uns drohen. Und da gibt es immer noch viele Profiteure. Wir können sicher sein, die FDP wird sie vertreten. Aber es ist nicht ausgemacht, dass der Kapitalismus sich dadurch aufflügt. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Sie hat ja hier so Segmente drin. Irgendwelche französischen Sozialisten meinten, der Kapitalismus trägt den Krieg in sich wie die Wolke, den Regen. Das Kriegsthema spielt ja bei ihr eine Rolle. Weil zum Beispiel auch dieses Argument drin hängt, ich habe es zu Taiwan schon ein paar Mal genannt, in verschiedenen Podcasts. Was ist eigentlich für China lukrativer? Taiwan langsam aufzukaufen 30 Jahre lang oder einmal eine Kriegsmaschinerie drüber gehen zu lassen. Wir wissen, der ökonomische Ansatz wird der klügere sein, weil dann ist auch am Ende noch was da, was man erobert hat. So wie wir auch alle, was China will ja schon wieder investieren, genau unter diesen, sie greifen uns ökonomisch an, sie wollen die Eigentumstitel haben. Und es gibt in diesem Text ja ein Schlüsselsatz, der uns sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es Schlüssel-Sachbücher wie Schlüssel-Romane gibt, aber ich will es mal vorlesen. Nur eine einzige Branche kann und soll expandieren, die Ökoenergie. Dies wäre aber kein Wachstum, wie wir es bisher kennen, denn es entsteht ein Produkt, das früher umsonst war, menschliches Überleben auf der Erde. Bisher kostete es kein Geld, das wir uns im Freien aufhalten, Ackerbau betreiben oder Süßwasser nutzen können. Künftig sind viele Milliarden nötig, um eine lebensgefährliche Erderwärmung zu verhindern. Was ja nur bedeutet, genau, es sind künftig viele Milliarden nötig. Und was bedeutet das? Wir bleiben natürlich dem Kapitalismus treu und zahlen diese Milliarden. Oder nicht. Der Kapitalismus kann sich abschaffen, wenn wir nicht bereit sind, die Geldströme in dem Kapitalismus so zu lenken, politisch, dass er sich nicht abschafft, dann schafft er sich ab. Das wäre dann auch ein Ende des Kapitalismus. Aber vor dem Ende des Kapitalismus kann man ihr Buch auch als eigentlich Plädoyer verstehen, anhand dieses Satzes. Wir sollten das Geld, das wir als Ordnungsmechanismus haben, mal so benutzen, dass sich der Kapitalismus nicht abschafft, nicht das Ende sich selbst und dann uns mitreißt. Und in der Hinsicht hätte dieses Buch sehr viel klüger angelegt werden können. Vielleicht sogar mit diesem Punkt als Pointe irgendwie. Dass man so das Ende des Kapitalismus und damit das Ende der Welt in den Raum stellt, wenn der Kapitalismus einfach weitermachen darf, was der Kapitalismus macht, ohne dass wir mit Vernunft nochmal eingreifen. Und da bietet sich ja wirklich an, diese britische Kriegswirtschaft zu nennen. Ich werde nachher eine sehr viel bessere, finde ich, Empirie nennen, nämlich diese französische Nachkriegswirtschaft. Aber wir können ja trotzdem noch zum Ende hier ein paar Worte zu dieser britischen Kriegswirtschaft verlieren.
Lass uns noch einen Schritt zuvor tun. Diese Beispiele, die sie noch aufführt, was man benötigen würde, um irgendetwas zu realisieren, die sind ja schon sehr schlagend. Also wir haben zum Beispiel diese Idee Solarpanels in der Wüste in Marokko. Da würde man viel mehr damit erzielen. 80% mehr Energie sammeln als in Berlin. Allerdings, schreibt sie, müsste diese Energie noch nach Deutschland befördert werden. Und das wird schwierig. Eine erste Variante wäre Hochspannungsleistungen zu nutzen. Knapp 10% der Energie würden jedoch unterwegs abhanden kommen, weil sich Strom nicht verlustfrei transportieren lässt.
Das stimmt zum Beispiel nicht. Diese Strecken aus Nordafrika nach Europa sind genauso lang wie mittlerweile die längst schon in Betrieb befindlichen, nämlich so 3.000, 4.000, 5.000 Kilometer in China. Da wird nämlich auch die Küste versorgt vom Landesinneren. Und da haben die Stromtrassen gebaut, die eigentlich keinen Strom mehr verlieren. Die sind unterbrechungsfrei. Da wird einfach nur durchgeleitet. Da kann man auch nichts abzweigen. Wir haben ja immer dieses Bild von, ja, da wird sowas abgezweigt und so. Nee, da gibt es einen Anfang und einen Endpunkt. Das funktioniert wie so eine Pipeline. Und da geht nennenswert nichts verloren. Vor allem nicht 10%. Das sind diese alten Stromnetze, die wir hier in Deutschland so haben. Wenn jetzt hier irgendwie der Frankfurter Flughafen versorgt wird. Aber nicht, man kann über 3.000 Kilometer Strom schicken, der nicht verloren wird. Und wenn man zu viel Strom hat, das ist ja dieser Vorteil, dieser erneuerbaren Energien, da kann man ja erstmal reinbuttern. Dann kann man das ja über diese ganzen Hydrolyse-Vergasungs- und dann auch Compact-LNG-mäßig, dann ist ja fast alles damit möglich.
Nur die Leitungen sind ja auch ein Problem. Zudem würden etwa 100 Leitungen gebraucht, um genügend Strom aus der Sahara nach Deutschland zu befördern. Was wiederum bedeuten würde, dass zwischen Marokko und der Bundesrepublik 750.000 Strommasten nötig wären. Den Transitländern Spanien und Frankreich würden also alle 300 bis 500 Metern 100 Strommasten stehen. Und es ist höchst unwahrscheinlich, dass die beiden Länder bereit wären, ihre Landschaft zu verschandeln, um nur Energie für die Deutschen zu transportieren. Auch die Kosten wären nicht zu verachten. Sie würden bei etwa 1.000 Milliarden Euro liegen. Für die Leitungen und Masten. Die Solarpaneen in Nordafrika wären da noch gar nicht eingerechnet. Ich meine, das sind Summen. Und wir haben jetzt erlebt, wir verschenken nicht mal Impfstoff an die Welt. Wir wollen ja nicht irgendwo noch ein Windrad haben, weil das die Sicht stören könnte. Das ist ja tatsächlich illusorisch zu glauben, dass man da alle 500 Meter oder alle 300 Meter in Spanien Masten aufstellt, die dann bis nach Berlin führen. Also da sind schon viele solche Details, bei denen man sagt, ja, kann das dann gehen? Genauso auch mit dieser Schwierigkeit, dass man nicht richtig den Strom speichern kann oder man bräuchte dann Batterien. Um drei Tage Stromausfall in Tokio aufzufangen, benötigt man 14 Millionen Batterien. Hat selbst Bill Gates dann, glaube ich, den zitiert, ausgerechnet. Wir haben ja da schon es mit ganz krassen Zahlen zu tun. Also das E-Auto, das rechnet sie dann durch. Es fallen ja auch bei der Produktion so und so viele Tonnen Kohlendioxid an, dass man sagen muss, erst nach 200.000 Kilometern rechnet es sich. Ich glaube schon, dass das noch besser werden kann. Aber das sind ja erstmal Zahlen, die einen nicht zum Optimismus führen. Wir lesen hier, dass die Stahlindustrie in Deutschland 12.000 Windräder benötigen würde, damit sie klimaneutral produzieren kann.
Oder 3.000 bessere Windräder. Das ist halt dieser Punkt. Sie nennt einfach diese Zahlen. Die Gesellschaft ist groß.
Ich freue mich an deinem Optimismus, weil wir jahrelang ja hier das zusammen machen müssen. Wenn ich dann immer ganz trübsen bin, kann ich sagen, ja, aber guck mal, da geht ja schon viel mehr mit dem Strom.
Also es ist kein Optimismus. Die Zahlen, die sie nennt, sind groß. Die Zahlen, die wir jetzt nennen, zu dem, was wir kapitalistisch oder wie auch immer in der Modernität schon auf die Beine gestellt haben, ist auch groß. Also das ist nicht, das würde uns, es ist groß, wenn man das so liest, aber es würde uns nicht überfordern. Diese Stromnetze sind ja, wir haben ja ein europäisches Stromnetz. Wenn wir dann andere Quellen, die einfach das Mittelmeer überbrücken, da anschließen und dann das Stromnetz, das wir haben, nachrüsten, ich weiß nicht, wo das uns überfordern soll, weil wir haben es doch schon geschafft, die Stromnetze aufzubauen, Atomkraftwerke da hinzustellen, Kohlekruben zu backern, die irgendwie 50 Kilometer groß sind und so. Das sind doch auch alles gigantische Sachen. Wir haben doch schon gezeigt, dass wir mit großen Herausforderungen kein Problem haben. Wir müssen sie halt nur dann mal angehen.
Was ich jedenfalls nicht glaube, ist, dass es ein Einsehen bei der Bevölkerung gibt. Ich fand auch nochmal sehr interessant die Zahlen zu den Niederlanden. Da sagt man ja, Amsterdam, das ist die Fahrradstadt. Und da sagt sie, die Leute fahren eigentlich nicht weniger Auto. Die gehen nur weniger zu Fuß. Die fahren das mit dem Fahrrad. Und dann hat sie auch eine Zahl, und die wird ja stimmen. Die Niederländer legten 1994 rund 127 Milliarden Kilometer mit dem PKW zurück. 2017 waren es 139 Milliarden. Das heißt, man hat es nochmal gesteigert, obwohl man jetzt so viele Fahrradwege und all das gebaut hat. Man hat die Fahrradstätte durch. Das ist auch meine Erfahrung, wenn ich mit dem Auto unterwegs bin. Und ich glaube, dass du absolut recht hast mit den Möglichkeiten, die ungenutzt sind und die Ulrike Herrmann auch nicht so erkennen will, dass ich aber zugleich sehr pessimistisch bin, wenn ich daran denke, wer soll es denn umsetzen, wenn wir selbst so kleine Sachen wie ein 9-Euro-Ticket oder so nicht richtig in die Pötte bekommen. Und das ist aber dann auch wiederum das Problem dieses Buchs, das eigentlich so ein apokalyptisches Szenario heraufbeschworen wird. Und dann die Alternative heißt dann Kriegswirtschaft, die für mich auch ziemlich apokalyptisch, ehrlich gesagt, klingt. Und es wird aber nicht eigentlich so ein Handlungsfaden der Politik gegeben oder die Politik unter Druck gesetzt, sondern man kann das lesen, wie man vielleicht damals Bevölkerungsexplosionen oder so etwas gelesen hat. Dann ist man mal ein bisschen wohlig gegruselt. Aber es führt nicht dazu, dass es die Politik unter Druck setzt, sondern man wird ja ganz klar wissen in Berlin, diese Kriegswirtschaft bekommen wir schon nicht. Und dann wursteln wir weiter. Also das Weiterwursteln, das wird das politische Agieren für dieses und auch für das nächste Jahrzehnt so kühnbinnig sein. Und was dieses Buch nicht unternimmt, ist genau solche Dinge, die du da ansprichst, einmal kühn durchzubuchstabieren, was denn sein könnte. Also das Buch zeigt an ganz vielen Stellen, auf was nicht möglich ist. Oder sagt dann so generelle Dinge wie, ja, die grüne Wirtschaft soll wachsen. Aber Ulrike Herrmann war ja noch eine, die sich gegen das 9-Euro-Ticket stellte, weil sie dann glaubte, das sei Gießkannenpolitik. Und das würde am Ende dann auch den Leuten zugutekommen, die sich aber ein teures Ticket leisten könnten, wo man nicht mal sagt, wäre das nicht mal ein großer Mentalitätswechsel, dass die Menschen ihre Bussen und Bahnen einfach als unsgehörig ansehen und sagen, ist doch toll, dass wir uns sofort bewegen können, dass wir jetzt nicht noch wieder auf irgendwas Privatwirtschaftlich zurück müssen. Ich hatte ja auch gerade, als wir in den Meistersingern waren in Frankfurt, das Ergebnis, das mir in der Hotelrezeption gesagt wurde, fahren Sie nicht mit dem Taxi, es hat keinen Zweck, Sie kommen hier nicht weg. Sie kommen so nicht zur Oper, auch wenn es nur zehn Minuten sind. Eigentlich gehen Sie da an die Oper, dann sage ich auf meinem Ticket, ach, das ist ja auch inklusive, wunderbar, ich fahre da gerade hin und bin da. Das sind die Momente, wo man sagt, okay, das ist tatsächlich die Alternative. Und wenn man dann selbst solche kleinen Schritte, dass da Ulrike Herrmann in Talkshows sitzt und dagegen wettert und auch sonst immer sehr dabei ist, Vorsicht vor der Gießkanne zu rufen, da muss man doch mal fragen, wenn wir wirklich die Transformation wollen hin zu grüneren Energien, dann brauchen wir die ganz große Gießkanne. Da können wir jetzt nicht darauf achten, ob da irgendjemand, der vielleicht auch die 20 Euro hätte, sich dann ein Gratisticket nimmt. Und das ist diese Kleinlichkeit, also zum einen ein riesengroßes apokalyptisches Szenario und dann aber wieder so ein ganz kleinliches Denken, was alles nicht geht.
Genau, es passt einfach nicht zusammen. Und da erkennt man aber auch in dem Moment, wo sie die Gießkanne ablehnt, weil dann plötzlich die partikularen Leistungsfähigkeiten nicht beachtet werden und man könnte ja da auch höhere Preise nehmen. Preise, Preise, Preise, Preislogik muss gelten. Dann sieht man ja, sie selber muss den Kapitalismus mal aus ihrem Kopf ein bisschen runter dimmen und einfach anerkennen, dass wir es hier mit einer, wie soll man sagen, Ordnungs, mit so einem Ordnungsprinzip zu tun haben. Wir wollen, dass Leute Mobilität haben. Dann sollen sie Mobilität haben. Alles andere kann man dann kapitalistisch lösen. Also wenn jemand im Restaurant und so weiter das bessere Essen haben will, dann gerne Preislogik. Aber wir müssen den Kapitalismus nicht abschaffen, nur weil wir Mobilität brauchen. Das kann man noch alles gemeinsam machen. Sie ist Wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin so weit, dass sie ihr richtiger Hintergrund ist. Aber wenn man sich ihre Publikationsgeschichte anschaut, ist sie ein bisschen zu verengt auf das Geld als Medium. Und so eine Rolle spielen könnte, dass man sich anschaut, worum es eigentlich geht. Das findet da nicht so richtig statt. Das finde ich immer wieder erfrischend bei Marcel Fratscher oder so. Der zwar auch hardcore marktwirtschaftlich, wie funktioniert Ökonomie? Aber dann kann er immer abstrahieren, was ist eigentlich der Sinn von dem ganzen Kram? Und da zieht er dann auch seine politischen Argumentationen her. Und da käme dann so ein Gies-Kann-Argument nicht vor, sondern er schaut sich dann ganz genau an, wer profitiert denn, wenn welche Steuern wie verändert werden? Und dann kann er eben genau sagen, was der Unterschied zwischen einer Mehrwertsteuerveränderung ist und einer Einkommenssteuerveränderung ist. Und dass die einen eben allen zugutekommt, insbesondere denen, die relativ viel mehr Geld ausgeben im Supermarkt zu dem, was ihnen zur Verfügung haben. Und die anderen profitieren halt, wenn man bei der Einkommenssteuer irgendwie entlastet. Und dann weiß man auch genau, wo die Politik dazu verorten ist. Und das findet hier bei ihr nicht statt, wenn man da einfach nur drüberfliegt und sagt, das ist Ende des Kapitalismus. Dann sind alle Nuancen, auf die es ankommt, jede politische Debatte, jede Anschlussfähigkeit ist dann verloren gegangen.
Kommen wir doch jetzt mal zu dem Höhepunkt, der uns ja von Anfang an diesem Buch versprochen wird, die Kriegswirtschaft. Sie geht ja vorher auf diese ganzen Postwachstums, Kreislaufwirtschaftsmodelle ein und sagt, ja, das ungelöste Problem ist allein, wie sich eine solche ökologische Kreislaufwirtschaft erreichen lässt, ohne unterwegs eine Wirtschaftskrise zu provozieren, die die Bevölkerung in Panik versetzt und einen Diktator an die Macht bringt. Das gilt es zu vermeiden. Sozialismus sagt sie einfach, der funktioniert ohnehin nicht. Der hätte in der Vergangenheit nicht funktioniert. Da würde ich auch mal noch gerade einwerfen wollen, der real existierende Sozialismus war kein richtiger Sozialismus, bzw. hat dieser Sozialismus tatsächlich auch nicht funktioniert. Das kann man so sagen. Nur gibt es ja durchaus sozialistische Modelle, die die Marktwirtschaft nicht völlig rausnehmen. Also das ist ja Unsinn, wenn man sich da immer nur so einen Staat geführt von Mao vorstellt. Sondern natürlich gibt es auch da Ansätze, wie marktwirtschaftliches erhalten bleibt. Also Markt und Sozialismus schließen sich nicht notwendig aus. Aber lassen wir das mal dahingestellt. Interessant ist, dass sie die Kriegswirtschaft als etwas Großes beschreibt, was uns jetzt helfen kann. Und sie sagt dann aber schon zugleich, nicht die Kriegswirtschaft der Nordamerikaner, denn die haben zwar auch ein bisschen rationiert, aber die hatten ein immenses Wachstum während des Zweiten Weltkrieges. Das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen die britische Kriegswirtschaft, die hatte ein viel geringeres Wachstum, obwohl man da ja auch dann im Laufe des Krieges auf insgesamt 27 Prozent Wachstum kam. Das wäre ihr zu viel. Sie will ja stärker rationieren, dass wir kein Wachstum bzw. einen Schrumpfen haben. Sie geht dann auf die Kalorienrationierung der britischen Kriegswirtschaft ein, auf Punktesysteme, die man auch einführen könnte. Jetzt bei Möbeln, bei Kleidern. Wie viel darf jemand? Das soll man nicht zu weit treiben. Damals war das sogar so, dass Frauenkleider nicht zu stark verziert sein durften. Nur zwei Taschen, nur fünf Knöpfe. Soweit muss man es nicht treiben, sagt sie dann. Aber doch will sie es schon sehr weit treiben, um dann eigentlich an den Punkt zu kommen, dass wir auch nur noch diese eine Tonne CO2 pro Jahr, wie Sudan, Kambodscha, Pakistan oder Uganda verbrauchen. Herrmann sagt dann, dass die britische Kriegswirtschaft nicht weit genug geht, aber sie sei eine Möglichkeit, um jetzt in die Tat umzusetzen, was dringend vonnötig ist. Und zwar 30 Prozent muss die deutsche Wirtschaftsleistung schrumpfen. Und die Kriegswirtschaft soll den Bürgerkrieg verhindern und soll verhindern, dass irgendein deutscher Trump an die Macht kommt.
Genau. Also sie sagt, minus 30 Prozent allgemeiner Konsum. Dann könnte man sich ja wieder anschauen, wie es denn verteilt bisher. Also 30 Prozent Konsum könnte man auch damit erreichen, indem man nur bei 10 Prozent der Leute überhaupt was wegnimmt.
Genau.
Das macht sie aber in diesen Nuancen nicht.
Um Verteilung wieder nicht. Ich will jetzt auch nicht zu böswillig argumentieren, aber sie ist ja extrem präsent mit diesem Buch, im bürgerlichen Lager sehr präsent. Und ich glaube, man ist sehr präsent im bürgerlichen Lager, wenn man die Umverteilungsfrage lieber mal nicht aufgreift. Man sieht das ja immer, wenn du mitunter im Radio oder auch im Fernsehen bist und über die Alten Republik redest und dann sagst du ja Wohneigentum. Allein wenn du das schon aussprichst, sieht man schon bei den Moderatoren so eine gewisse Panik. Sollen da noch Eigentumswohnungen vielleicht nicht mehr so als Spekulationsobjekt? Also da ist die Sorge sehr groß. Man wird lieber mal darüber diskutieren, wie können wir denn Alt und Jung zusammenbringen, Hand in Hand?
Genau, blendet sich so ein bisschen aus. Diese Kriegswirtschaft verwendet das wahrscheinlich nur aus einem Grund. Die Briten haben es geschafft, ihre Wirtschaft zu behalten. Die Ergebnisse, die Produkte so zu rationieren, dass Produktionskapazität frei wurde für Kriegsmittel. So, angenommen, wir tauschen jetzt den Krieg gegen das Klima. Wir brauchen ja gar keine weiteren Mittel für irgendwas, sondern wir simulieren einen Bedarf, der einschneidend in die eigentliche Produktion reingeht. So, das ist schon mal eine ziemliche gedankliche Übung, das überhaupt so sich vorzustellen, weil sie ja nur die Prinzipien, aber nicht die Gründe, die Ursachen dafür übernehmen möchte, dass die Politik kommt und sagt, liebes Unternehmen, habe jetzt nur noch 70% der Produkte.
Und dann sagen die Unternehmen, ach so, ja dann.
Ja genau, also mir ist das völlig unklar. Ich verstehe so ein bisschen, warum sie das aus so einem historischen, da haben wir das halt mal gesehen, so. Aber sie verschweigt halt so ein bisschen, dass der Staat ja dann trotzdem gesagt, nicht nur 70%, sondern 30% sind jetzt reserviert für Fallschirme, Stichwaffen oder sonstiges. Wir bezahlen euch das ja auch.
Genau, die Wirtschaft ist ja da gewachsen. Man hat denen ja nicht gesagt, wir machen uns jetzt arm, damit die Deutschen den Krieg verlieren, sondern wir machen uns stark, damit die Deutschen den Krieg verlieren. Ganz richtig, ganz richtig. Also, warum Kriegswirtschaft? Sie hat offenbar die Bücher von anderen gründlich gelesen. Zum Beispiel Naomi Klein und Anne Patti vorschlagen auch eine Kriegswirtschaft vor, mit der wir den Green New Deal umsetzen können. Darauf nimmt sie offenbar Bezug, wenn sie jetzt auch mit der britischen Kriegswirtschaft ankommt. Die britische Kriegswirtschaft ist ja gewachsen. Und die britische Kriegswirtschaft war kapitalistisch, mit einem stärker eingreifenden Staat. Wir leben jetzt in Zeiten, wo der Staat wieder stärker eingreift. Das sehen wir ja auch im Zuge des Krieges. Wir haben eine Sanktionspolitik, die der deutschen Wirtschaft schadet. Ganz klar. Also für die deutsche Volkswirtschaft, zunächst einmal zumindest kurzfristig gesehen, wäre natürlich besser, man hätte gar keine Sanktionen. Jetzt hat man aber Sanktionen. Also muss man damit umgehen. Das Kapital in Deutschland trägt das mit, weil man sicherheitspolitischen Interessen hat. Oder weil man auch weiß, würde jetzt Deutschland tatsächlich sagen, wir machen gar keine Sanktionen mit Russland. Dann würden wir anders sanktioniert werden, nämlich von den USA. Die würden dann nämlich sagen, also wenn ihr weiter mit Russland, dann bekommt ihr aber von uns nichts mehr. Das heißt, man ist da in einer politischen Gemengelage und die Unternehmen müssen sich in gewisser Weise unterwerfen. Und die Politik entscheidet sicherheitspolitisch, zum Teil ideologisch stark aufgeladen. Das ist ja in der Vergangenheit immer wieder passiert. Nur die Kriegswirtschaft hat ja etwas ganz Konkretes zum Ziel. Nämlich, wir müssen wehrfähig sein gegenüber Nazi-Deutschland. Wir haben Nazi-Deutschland, wir haben Hitler unterschätzt. Jetzt ist fünf vor zwölf, wir müssen agieren. Sonst werden wir eingenommen und dann gibt es England in dieser Form nicht mehr. Die Bedrohung ist ganz konkret. Das heißt aber auch, diese Bedrohung ist temporär. Die Briten hätten gerne den Krieg sicherlich früher beendet. Aber eine Perspektive von fünf Jahren oder sechs Jahren ist eine andere als eine Perspektive von Klimawandel. Die nächsten hunderte Jahre haben wir dieses Projekt. Man kann keine Kriegswirtschaft für die nächsten 80 Jahre machen. Man kann sagen, wir machen jetzt gerade mal Kriegswirtschaft, weil wir da noch einen Krieg zu gewinnen haben. Wir haben zugleich realpolitisch gesprochen, das ist bei Hitler mit einem ganz konkreten Feindbild zu tun. Kein Brite hätte dann noch gesagt im Zweiten Weltkrieg, das wäre auch ganz gut, ist doch auch eine Alternative. Damit bekommt man sowohl die Unternehmen als auch die Bevölkerung dahingeheicht, dass man eine solche Kriegswirtschaft überhaupt demokratisch vollziehen kann. Das bleibt ja hier vollkommen offen, warum plötzlich die Bürger dazu bereit sein sollten, wenn es schon Widerstand gibt, wenn man nur ein bisschen Bürgergeld erhöht. Also es ist eine schöne Idee, aber eigentlich macht sie doch genau das, was auch diese Kreislaufwirtschaftstheoretiker machen. Man malt sich eine Vision aus, so könnte man es machen. Nur dieser Übergang ist völlig unklar. Und da würde ich auch hinzufügen, ich kann hier auch ein Beispiel ausmachen, wie wir eine sozialistisch marktwirtschaftliche Gesellschaft haben, wo Wohnen genossenschaftlich organisiert ist. Ich weiß nur noch nicht ganz, wie wir dahin kommen, lieber Stefan. Aber ich kann dir das schon mal exakt ausmalen, wie das dann wäre und wie viel Wohnraum du dann in Frankfurt bekommst.
Hätte sie das Buch angelegt als der Anfang der Politik mit dem Argument Kapitalismus schön und gut, ich bin da Experte, ich kann euch das beschreiben, wenn wir den Selbstläufer, das Selbstläuferprinzip weitermachen, schaffen wir uns alle ab. Und hätte sie dann dieses, der Anfang der Politik, wir brauchen jetzt wieder Politik oder die Renaissance der Politik oder wie auch immer, illustriert mit beispielsweise, guckt euch mal an in der britischen Kriegswirtschaft, was politisch alles möglich ist, dann hätte sie diesen Teil betont und nicht so sehr diesen, ja, da wurde eben geschrumpft im Sinne von, ne, die haben einfach nur Kriegswirtschaft ergänzt und mussten halt ein bisschen Kapazität umschichten, aber es waren eben politische Entscheidungen. Dann hätte ich es irgendwie gut gefunden und das wäre dann auch interessant gewesen, man hätte so darüber reden können, dass man sagt, ja stimmt, die Politik kann ganz schön viel machen, während wir gleichzeitig schon wieder habe hören, wie er sagte, also ich habe ja nur vermittelt, die Unternehmen kaufen das Gas in Katar. Das hat mit mir und der Politik nichts zu tun. Wo wir sagen müssen, ne, hast du nicht Ulrike Herrmann gelesen? Du musst das jetzt machen, also es ist jetzt politische Aufgabe, du kannst nicht einfach dein Unternehmen da los schicken, sondern das muss jetzt gemacht werden.
Wir sind jetzt im Zeitalter der Industriepolitik und das bedeutet ja auch, wenn man ein Buch heute schreibt, wir sind nicht mehr in den 40er Jahren. Wir können erstmal das sehr schwer vergleichen, weil Großbritannien das ja nicht im Alleingang machte, sondern hatte sehr viele Partner, die das ähnlich gestaltet haben. Und man hatte ein gemeinsames westliches Ziel. Wir haben nicht dieses gemeinsame Ziel, Bekämpfung des Klimawandels, nur in einer sehr abstrakten Weise, aber nicht so konkret. Und wenn wir uns jetzt die internationale Konkurrenz ansehen, dann ist es ja doch ein bisschen merkwürdig. Ulrike Herrmann, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, ist für Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine und hat da eigentlich so den bürgerlichen Diskurs vertreten. Aus sicherheitspolitischen Gründen, aus Solidarität, was auch immer. Nun stellen wir uns einmal vor, wenn wir dieser Argumentation treu bleiben, man würde wirtschaftlich radikal schrumpfen, wie sie sich das vorstellt. Also die deutsche Industrie wird erheblich geschwächt. Das heißt, wir sind dann ja auch international wenig konkurrenzfähig. In gewisser Weise könnte Putin dann unsere Aktienkonzerne aus seiner Portokasse bezahlen. Also das ist ja eine auch sicherheitspolitisch sehr eigenartige Idee. Und hier kommen wieder volkswirtschaftliche Ideale und betriebswirtschaftliche Bedingtheiten durcheinander. Ja, der Kapitalismus ist ein widersprüchliches System. Und eigentlich könnte es allen besser gehen. Aber nun ja, der Kapitalismus funktioniert anders. Und das kapitalistische Prinzip funktioniert auf Konkurrenzdenken. Also der Konkurrent ist mein Feind. Und die Konkurrenz belebt eigentlich auch gar nicht so das Geschäft, volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet. Klar, aber der Konkurrent ist der entscheidende Akteur im Kapitalismus. Und das bedeutet aber auch, dass sich alle Länder im globalen Kapitalismus in Konkurrenzverhältnissen gegenüberstehen. Das heißt, wenn Deutschland jetzt so ein Programm machen würde, dann würde man Deutschland erheblich schwächen und die anderen Länder würden sagen, toll. Also Frankreich würde sagen, endlich, endlich, mach das mal, damit wir diesmal jetzt, wie Will Beck das in seinem Roman sagt, 2027, die wichtigsten Autorexporteure werden, dass es endlich nicht mehr Deutschland ist. Das heißt, es ist doch sehr, sehr verschroben, wenn man glaubt, man könnte als einzelnes Land das in dieser Weise tun. Dann wäre doch viel besser zu sagen, wie wir das ja in dem Podcast auch immer wieder betonen, wo hat Deutschland eine Verantwortung, wo kann man versuchen, auch dann mit so etwas wie Lieferkettengesetz und internationalen Mindestlöhnen Standards einzuführen, die dann für alle gelten, die dann dafür sorgen, dass es generell klimafreundlicher wird. Aber hier will ich noch eine Frage an dich richten. Kannst du dir mehr als, sagen wir, fünf Prozent, oder sagen wir auch wegen mir, zehn Prozent der Wähler vorstellen, die für eine solche Kriegswirtschaft votieren würden? Denn das wäre ja entscheidend.
Never. Das finden wir ja nicht mal bei den Erstwählern vor. Wenn sich FDP-Unterstützer und Grüne da gegenüber stehen, 50-50 quasi. Das ist einfach völlig absurd. Mir fehlt hier dieser inspirative Kick irgendwie, der geliefert werden muss. Das ist zu appellativ, um es sozusagen, und mir fehlen insbesondere zwei Sachen. Zum einen diese mindestens doch europäische Dimension, in der, wenn man das denken muss, janken muss. Und dann zweitens an diese europäische Dimension angekoppelt. Die Politik, klar, wir kennen die Politik als, wenn die Politik was machen soll, der Befehl. Im Gesetz steht, das ist geboten, das ist verboten. Aber wir haben doch auch dieses dritte Prinzip, der Subventionierung. Insbesondere von Bedeutung, wenn wir, wie heute, ein Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil haben, das sagt, ja, die EU-Kommission darf sich über 750 Milliarden verschulden, weil wir wissen, naja, das ist ja auch, damit wird ja gesteuert. Die geben das Geld ja klug aus, so wie Stephanie Kelten das in ihrem Buch geschrieben hat. Wenn ihr schon Geldschöpfung als politisches Instrument benutzt, dann macht es wenigstens programmatisch klug. Und wir wissen ja, dass die EU-Kommission da schon dran arbeitet, es klug zu machen. Sie werden nur daran gehindert, es wirklich klug einzusetzen, weil der Europäischen Zentralbank alle Mandate verboten sind, außer irgendwas mit Inflation, 2%. Was bedeutet, dieses Geld steht zur Verfügung und wird dann einfach breit im Markt gestreut, weil man einfach nur keine direkte Staatsfinanzierung, sondern wir können halt Anleihen aufkaufen, dann machen wir das halt so. Und wir alle sind dagegen in Deutschland. Merz, Lindner und so, alle schießen da rum. Von Olaf Scholz wissen wir die letzten 4 Jahre im Finanzministerposten hat es auch nicht besser gemacht. Nur angenommen, wir hätten 57 Milliarden jetzt noch mal zur Verfügung oder sogar, wie Adam Tuß sagt, dann Billionen und Billionen und würden sie wirklich für eine programmatisch unterfütterte, ausgestaltete Klimapolitik benutzen, dann könnten wir ja die große Finanzierungsfrage, die sie aufzieht, Kapitalismus ist dieses Finanzierungsprinzip. Man greift schon mal in die Zukunft und sagt, wir investieren jetzt in die und die Richtung. Dann könnte man das ja mit politischer Richtung machen. Und wir haben ja viele Ideen dazu. Dieses ganze Green Financing, wir haben diese Renditeversprechen. Wenn ihr in diese und diese Kategorien investiert, gibt es zwei Prozent extra Rendite, und zwar nicht, weil der Markt das hergibt, sondern weil es euch politisch garantiert wird und so weiter und so fort. Das bietet ja all diese Sicherheit. Und diese moderne, nicht nur Theorie, sondern auch politische Praxis, gerade beispielsweise in Amerika, die machen jetzt komplette Industriepolitik über dieses, wir machen das mit Geld, Geldschöpfungsmechanismen, blendet sie komplett aus, kein Wort dazu. Das wird einfach verschwiegen, als wäre wirklich 1978 das Jahr, an das sie uns zurückbringen will. Und da finde ich, ist das Buch nicht auf der Höhe der Zeit. Also das ist hier für Leute, die noch mal, ja, stimmt, Ulrike Herrmann sagt das auch, was ich auch sage. Also diese 1%-Klasse, die sagt, ich mache lieber gar nichts und habe dafür eine Welt, die bleibt als und so weiter. Für die ist das dann was. Aber ansonsten ist doch hier jetzt nichts Handlungsanweisendes drin. Werden wir den Kapitalismus abschaffen, weil Ulrike, das Herrmann das sagt? Nee, dieses Buch wird vergessen, wie alle Sachbücher irgendwann vergessen werden.
Die Kriegswirtschaft wird nicht kommen. Das ist ein Szenario, dass ich überhaupt nicht sehe. Und glaube auch, dass man mit dem Begriff nur partiell weiterkommen kann, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir rationieren ein bisschen Energie oder lassen manche Dinge nicht mehr zu. Aber so einschneidend, wie es da geschildert wird, wird es nicht kommen. Und dann würde ich auch appellieren, warum soll das dann, wenn das ohnehin so reglementiert und eingeschnürt ist, noch privatwirtschaftlich sein? Dann wäre doch es viel interessanter, über eine sozialistische Alternative nachzudenken, wo es eine freie Entfaltung gibt, wo ich nicht nur Angestellter, Arbeiter bin und muss einen Mehrwert für jemand anderen erwirtschaften. Dann müsste es ja darum gehen, dass man tatsächlich gemeinsam an einem Strang zieht. Es gibt, glaube ich, von Horkheimer diese Aussage, dass im Sozialismus auch er den Aufzug bedienen würde. Also was damit gemeint ist, ist, dass wenn es wirklich ein gesellschaftliches, gemeinschaftliches Projekt ist und es nicht mehr um private Profite geht, dass auch dann Professor Horkheimer bereit wäre, nicht nur intellektuell tätig zu sein, sondern auch gemeinsam mit allen anderen die gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit zu verrichten. Denn eine gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit wird es ja immer geben, die müsste aber nicht der 8-Stunden-Tag wie jetzt sein, sondern die ließe sich vielleicht in 3 Stunden dann realisieren. Und ja, man könnte dann auch in einer solchen Gesellschaft sehr viel Energie einsparen und vieles würde dann nicht mehr möglich sein. Oder das Leben könnte auch sehr viel schöner sein. Aber ich finde, dass die Vorstellung einfach auf den Punkt 1978 zurückzukommen, aber zugleich bleiben die Eigentumsverhältnisse weitestgehend so, wie sie sind, nicht besonders angenehm. Und ich kenne auch niemanden aus meinem ganzen doch sehr weit gefassten Bekanntenkreis, der sagen würde, ja, wir lassen die Verhältnisse an sich unangetastet, aber ich verzichte auf so und so viel Prozent meines Einkommens und auf den Luxus, den ich mir leiste. Mit Luxus meine ich jetzt hier, kauft sich ein Hemd mehr, fährt mal an die Ostsee und so etwas. Und das ist, wo Menschen in dieser Weise verzichten sollen, aber nicht wirklich das Angebot bekommen einer neuen, besseren Gesellschaft. Das ist etwas, was ganz klar in einen radikalen Verteidigungskampf führt und wo sich jeder selbst der nächste ist. Also das ist eine, da gibt es keinen friedlichen Übergang und den Buchstabiert sie ja auch dann hier nicht aus. Das ist ja nur der Wunsch, dass das mit der Kriegswirtschaft gelingen kann. Dann würde ich tatsächlich vorschlagen, über sozialistische Alternativen nachzudenken. Und auch da braucht man jetzt nicht das Buch zu schreiben und so, bitteschön würde der Sozialismus aussehen, sondern man würde einfach mal fragen, was muss eigentlich schrittweise reformiert werden, dahingehend, dass es dieser kapitalistischen Verwertung entzogen wird, zum Beispiel der Wohnraum. Und damit würde auch gleich man den Weg öffnen für eine andere Form des Bauens, nämlich eine Form des Bauens, die nachhaltig ist und die nicht nur auf kurzfristige Spekulationen es abzielt. All diese Dinge sind auch gegeben im Kapitalismus. Auch da sind sehr starke Reformen möglich. Du hast sie jetzt einiges aufgezeigt. Und ich glaube auch, dass man mit... Also sollte es wirklich so sein, dass man sich so radikal einschränken müsste, um das Schlimmste abzuwenden, dann kann ich also hier ganz klar schon sagen, das wird nicht passieren. Also müssen wir uns irgendwas ausdenken, wie wir dann damit zurechtkommen. Aber dieser Illusion kann sich ja nun wirklich niemand hingeben.
Richtig, ich mach das auch nicht.
Ulrike Herrmann legt mit diesem Buch ihre spezielle Geschichte des Kapitalismus vor, die sehr kensianisch geprägt ist. Es ist aber eine Geschichte, die zu dem Punkt gelangt, dass der Kapitalismus enden muss und in eine Kriegswirtschaft überführt werden muss. Allerdings wird die Autorin dann nicht konkret, wie diese Kriegswirtschaft sein sollte. Und dieses Buch hat sehr viele Widersprüche, die nicht aufgelöst werden.
Ja, sie entführt uns nochmal in die Vergangenheit, als es Kriege richtig in Europa gab. Wir wissen aber trotzdem nicht, was meint sie mit dem Ende? Was meint sie mit dem Kapitalismus? Warum kommt ja nicht noch ein bisschen Zukunft vor? Ich bleib ratlos zurück. Ich sehe aber, dass dieses Buch gerne gelesen wird von Menschen, die sich einen radikalen Gedanken ausformuliert wünschen. Diese Ausformierung wird uns auch nicht weiterhelfen. Dieses Buch verschwendet unsere Zeit. Ein kleines Intermezzo zu den Terminen. Also jedes Quartal ein Auftritt am 21.
März.
23. Juni, 26. September und 21. Dezember.
Und jetzt sag uns das bitte noch einmal. Wir machen das hier wie bei den Motto-Zahlen. Oder ich glaube, da wird es noch einmal genannt.
Der 21. März, 23. Juni, 26. September, 21. Dezember.
In der Case in Frankfurt, da gehen knapp 200 Leute rein. Also die Karten sind jetzt auch nicht übermäßig vorhanden, aber für die Salonisten könnte es dann ausreichen. Wir werden sehen, wie groß der Antrag ist. Wir sagen gleich dazu, es gibt einen Saal, der fast 800 Leute, aber wir wollten es ja eigentlich gemütlicher haben. Wir würden ja auch gerne mit den Menschen ins Gespräch kommen, die zu uns vielleicht sogar anreisen. Deswegen wollen wir jetzt mal schauen, dass wir das so hinbekommen. Vielleicht kann man dann noch, wenn das jetzt zu viel wird, noch mal schauen, ob man noch diesen anderen Saal für einen anderen Termin bucht. Aber wir lassen es erst mal alles offen. Ich würde sagen, so ist jedenfalls gegeben, dass viele Interessierte kommen können und Frankfurt ist wie gesagt schon eine sehr sehenswerte Stadt, in der man noch viel mehr erleben kann als uns zwei.
Es lohnt sich immer noch, Frankfurt zu reisen. Also diese vier Termine, sie sind auch im Steady Text noch mal vermerkt. zwanzigersalon.cass.de ist die E-Mail-Adresse. Ihr schickt da einfach eine Mail hin mit, ich hätte gerne Tickets für und dann nehmt das Datum, was ihr möchtet.
Wie schreibt man das? Zwanzigersalon zusammen und als Wort, nicht als zwei?
Ein Wort, zwanzigersalon, nur Buchstaben, zwanzigersalon.cass.de, k-a-e-s. Ihr findet es aber auch schriftlich noch mal im Steady Text. Man sollte sich noch mal vergewissern, wie man es wirklich schreibt, aber um es hier einmal genannt zu haben. Genau, das lief beim letzten Mal ja auch sehr gut mit den E-Mails. Also klar, kann man auch Tickets so klicken.
Ist nur jetzt eine andere Adresse, damit man...
Genau, die reguläre Adresse, die wir auch für diesen Dezember benutzt haben, die ist dann ab Januar auch scharf geschaltet. Also wer jetzt über Zwanziger Salon at Casethe bucht, weiß... Ah ja, das wissen jetzt erst mal nur die Salon-Mitglieder, weil die das ja hier gehört haben im Podcast. Ab Januar kommen dann alle Tickets, die nicht an die Salon-Mitglieder mit gewissen Vorabzugriff weggegangen sind. Das sagt man dann einfach in der Januarausgabe im Podcast.
Wenn da noch welche da sind.
Genau, wenn da noch Tickets da sind. Also in der Hinsicht bucht euch gern solidarisch genau für eine Veranstaltung eure Tickets, nicht alle vier. Es lohnt sich dann.
Aber wir machen keine Kriegswirtschaft.
Wir machen keine Rationierung.
Zwei Mal bekommen wir noch keine Rationierung.
Bucht, was ihr wollt, aber denkt dran, dass viele Interessenten da mit dabei sein wollen. Und in der Hinsicht läuft das alles wie beim letzten Mal beim Ticket. Und das hat ja schon mal gut funktioniert.
Und man kann danach dort auch was trinken. Also es ist tatsächlich nicht einfach eine Veranstaltung, die 120 Minuten dauert und dann sitzt man schon wieder im Zug und fährt nach Hause. Ja, sondern es ist ja auch so, dass der Podcast die Möglichkeit bietet, dass man auf Leute trifft, die vielleicht ähnliche Interessen haben. Das ist ja doch etwas, was nicht so häufig vorkommt, dass man sich mal so irgendwo treffen kann, wo gemeinsame Interessen sind. Das sei denn, man ist bei einer kulturellen Veranstaltung, aber Leute, die sich vielleicht für politische Themen oder für gesellschaftliches, digitales Interesse interessieren, das ist natürlich ein großes Meet and Greet da. Es ist gar nicht so sehr nur primär, wir sind dann live da, sondern auch alle sind da, die grundsätzlichen Interesse vielleicht an einer Debatte oder an Austausch haben.
Richtig. Das gilt insbesondere für die Termine im Juni und September, denn wir sind mit der KS in Nähe der Bergerstraße, die ist in Frankfurt so ein bisschen das Auf- und Abgehviertel, um mal das Ausgehviertel so zu nennen, denn die hatten eine gewisse Steigung. Für Frankfurt ist es eine große Steigung, aber da kann man so ein bisschen flanieren, da gibt es unendlich viele Möglichkeiten, sich da auch Mitternachts noch mal eine Waffel mit 1500 Kalorien reinzuhauen, weil da einfach drei verschiedene Schoko-Soßen drauf sind und so. Ja, sehr gut.
Dann könnt ihr euch dann im Salon von Stefan wieder sagen lassen, wie schlecht die Ernährung Bürger ist.
So wird es dann kommen. Genau. Gut. Also, frohes Buchen. Wir sehen uns dann zu den jeweiligen Terminen jeweils.
Ja, Stefan, ich gehe mal in eine andere Stimmlage. Vielleicht könnte es so klingen, wenn ich meinen Onlyfans für Audio anbiete. Zumindest ist das die Vorstellung von Pauline Schmiechen. Sie ist Gründerin von Voyal und das soll ein Onlyfans für Audio sein. Nina Annika Klotz hat in Business Insider diese Gründerin und dieses Projekt vorgestellt. Pauline Schmiechen sagt, ich stehe da voll dazu mit meinem Namen und mit meinem Gesicht und ich will auch nicht hinter irgendwelchen Begriffen wie Sexual Well-Being oder so mich verstecken. Wir machen Audio-Porno mit den größten Pornostars der Welt, Punkt. Es geht darum, dass diejenigen, die schon eine Reichweite im Pornogeschäft haben, jetzt einen Audio-Inhalt anbieten können auf dieser Plattform. Eine Audio-Social-Media-Plattform ist das. Diese Plattform namens Royal verspricht, dass Creators damit direkt ihre Fans adressieren können. Nämlich die Pornostars laden ihre Sprachnachrichten hoch und die Nutzer können dann dafür bezahlen. Bei Unifans ist es ja so, dass vor allem Videos und Fotos hochgeladen werden. Da würde ich aber sagen, da wird man wahrscheinlich auch Audios hochladen können. Mir leuchtet da jetzt noch nicht so ganz ein, warum man nicht solche Audio-Botschaften auch einfach über Unifans machen kann. Also ob man da tatsächlich mit noch mal ein eigenes Publikum abgreift, das nur Audio will und dann aber keine Bilder bekommt, weiß ich nicht. Oder da zusätzlich was abschließt. Die Creators, so verspricht die Kunderin, bekommen 60 Prozent der Einnahmen. Das ist ja nicht viel. Also da ist man ja eigentlich noch, da ist es ja bei Apple angenehm. Die Apple will nur 30 Prozent, sie wollen also 40 Prozent. Und da ist man auch schlechter mit aufgestellt als OnlyFans. Da ist es so, dass OnlyFans 20 Prozent behält und 80 Prozent geht an die Creators. Was wird also da jetzt angeboten? Es ist, sagt sie, zum einen Girlfriend Experience, das also vermittelt wird von diesen Pornostars, ich bin wie deine Freundin und sie richten sich dann nicht nur mit hochsexualisierten Botschaften, sondern auch mit alltäglichen Botschaften an einen, um so eine Art Liebesbeziehung herzustellen. Das erinnert an den Film Her, wo Scarlett Johansson eine solche Girlfriend Experience als KI bietet und ja nur stimmlich dann präsent ist bei dem Single. Aber es geht auch um, wie sie sagt, Jerk-Off-Instructions oder Spicy Stuff, was immer das dann meint. Nun, das Motto ist, wie es euch gefällt. Es heißt dann hier tatsächlich ist die Audio-Porno-Plattform das Ergebnis eines Pivots des ersten Startups von Pauline Schmiechen und ihrem Mitgründer Florian Pontalti. 2020 hatten sie direkt aus der Uni heraus Audienz gegründet, eine Social-Media-App für Audio. Wir haben den Erfolg der neuen Devices gesehen von Apple, Airpods und Smart-Home-Speakern. Klassische Social-Media-Plattformen wie Instagram oder TikTok funktionieren nicht auf diesen Geräten. Zugleich hätten aber noch viele die ganze Zeit Airpods im Ohr. Und die muss man eigentlich bedienen. Sie beziehen sich ja noch auf Clubhouse. Gut, das Ding ist ja vorbei. Sie haben jedenfalls, als sie diese App damals konstruierten, festgestellt, dass das nicht so richtig läuft. Also die Leute wollen dann doch nicht nur Audio hören. Clubhouse hat das gezeigt. Aber es gab ein Thema, das funktioniert hat. Alles, was sich im Kreis Liebe, Sex, Dating aufhielt. Da waren Leute bereit zu bleiben und auch zu zahlen. Generell ist ja diese ganze Sex-Tech-Branche ein Wachstumsmarkt-Statista. So wird hier zitiert, schätzte in einer Studie aus dem Jahr 2017, dass der globale Markt für Sexual Wellness 2022 mehr als 35 Milliarden US-Dollar umsetzen würde. Aber die Autorin dieses Textes wiederum geht davon aus, dass es sehr viel mehr sein wird, da Corona noch mal einen richtigen Schub gegeben hat. Man hat auch schon berühmte Porno-Stars, wohl im Boot, die sich gleich dafür begeistert haben. Sie erzählt dann hier von Janice Griffiths, die sie auf einer Party traf und die dann gleich mit eingestiegen ist. Es geht darum, dass man einen neuen Sexmarkt sich erschließt und dass man glaubt, dass dadurch, dass die Leute so viel Audio konsumieren, zum Beispiel Podcasts, vielleicht auch jetzt gerade eine hohe Affinität dazu entwickelt haben, sich über Audio irgendwie erotisch sexuell betören zu lassen. Eigentlich ist es ja eine Neuauflage von Telefonsex, hat mir auch nie so ganz eingeleuchtet, aber da ist ja jeder Jack anders. Aber naja, man darf gespannt sein, ob das tatsächlich von sich hören machen wird.
Ich würde sagen, dass sind diese Hypes, wo man so weiß, okay, die saßen so zusammen und haben sich überlegt, was könnten wir denn business-mäßig machen. Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, wie das dann noch abläuft, wenn die dann hören, was die Alexa-Division bei Amazon hat jetzt 10 Milliarden Miese eingefahren. Und zack, ist der Kompass wieder umgepolt. Also in der Hinsicht, mal sehen, was daraus wird. Wir kommen zurück zum harten Business, greifen genau die gleiche Fragestellung auf wie Ulrike Herrmann, beantworten sie aber mit Hilfe von Max Krahe, der auf politischeökonomie.com aus dem nie ein Jetzt zur Planung und Umsetzung der Nachhaltigkeitswende schrieb. Und er kommt gleich mit dem, was am Anfang für uns ganz wichtig ist, Planung ist keine Planwirtschaft. Man muss nicht den ganzen Kapitalismus über Bord werfen, um Probleme zu lösen. Es ist verzwickt, aber nicht hoffnungslos, sagt er. Denn unsere Ziele, Treibhausgase Null, Teile der Erde der Natur überlassen, tierische Produitproduktionen reduzieren und Materialnutzung in Kreislaufwirtschaft überführen. Das kann man ja auch einfach mal angehen. Es ergeben sich also politische Fragen zur Aufteilung der Lasten, Anschlussverwendung von Menschen in Bezug auf ihre Arbeit und Finanzierungsfragen. CO2-Speichern und so weiter, er geht die Liste so ein bisschen durch, kommt ungefähr zu dem gleichen Schluss wie Ulrike Herrmann. So richtig, alles schwierig. Er macht es nicht ganz so breit wie sie, aber ich würde mal sagen, wenn man ihn zur Atomkraft fragt, dann wäre das alles das gleiche. Also Atomkraft, CO2-Speichern und so, das wollen wir mal alles ein bisschen ausblenden hier. Und es gibt jetzt nun verschiedene Herangehensweisen. Zum einen so eine Art Deglobalisierung, lokale Entscheidungsfindung, lokale Produktion und so weiter. Also alles wieder so ein bisschen runter dimmen. Das würden aber die Leute nicht akzeptieren, denn damit ginge zu viel Einschnitt in den Wohlstand einher. Kann man den Markt irgendwie noch mal nutzen? Markt als Retter in der Not, Marktlogiken, vielleicht auch durch politisches Eingreifen so steuern, dass man mit Bepreisung, was ja so die Standardoption ist, wie er schreibt, wirklich was hinbekommt. Er kommt auch auf die britische Kriegswirtschaft, kurz zu sprechen, aber nur so ein paar Sätzen, um das einfach abzuhandeln. Preisgestaltung, Gebote, Verbote. Man kann dann noch mal so Liquiditätspräferenzen einprogrammieren, indem man dann Green Finance-mäßig irgendwie so Investitionsleitplanken aufbaut. Aber auch alles nur halb gar. Bleibt also als drittes im Bunde der große Koordinierungsmechanismus. Planung. Planung, das Festlegen wirtschaftlicher Prioritäten durch, also mit Hilfe marktwirtschaftlicher Mittel und Analysen, aber eben politisch normativ einfach entschieden. Das unterscheidet sich von Planwirtschaft dahin, dass es nicht um den Befehl geht, sondern dass politische Pläne sozusagen gemeinschaftlich gefunden und dann noch durchgezogen werden können. Also der Kompromiss im Vergleich zum Befehl in der Planwirtschaft. Es ging ja dann darum, wie schafft man es, Ressourcen zu bündeln, Energie zu erzeugen und zu kanalisieren und Unsicherheiten verringern. Und er kommt jetzt auf den Monetplan 1946 zu sprechen. Innerhalb von zwei Jahren, so die Zielsetzung, sollte die französische Wirtschaft auf das Vorkriegsniveau angehoben werden. Und dann nachüber hinaus hat man nochmal 50 Prozent weitere Planung eingeplant. Also Wirtschaftswachstum eingeplant. Allen voran, Investitionen bekamen Vorrang vorm Konsum. Man sprach dann in der Literatur von French Planning, zum Beispiel Charles Kindleberger hat ein Buch zugeschrieben. Disziplin, Orientierung, Vision, Zuversicht und Hoffnung. Das soll ein Plan alles abdecken. Fokus damals, Elektrizität, Stahl, Kohlebaue, Kohlebergbau, Transport, Zement, Landwirtschaftsmaschinen. Stahle und Kohle war ja dann auch gleich das europäische Gründungs, die Gründungsidee. Die Lektion für heute ist offensichtlich Konzentration auf die fünf Sektoren, also wir haben hier Segmente differenziert von Sektoren, die den Klimawandel, die übermäßige Landnutzung und den Verlust der Artenvielfalt vorantreiben sind Energie, Verkehr, Industrie, Stahl, Zement, Dünger, Kunststoff, Gebäude und Landwirtschaft. Also das finde ich sehr viel detaillierter, wo man dann einfach sagen kann, da gibt es auch nicht ein Rezept, sondern wir brauchen jetzt unterschiedliche Planungsansätze für diese unterschiedlichen Sektoren. Der Prozess der Sektorplanung wurde von einem rund hundertköpfigen Kernstab, der im Kommissariat General du Plaine, war das wahrscheinlich ausgebrochen, geleitet. Dieser Kernstab arbeitete mit einer Reihe sogenannter Modernisierungskommissionen zusammen. Also es gab einen Kern, der geplant hat, der hat sich dann wieder Expertise geholt von außen. In der dann auch Vertreter des Staates, also die Politik und Verwaltung, Arbeitgeber und Gewerkschaften zusammensaßen und gemeinsam die Sektorplanung aufgezogen haben. Und einige sprachen dann später, das war eine der folgenreichsten Schöpfungen von Jean Monnet, nämlich das zu machen. Wir haben ja heute noch diesen Namen zumindest präsent in einigen Stiftungsprofessuren und so. Eigentlich ist das immer so die Gründung Europas und wie man das so alles macht und so. Also von diesem Plan damals Frankreich direkt nach dem Krieg, also ein Jahr nach dem Krieg wieder aufzubauen, da habe ich so noch gar nichts gehört. Heute bräuchten wir also nach diesem Vorbild eine Wendekommission, die dann auch 100 Mitglieder, er meint hier so 10 bis 30 Mitglieder, je nach Sektor zum Thema Fachwissen und zur Durchführbarkeit und Gutachter der Selbstverpflichtungen. Also es ist ja kein Befehl, sondern dass man dann diese Planungsstäbe immer hat. Diejenigen machen den Plan und diejenigen gehören auch zum Gremium, sind aber dafür zuständig zu gucken, wie es denn so läuft, um immer wieder Feedback-Schleifen ins eigentliche Planungsgremium zurück zu schicken. Entscheidend ist also nicht, die perfekten Pläne zu entwickeln, sondern ausreichend gute Pläne rasch zu entwickeln und sie dann regelmäßig an neue Erkenntnisse anzupassen. Ich habe ja einen meiner Lieblingsgrundbegriffe, für die praktische Intelligenz, also nicht nur irgendwas auszutüfteln und dann mal gucken, sondern es sozusagen im laufenden, am offenen Patienten sozusagen zu entwickeln. Indem die Sektorplanung öffentlich und private Investitionen, öffentlichen und privaten Investitionen eine systematische Richtung gibt und ein konkretes Bild unserer Zukunft zeichnet, ermöglicht sie kühne und schnelle Experimente, kohärente und wirksame Maßnahmen, sowie das Überwinden von alten Pfadabhängigkeiten. Genau das, was wir heute brauchen. Und es stimmt, The Daily hatte jetzt noch mal einen Nachtrag zur Klimakonferenz, wo die Bemühungen der aufstrebenden Länder sind, Investitionen in ihre Richtung zu lenken, indem sie nämlich auf private Investitionen zugreifen können, indem sie Garantien für semistaatliche Investitionen wie von der Weltbank oder vom IWF bekommen. Dazu müssen aber die Länder, die diese Institutionen anleiten, nämlich vor allem die europäischen und amerikanischen, diesen Plan mittragen. Und da gab es zwar extra einmal ein 40 statt 20-minütiger The Daily, wo sie das mal aufgezogen haben. Erstens, was das für eine gute Idee ist und zweitens, wie vehement das da auch durchgedrückt wird. Also das sind alles auch Erfahrungen hier aus der Nachkriegszeit. Interessant ist, dass dieses französische Modell in die japanische Industriepolitik übergegangen ist, und zwar als Dauerlösung. Also dieses ganze, wir machen jetzt hier einen Techniksektor auf und dominieren mit Sony die Welt und so. Das ist wie Silicon Valley, da ist einfach die politische Idee kam zuerst und dann hat man das gemacht. Doch während schwache staatliche Kapazitäten eine ernsthafte Herausforderung darstellen, ist das tiefer liegende Problem ein anderes. Wie entsteht der politische Wille für eine rasche geplante Nachhaltigkeitswende? Welche Mehrheit wird dies fordern und gut heißen? Er stellt sich also hier die richtige Frage. Also es ist alles schön und gut. Am Ende muss man den politischen Willen irgendwie wecken. 100 Leute müssen inhaltlich arbeiten, aber 80 Millionen oder 500 Millionen müssen am Ende überzeugt werden. Und die Einschätzung damals war, die französische Planung zeichnete sich nicht durch ihre Zweckstruktur oder Mittel aus, sondern durch ihren Esprit. Man braucht also einen gewissen Gemütszustand, eine gewisse Themesetzung bei Anne Will und vielleicht auch Bundestagswahlen, bei denen es mal um was geht inhaltlich, um sowas zu machen. Das sind sehr gute Hinweise, die wir bekommen. Der Esprit des Plans war, zusammenzuwirken aller wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Kräfte der Nation. Also man hat auch Frankreich nochmal ideell neu begründet nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und strukturell dann auf neue Füße gestellt. Warum gibt es sowas bei uns nicht? Da geht die Länder so ein bisschen durch. Amerika, da scheitert es an der Blutokratie. Also da sind die Partikulareninteressen einfach zu groß. Europa, wir haben ein Problem mit der Energiegrundlage. Frankreich macht Atomstrom, Polen geht immer noch in Kohle und Deutschland macht irgendwas mit Gas. Spanien und Schweden machen erneuerbare Energien. Also da ist sozusagen, da weiß man gar nicht, wo man anfangen soll zu diskutieren, um da irgendwelche Leitplanken einzuschlagen. Er kommt dann nochmal auf den European Green Deal zu sprechen, der eben komplett in die Irre läuft, weil er einfach diese Fundamente da gar nicht legen kann. Wir haben es hier mit einer sozial-ökonomischen Doppeltransformation anzutun, in dem European Green Deal, der viel zu kompliziert ist und die richtigen Fragen zum Thema Reichtum, Emissionen und Macht nicht stellt. Also Reichtum, ökonomische Macht, Macht im Sinne von politischer Handlungsfähigkeit und dann Emissionen. Alle wissen im Grunde, dass die 10% das Klima versauen, aber man kriegt es weder hin, wie ökonomisch einzurenken, noch mit politischer Macht die Ökonomie da entsprechend zu steuern. Also in deren Sicht, es ist illustrativ, sich das historisch nachzulesen, aber wir wissen, dass es sozusagen mehr als inspirativ erstmal nicht sein kann. Allerdings dieser Monetplan damals, und er bringt eben diesen Punkt, der mir vorhin bei Ulrike Herrmann so sehr fehlte. Es setzte alles auf staatlich gelängte Kapitalallokation auf. Es gab gar nicht so viel privates Geld, das dann irgendwie mit Profitinteresse und so weiter sich da lobbymäßig durchpeitschte, sondern nein, der Staat hatte die Hoheit über das Geld und dann wurde einfach den Unternehmen gesagt, was man braucht, was man plant und in welche Richtung es geht. Und dann kam der Esprit, dann haben wir das gemacht. Also in der Ansicht sind wir blank, was das angeht, selbst der European Green Deal, der noch am ehesten in die Richtung geht, bedeutet, unsere Klimapolitik ist festgefahren und dieser Ansatz, sich auf Klimatechnokratie zu verlassen, wird scheitern und dann macht er hier am Ende so einen ganz interessanten Punkt. Seine Hoffnung ist, dass es so einen Mauerfallmoment gibt, dass man bis August, September, Oktober sich so denkt, das ist echt blöd, aber wir machen jetzt mal hier und dann ist plötzlich November und die Mauer ist offen. Und keiner hat es vorher gewusst. Es hat sich so langsam irgendwie von Osten hat es gegen die Mauer gedrückt und dann plötzlich war der Westen überrumpelt davon, dass sie wirklich auf war. Und er sagt dann 2022 ist nicht 89, die Nachhaltigkeitswende ist eine Generationenaufgabe, keine Revolution. Aber angesichts dieser Wechselwirkungen können vergrößtete Stillstände plötzlich zu Kaskaden rasender Aktivität werden. Deswegen ist aufgeben nie eine Option. Deswegen müssen wir das 1,5 Grad Ziel weiterhin fest im Auge behalten. Deswegen haben Proteste direkte Aktionen, der parlamentarische Weg und weitere noch kreativere Ansätze alle ihre Berechtigung. Also auch wenn sich jemand auf der Straße festklebt, heißt das erstmal, ahja, das ist auch nur so ein Puzzlestein in so einem großen Gefüge. Irgendwer füllt einfach weiter das, bis es dann mal überläuft. Denn man weiß nie, welcher Schubs den Kipppunkt letztlich überwindet, mit welchem Stoß aus dem nie ein Jetzt werden kann. Also es ist so diese Hoffnung, die ganz klar markiert ist als, ich weiß, mein Text wird die Welt nicht verändern, aber ich sage nur, es soll mir nicht die Hoffnung aufgeben. Und jetzt kann man ja mal zurückblicken. Wir hatten diese Hitzesommer, wir hatten diese Flut im Ahrtal, irgendwann muss ja mal der Groschen durchrutschen, oder? Also irgendwann ist doch...
Ich lasse das unbeantwortet, Stefan. Das ist dann eine sehr subjektive Sichtweise auf die Dinge.
Ich stelle es nur in die Kopf.
Meine Grundnote ist pessimistischer, wenn gleich ich diesem Ansatz, den du da jetzt gerade vorgestellt hast, zugute halte. Metapolitisch gesprochen, dass es schon eine andere Perspektive ist, wenn man sagt, so haben wir da Europa gegründet, noch mal neu als eigentliches Projekt. Wenn man aber mit Kriegswirtschaft argumentiert, dann ist das ein sehr, sehr düsteres Bild.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Jetzt müssen wir uns zusammenreißen und nicht nur diese fünf Jahre, die ein zweiter Weltkrieg dauert, sondern Jahrzehnte. Ich glaube nicht, dass man damit mit einem solchen Bild langfristig Politik machen kann. Ich sehe das auch bei keiner Partei vertreten. Ich könnte ja nicht mal eine Partei nennen, wo ich sage, die wollen da so in diese Richtung gehen. Das ist deswegen für mich völlig illusorisch. Also dann hatte ich das für wahrscheinlicher, dass wir im Bundestag eine Partei haben, die den Sozialismus einführt, bevor diese Kriegswirtschaft kommt. Das finde ich aber in dieser Weise von der Leyen, dass er ein bisschen mit dem Man on the Moon Projekt probiert, dass man damit eine positive Vision schafft. Denn nur sich einschränken und verzichten, damit das in 750 Jahren Hamburg noch nicht unter Wasser steht, das ist für mich ehrlich gesagt dann keine Perspektive. Also dafür lebe ich nicht.
Genau, ich komme ja auch, wenn ich auf Altenrepublik angesprochen werde, morgen bin ich ja auch wieder im Radio oder am Mittwoch, dann kommt immer so dieses, ja wie und dann sage ich immer, wir brauchen eine Aussöhnung mit dem Alter und mit den Alten oder die Alten mit den Jungen, je nachdem dieses Aussöhnungsargument. Und jetzt, wo du es hier sagst, ja, das ist eben eine Friedenswirtschaft gewesen, mit einer klaren Zielsetzung. Im Grunde brauchen wir auch so einen Friedensvertrag mit der Natur. Das sollten wir eigentlich auf die Buchtitel schreiben. Der Friedensvertrag von uns Menschen mit der Natur oder das Angebot zum Frieden oder irgendwas.
Sonst kriegen wir da direkt wieder zehn Bücher, die wir nicht haben wollen. Bleibt vorsichtig. Wir haben schon Autoren im Kopf, die das schreiben und das wird schlimm.
Der Titel sollte auch nur sozusagen die Distanz zum Text waren, so wie bei Ulrike Herrmann, aber sie hat es unabsichtlich gemacht, dass der Titel ein bisschen vom Buch Abstand genommen hat. So mit einer gewissen Ironie, ja, weil irgendwie so sollte man es machen.
Kommen wir zum Pazifismus. Wer sich zum Pazifismus bekennt, ist in einer Minderheit und wird nicht selten verlacht als Idealist, als Träumer, als derjenige, der offenbar nichts von Realpolitik, von Machtverhältnissen versteht. Olaf Müller ist Philosoph und er weiß natürlich, um all die Anfeindungen, die ein Pazifist bekommt. Aber dennoch ist er Pazifist, wenngleich er auch eingesteht. Es ist gerade besonders schwer, Pazifist zu sein, weil wir einen Krieg vor der Haustür haben. Er geht dann im letzten Kapitel persönlich darauf ein, ich hätte das gar nicht gebraucht, dass er mit einer Polin feiratet ist, dass er 2019 schon einen Artikel geschrieben hat, der fürchtet, dass es wieder Krieg geben wird in Europa. Er hat große Sorge, was Putin da macht. All das hat er ausbuchstabiert. Das heißt, wir haben es hier nicht mit einem Fantasten zu tun, der nun von der Realpolitik überrascht wurde, sondern der schon wahrscheinlich lange vor vielen anderen davor gewarnt hat, dass es dazu kommen könnte. Und dennoch ist er einer, der zum Pazifismus weiterhin steht, aber nicht aus dieser rein idealistischen Weise. Denn er sagt, man kann natürlich sich als schöne Seele retten und sagen, ich bin Pazifist, was immer auch geschehe. Aber dann macht man es sich zu einfach. Dann ist man genauso grundsätzlich dann auch wie die anderen, die immer sofort nach militärischen Erwägungen gehen. Man muss viel mehr den Pazifismus als etwas Pragmatisches verstehen. Und er bezieht sich in seiner ganzen Argumentation auf den amerikanischen Pragmatismus. Das heißt, man kann nicht nur idealistisch den Pazifismus verteidigen, sondern man kann auch ganz pragmatisch fragen, wann ist es sinnvoll, wo gilt es, etwas zu tun? Waffenlieferung ja oder nein? Wenn ja, in welcher Form? Pazifismus bedeutet vor allem eine Arbeit am Frieden, sagt er. Es ist nicht einfach eine Position, auf die man sich zurückziehen kann. Ich habe da nichts zu tun, ich bin ja Pazifist. Sondern es heißt, dass der Pazifist Möglichkeiten entwickeln soll, wie Frieden gewahrt werden kann oder wie er wiederherstellen kann. Und das ist nicht einfach nur zu sagen, ja, verhandelt halt mal, sondern dass man ganz klare Absprachen trifft, was Gefangenenaustausche anbelangt, was die Möglichkeit für die Kriegsparteien gibt, dass sie aus dem Konflikt wieder rauskommen, ohne dass sie dabei ihren Kopf verlieren. All diese Dinge sind Themen, die Pazifisten beschäftigen sollen. Wie ist es denn nun jetzt aber mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg? Denn im Zweiten Weltkrieg können wir ja ganz deutlich sagen, dass da die Alliierten eingeschritten haben, hat dafür gesorgt, dass Hitler seine Macht verloren hat, dass Nazi-Deutschland besiegt wurde. Und er möchte dies als eine Ausnahme, und zwar ist es die allererste Ausnahme, und es ist möglicherweise auch die einzige Ausnahme sehen. Wir haben ja zu Recht einen sehr vorsichtigen Umgang mit solchen Begriffen wie Zivilisationsbruch. Baerbock hat zwar jetzt auch mal an den Mund genommen, was ich nicht gut finde. Wir haben die Einmaligkeit der Nazi-Verbrechen an den Juden. Und er ist sehr dafür, dass wir diese Einmaligkeit auch zunächst einmal als eine solche verstehen. Und dann verstehen wir auch, wie Pazifisten sich im Zweiten Weltkrieg dann anders verhandelt haben, dass man aber nicht jetzt immer anfangen kann, den Zweiten Weltkrieg in Anschlag zu bringen, um irgendeine militärische Intervention zu verteidigen, was ja in den vergangenen 30 Jahren immer geschehen ist. Man hat ja immer quasi argumentiert, da gerade wieder Auschwitz zu verhindern. Er schreibt über Einstein und Bertrand Russell folgendes. Es gibt zwei berühmte Pazifisten, die mit beeindruckender Konsequenz vorgemacht haben, inwiefern es bei der allerersten Ausnahme stehen zu bleiben gilt. Die Martha Asser, Albert Einstein und Bertrand Russell waren zur Zeit des Ersten Weltkrieges erklärte Pazifisten und blieben es angesichts der verheerenden Folgen dieses Krieges jahrelang. Dann kam der Zweite Weltkrieg und sie haben sich mit guten Gründen für den alliierten Krieg gegen Hitler-Deutschland ausgesprochen. In dieser dramatischen historischen Situation, in der das Überleben der Menschlichkeit auf der Kippe stand, da machten beide schweren Herzensen voller Überzeugung eine Ausnahme von ihrem Pazifismus. Sahen sie das als Wiederlegung ihres pazifistischen Gedankenguts? Keineswegs. Es führte sie vielmehr zu dessen Präzisierung. Sie verstanden sich nach Kriegsende weiterhin als Pazifisten, ergriffen wieder und wieder das Wort gegen Korea-Krieg, Hochrüstung, Atomkriegsgefahr. Als Einstein längst gestorben war, protestierte der steinalte Russell noch gegen den Vietnamkrieg. In der Tat gehören beide zur wohl einflussreichsten Handvoll von Pazifisten des vorigen Jahrhunderts. Bei all den anderen Kriegen sind Kriege nicht absolut notwendig. Und das spielt er sehr gut durch. Und er macht das auf einer argumentativ sehr bestechenden Weise. Die Gesinnungsetik, die einfach nur sagt, kein Krieg, die macht es sich zu leicht. Ebenfalls ist aber auch eine Verantwortungsetik viel zu schlicht, die sagt, aber seht her, wir haben jetzt das und das gemacht und damit haben wir das und das verhindert. Denn wir wissen gar nicht, was wir verhindert haben. Das heißt, wir haben es bei all den Fragen des Krieges immer mit ganz großen Unbekannten zu tun. Und er sagt, der Pragmatismus, und deswegen bezieht er sich auf ihn, hat Folgendes erkannt. Fakten sind nicht einfach Fakten, sondern in ganz vielen Diskussionen sind Fakten untrennbar mit Werten verknüpft. Wie wir die Wirklichkeit einschätzen, ist nicht einfach nur eins plus eins gibt zwei, sondern wir legen Werte darauf. Und das können wir in den Diskussionen vergangener Kriege, ob das jetzt gegen Milozovic war, ob das der Irak-Krieg war oder auch jetzt der aktuelle Krieg, immer wieder sehen, dass also die Beschreibung der Fakten selbst auch schon eine Wertung enthält. Das heißt, wir haben immer eine tendenziöse Berichterstattung. Wir kommen auch gar nicht richtig daraus, weil die Verhältnisse so komplex sind. Und hinzu kommt auch, wir können gar nicht antizipieren, was wäre wenn? Wir haben ja jetzt diese ganzen Bußrituale von Politikern erlebt. Wir hätten schon 2014 oder 2018 erkennen müssen. Manche haben so gesagt, ja schon damals als Putin im Bundestag sprach, hätte man erkennen müssen. Ja, was hätte man erkennen müssen? Und was hätte man wann wo verhindert, damit das und das nicht eingetreten wäre? Das ist alles hypothetisch. Das kann man alles durchspielen. Es führt aber nicht weiter, außer dass man immer mehr Tendenzaussagen produziert. Aber das hilft uns nicht weiter. Was Olaf Müller vorschlägt, ist, dass wir zunächst einmal uns von solchen absoluten Äußerungen trennen, dass wir nicht elitär-pazifistisch sind, denn das ist nicht universalisierbar, wie er sagt. Es geht viel mehr darum, dass man versucht, in Komparativen zu denken. Also was wäre friedlicher? Was wäre nicht so kriegerisch? Was wäre nicht so eskalierend? Was wäre für die Bevölkerung annehmbarer? Solche Fragen, wo man also im Komparativ denkt, das ermöglicht politischen Spielraum, ermöglicht auch Spielraum für Verhandlungen von möglichen Kriegsparteien. Wenn man also von diesen absoluten Positionen weggeht, dann hat man schon mal viel mehr Möglichkeiten, sich zu den Dingen zu verhalten. Wir sagen, wir müssen ganz klar sagen, selbst wenn wir es mit einem Angriffskrieg zu tun haben, haben wir auch noch Gefahren jenseits der reinen Definition, Angriffskrieg geht nicht, sondern wir müssen auch sehen, was könnte die Folge unseres Reagierens sein? Und da sagt er, das sei etwas, was überhaupt nicht richtig berücksichtigt wird, was zum Teil einfach ausgeblendet wird. Und ich finde das auch toll, dass ein Philosoph dann in einem Kapitel auch sehr eindringlich gesteht, dass er Angst hat vor einem Atomkrieg und was der bedeuten kann. Und dass diese Angst selbstverständlich auch jetzt seinen Philosophiern prägt, aber dass er doch glaubt, dass er viele Dinge aufgrund dieser Angst noch mal klarer sieht als diejenigen, die einfach über diese Angst sich hinwegtäuschen wollen. Er bringt dann sehr schöne logische Beispiele. Und das ist das Tolle an dem Text. Es ist auch eine Denkübung. Er spricht nämlich über Wenn-Dann-Sätze. Wir haben ganz viele Wenn-Dann-Sätze in der gesamten Kriegsberichterstattung. Wenn wir das machen, macht Putin das. Wenn Putin das erobert hat, wird das geschehen. Nun, er sagt also, wenn das Kluntje-Stück, also das Zuckerstück, in den heißen T geworfen wäre, dann hätte es sich darin aufgelöst. Er sagte, das ist eine Aussage, die man treffen kann. Aber wie ist es mit der Aussage, wenn die Mörderin das Gewehr nicht auf den Butler abgefeuert hätte, dann wäre er nicht kurz darauf an seiner Schussverletzung gestorben? Ja, sicherlich auch eine Aussage, die man treffen kann. Und dann, wenn die Bombe nicht mit Dynamit, sondern mit Zimt gefüllt gewesen wäre, dann wäre sie nicht explodiert. Ja, stimmt auch, das sagt uns die Naturwissenschaft. Aber was ist eigentlich mit so einer Aussage wie, wenn Putins Großmutter Räder gehabt hätte, dann wäre sie ein Omnibus gewesen. Da gehen schon die ganzen Kategorien durcheinander. Welche Wenn-Dann-Sätze können wir eigentlich treffen? Geht er dann weiter dieser Frage nach? Wir können sagen, dass sich ein Stück Zucker auflöst im heißen Tee. Aber können wir wirklich ein naturwissenschaftliches Gesetz dann auch anwenden auf Kriegsverläufe? Nein, können wir nicht. Das heißt, wir sind in einer großen Sphäre des Unwissens. Und dieses Unwissen mag einen frustrieren, aber man sollte erst einmal anerkennen, dass es dieses Unwissen gibt. Und das heißt, auch bei nachträglicher Bewertung gibt es dieses Unwissen. Er kommt auf den Bombenkrieg, auf Dresden zu sprechen, der Alliierten. Da gibt es ja diese große Debatte, inwieweit dieser Bombenkrieg gerechtfertigt war. Hat er den Krieg tatsächlich verkürzt? Hat das am Ende nur viel Leid angerichtet? Und hier auch geht er verschiedene Argumentationen von Gegnern und Befürwortern durch. Und kommt auch da wieder zu dem Punkt, wir wissen so wenig darüber. Wir wissen so wenig über die Alternative Läufe. Wir haben nicht den AB-Test. Das heißt, wo wir in dieser Sphäre des Unwissens sind, da hat der Pazifist, um darum geht es ja eigentlich, ein sehr gutes Argument zur Hand, das nämlich sagt, ja, es scheint dir jetzt die einzig mögliche Antwort zu sein, auch in den Krieg zu ziehen, aber du weißt genauso wenig wie ich, wie die Sache verlaufen wird. Wir hatten das Beispiel von Mark Milley mit dem ersten Weltkrieg. Da hat man auch gedacht, man marschiert schnell durch, das wird rasch mit dem ersten Weltkrieg wieder zusammen sein, das wird sich gar nicht so einem solchen entwickeln, und dann hat man jahrelang Stellungskrieg produziert, Millionen von Toten, weil es auch gar kein Wissen gab über die Art und Weise, wie sich dieser Krieg vorziehen wird. Der Nebel des Kriegs, die Eigendynamik des Krieges, das sind ganz viele Komponenten, die unbekannt sind, und diese Unbekannten, deren ist der Pazifist sich gewahr und sagt deshalb, Vorsicht ist angebracht. Gerade mit Bezug auf einen Atomkrieg. Er bringt ein schönes Beispiel. Eigentlich müssen wir, sagt er, wie Ingenieure denken. Wenn ein Ingenieur ein Atomkraftwerk betreuen soll, dann wird er jeder kleinsten Stelle, wo irgendwo was undicht sein könnte oder etwas nicht ganz sicher ist, nachgehen, damit ja nichts passiert. Wir aber sagen, wir wollen uns nicht von unserer Angst leiten lassen, in diesem Krieg, der Angst vor einem Atomkrieg. Ich glaube, da ist noch viel Spielraum, da können wir ruhig noch ein bisschen provozieren oder was weiß ich machen. Er sagt, das würde man niemals machen, wenn man Ingenieur wäre bei einem Atomkraftwerk.
Ich erinnere mich jetzt, als damals Hendrik Streeck kam mit, es sind ja noch so und so viele Intensivbetten frei, hat er ja auch so einen Spielraum markiert. Und dann hieß es, das ist ja super zynisch, weil wir wollen ja nicht, dass da und so weiter, so viele Leute dann intensivmedizinische, also wenn sozusagen nur der Tod ausgeschlossen ist, als das wollen wir nicht, aber intensivmedizinische Behandlung, Beatmung und so weiter schon. Das ist ja genau das Gleiche wieder. Aber diesmal von den gleichen, mit unterschiedlichen Vorzeichen. Der Atomkrieg ist zu verhindern, aber die Lücke bis dahin ist ja noch zu verknappen. Da ist ja noch Spielraum.
Ja, er bekommt dann von diesen erstmal logischen Erwägungen und den Fragen des Unwissens noch mal zu dem Pragmatismus, der sagt, wir reden nie nur über objektive Fakten, sondern wir haben auch immer eine Wertung da drin. Und wir haben auch immer unseren eigenen Standpunkt, von dem wir draufblicken. Wir erleben eigentlich die Welt als etwas sehr chaotisches. Und dann ordnen wir die schon mal vor. Und da bringt er das Beispiel der Physik. Eigentlich blicken wir zumal hinauf und sehen Chaos. Und dann fangen wir aber an, weil wir nicht einfach Chaos machen können, dass wir schon mal von uns ausgehen, schauen, da ist die Sonne, da ist das Sternenzelt so und so. Und da sehen wir dann durch diese Reduktion, die wir vornehmen, eine Struktur, die aber würde man aus einer ganz anderen Perspektive oder von sehr viel weiter weg draufblicken, sehr viel chaotischer ist, als sie ist. Die Physik muss auch, wenn sie Labortests macht, vor allem wenn sie Experimente macht, dann möchte sie, das ist ja eine Kritik, die auch in den letzten Jahren immer mal wieder laut geworden ist, schöne Experimente durchführen, also die eine gewisse Schönheit, Reinheit, Klarheit haben. Das ist logisch, weil man sonst schwerlich Wissenschaft betreiben kann mit den hässlichen Experimenten, die nur sagen, es ist alles noch viel chaotischer. Das führt aber dazu, dass man Dinge ausblendet. Und er schreibt dann, meine Ansicht nach, steht die Menschheit in Bezug auf Krieg und also mit Blick auf sich selbst zu einem ähnlichen Startpunkt, an einem ähnlichen Startpunkt, wie ganz am Anfang der neuzeitlichen Physik mit Blick auf den Kosmos. Die Physiker haben damals, in der Mitte des vorigen Jahrtausends, mit ihren revolutionären Leitprinzipien einen vertrauensvollen Sprung gewagt. Die im Sprung ausprobierten Werte waren hoch kontrovers, beinahe erschienen sie zu schön, um wahr zu sein. Doch da sie erfolgreich waren und heute in der physikalischen Arbeit von vielen Forschern respektiert werden, ergibt sich zumindest für mich daraus die Hoffnung, dass eines Tages auch die Werte und Leitprinzipien der Pazifisten breitere Anerkennung finden werden als gegenwärtig. Man müsste sie nun endlich einmal ausprobieren und warum nicht bald? Seit Jahrtausenden schlagen einige versprengte Idealisten vor, mit Krieg schon im Denken radikal Schluss zu machen und seit Jahrtausenden traut man sich nicht, ihnen zu folgen. Und er bringt sehr gute Beispiele, wie man anders vorgehen könnte. Er sagte auch, was es heißt, die Kontrolle über ein Geschehen zu verlieren oder gar nicht erst zu gewinnen, dürfte kaum einer so genau wissen, wie die Experimentalphysiker. Wenn es ihnen übel ergeht, werden sie von der Angst vor Kontrollverlust und Kontrollunfähigkeit bis in ihre schlimmsten Albträume verfolgt. Krieg nun ist das krasseste Chaos überhaupt. Daher ist es kein Wunder, dass sich ausgerechnet viele Physiker die chaotischen Gefahren außer Kontrolle geratener Kriege besonders drastisch vor Augen stellen können. Er sagte auch, und das wusste ich gar nicht, meiner Ansicht nach ist es kein Zufall, dass Physiker überdurchschnittlich viele Pazifisten sind. Überdurchschnittlich häufig Pazifisten sind. Der leitet das daraus ab, dass Physiker sehr wohl um diese Komplexität wissen, als auch darum wissen, was passiert, wenn wirklich chaotische Zustände herrschen. Darin sieht er also einen großen Vorteil der Physiker in dieser Denkweise. Das ist etwas, was wir viel zu wenig verstanden haben. Er sagt auch, dass das Wort Atomkrieg heute so leichtfertig über die Lippen geht, dass wir uns aber eigentlich bewusst machen müssen, was das bedeutet, wenn wir eine solche Eskalation zulassen. Und hier ist die einzige Möglichkeit, mit pragmatischem Verstand alle Mittel, aber wirklich alle Mittel einmal auszuschöpfen, die es gibt, die jenseits kriegerischer Mittel liegen. Und das ist etwas, was aber tatsächlich eine extrem marginale Position hat. Er sagt, die Angst ist ein willkommener Ratgeber bei dieser Untersuchung. Aber man soll auch verstehen, dass die Angst nicht der Anführer des Ganzen sein soll. Nach allem, was wir über zum Beispiel Putin wissen und nicht wissen, passt ihre gegenwärtige Präsenz auf stimmige Weise zu dem pazifistischen Leitprinzip. Demzufolge wir unseren Blick für die unkontrollierbaren, irreversiblen Nebenfolgen militärischer Handlungen schärfen sollen. Wie ich eben hervorgehoben habe. Sie passt sie auch zu unserer gegenwärtigen Schwäche im Wissen über Putin, sein Umfeld und die dort wirkenden Triebkräfte, Beweggründe, Psychosen. Es ist keine Schande, eine solche Wissensschwäche zuzugeben. Wir lernen hier aus der Naturwissenschaft die Anerkennung von Wissensschwächen und den pragmatischen Umgang damit, das Experimentieren und die Furcht davor, dass man die Kontrolle verdienen kann. Es ist ein sehr origineller, nicht idealistischer, pazifistischer Ansatz, der hier vertreten wird und der mehr Gehör finden sollte.
Müssen wir deswegen auch diesen Aspekt mit reinnehmen in die Biografie Angela Merkels, die als Physikerin, obwohl 2001 schon ersichtlich war, als sie noch gar nicht Kanzlerin war, was in dem Putin steckt, ihn gezähmt zu haben mit pragmatischer Herangehensweise, Energiepartnerschaft, bis zur Teilenabhängigkeit?
Möglicherweise. Ich finde solche Psychologisierungen immer ein bisschen unsinnig. Aber wenn mir eine gefallen würde, dann wahrscheinlich tatsächlich noch die, weil er ja gerne immer gesagt hat, sie ist ja Physikerin, dass es ein großes Unwissen auch gibt über das, was geschehen wird. Und das haben ja auch die großen Strategen der NATO eingestanden, dass sie so nicht damit gerechnet haben. Und viele, die dachten, Putin gewinnt den Krieg sehr schnell, rudern auch zurück. Und wiederum andere haben plötzlich alles an Friedensethik hinter sich gelassen, weil sie jetzt im Moment glauben, dass das gerade das Richtige ist. Und da scheint mir doch ein Ansatz, der zunächst einmal sagt, wir wissen gar nicht so viel über die Zukunft, wie sie sich entwickeln wird. Es ist nicht ein naturwissenschaftliches Gesetz, das sich vollzieht. Da löst sich nichts auf, wenn man was reinwirft in den Tee, sondern das kann auch ganz anders kommen, dass aus dieser Haltung heraus ein anderes friedenspolitisches Denken möglich ist und auch handeln.
Sehr gut, bleiben wir bei Krieg und Frieden, wechseln aber innerhalb eines Landes. Und zwar, ich vergewissere mich nochmal, es ist die Seite 4 der Zeit mit dem Titelthema Die Proteste in China. Man hat eine ganze Seite, wobei die obere Hälfte nur einem Bild gewidmet ist, nämlich wie die jungen Chinesen einfach weißes Papier in die Kamera halten. Das kennen wir ja auch aus den Protesten in Russland, dass man dann die Botschaft, klar, wir demonstrieren halt und so, aber wir machen uns hier erst mal nicht explizit innerlich angreifbar. Und über den Text von Xi Fan Yang, die also China-Korrespondentin ist, steht mehr als nur Papier. Was lernen wir oder wohin führen diese Proteste? Und sie beschreibt am Anfang eine Szene von diesem Wochenende bei einer Demonstration oder bei dem Wochenende, bei dem sie dann anwesend war, letzten Donnerstag gewesen. Ein Mann legt seine Maske ab und brüllt, wir sind Chinesen und Chinesen sind auch Menschen, sind individuell wie alle Menschen, haben das Recht auf Würde, wir wollen nicht, dass die nächste Generation unser grausames Leben führen muss. Hier hören wir schon, oh, das geht nicht nur in diesem Text einstieg, sondern wahrscheinlich auch bei den Protesten um ein bisschen mehr als nur Corona, wenn hier schon die junge, nachkommende Generation nochmal für sie die Anwaltschaft mit übernommen wird. Wir wollen einen Rechtsstaat, wir wollen Demokratie. Und in diesem Moment, wo jemand so seine Maske abnimmt und anfängt zu brüllen, ist für alle klar, insbesondere für ihn, du bist jetzt auf dem Kieker, also du bist jetzt bekannt, du wurdest sofort gefilmt, fotografiert und jeder weiß, wer du bist. Dennoch sind das mittlerweile Demos, bei denen in dem Fall ungefähr 2000 Leute da waren. Und die entwickeln sich immer wieder aus diesen Trauertreffen, die es so gibt, weil in Urumqi, einer Stadt in Jingjiang, also Jingjiang, dieser sowieso schon mit den ganzen Uiguren und so komplizierten politischen Region, da ist ja ein Haus ausgebrannt und war so zu gegittert und Corona-Lockdown, also die Leute kamen nicht raus, die Opfer und die Feuerwehr kamen nicht rein. Also gab es da die zehn Todesfälle, um die man jetzt trauert. Und selbst in Peking ist es mittlerweile so, dass es die Proteste gibt, aber, und das ist dann Beobachtung der Korrespondentin, sie weiß, wo die Proteste stattfinden, geht dahin und sieht, ah ja, da war die Polizei mal wieder früher da als die Demonstranten selbst, weil da wird alles mitgelesen. Hier ist man also, man weiß Bescheid sozusagen, trotzdem dieses, also das vorletzte Wochenende, Proteste in 80 Universitäten und bekannt aus sechs Metropolen im ganzen Land. Also es gibt jetzt Proteste trotz dieser ganzen Repressionen, die das ja eigentlich verhindern sollen. Und wohin das jetzt führt, ist unklar, aber sie kommt noch mal auf diesen Ursprung zu sprechen. Am 13. Oktober, also kurz vorm Parteikongress, auf dem sich Chee dann für Lebenszeit da bekannt gibt, ist ein Mann auf einer Brücke in Peking, in einem Stadtteil, keine Ahnung, wie wichtig das ist, aber es ist halt so in Peking, neben dieser Uni, in der 89 schon die Proteste losgingen, also symbolisch aufgeladener Ort. Er gilt heute als der Brückenmann, der nämlich dort sein Widerstandsmanifest einfach, keine Ahnung, anbringt oder wie auch immer, so auch auf weißem Grund. Da sind Banner, wie sie schreibt. Da steht dann drauf, wir wollen keine PCR-Tests mehr, wir wollen Freiheit. Wir wollen keinen Führer mehr, wir wollen freie Wahlen. Sei kein Sklave, sei ein Bürger. Studenten streikt, Arbeiter streikt. Entfernt den Diktator und Landesdieb Chi Ching-Ping. Also es ist auch hier schon vorm Kongress, als wir immer noch geredet haben, ist das jetzt Corona? Naja, wir wollen keinen PCR-Test, ja, aber dieses Manifest, dieses kleine Ende, der halt auch mit dem Landesdieben und Diktator, gegen den man sich wendet. Diese Aktion dauerte damals 45 Minuten, wurde also sehr schnell wieder eingefangen, wurde aber trotzdem dann bekannt. Sie beschreibt dann so, wie sie dann in der Nähe in diese Läden ging und die Leute fragte, was habt ihr da gesehen? Die so, ich hab nichts gesehen. Also da hat man auch gemerkt, okay, es gibt halt die allgemeine Bevölkerung, die dann einfach von nichts gesehen hat. Und diese Demos für Orumqui oder in Orumqui gibt sie auch. Da zieht man zur Stadtverwaltung und singt dann die chinesische Hymne, die nämlich mit dem ersten Satz beginnt, steht auf ihr, die ihr keine Sklaven mehr sein wollt. Also da beißt sich dann die Schlange auch selbst in den Schwanz. Wenn man da einfach nur die chinesische Hymne, wer will es ihnen verübeln, die chinesische Hymne zu singen? Also passt ganz gut. Und dann hörte man ja auch in Shanghai Demos. In Shanghai gibt es eine Volumukui-Straße, die von der Schreibweise her wie Rumkui geschrieben wird. Also man konnte sich solidarisieren, indem man sich einfach an diesem Ort traf. Es ist eigentlich so eine Ausgehstrasse, die aber natürlich jetzt auch unter jahrelangem Lockdown und so weiter litt. Und sie kommt dann nochmal darauf zu sprechen. Es gibt heute junge Chinesen, die von 89 gehört haben, weil beispielsweise zu ihrer Schulzeit Lehrer davon berichtet haben. Das ist heute schon undenkbar, weil ja in jedem Klassenzimmer eine Kamera hängt. Also da sieht man schon, dass selbst der 89, wie es dann nochmal anzog. Warum nun ausgerechnet in Shanghai Proteste und werden jetzt aus Anti-Corona-Protesten Proteste gegen die Regierung? Sie kommen nochmal darauf zu sprechen, dass die Lockdown-Zeit für viele eine sehr langweilige Zeit war, in der sie sehr viel gelesen haben und auch sehr viel studiert haben. 2022 haben so viele Leute die Universität mit einem Abschluss verlassen wie nie zuvor in China. Und man hat aber gleichzeitig eine Jugendarbeitslösigkeit von 20% auch unter Akademikern. Also die Leute werden gerade aus einem Lockdown aus ihrer Uni ins absolute biografische Niemandsland entlassen. Und so wie Corona nur das eine ist, gibt es eben die ökonomischen Verwerfungen das andere. Im Finale kommt sie aber jetzt darauf zu sprechen. Und das sollte für uns super interessant sein, weil jetzt kommen die chinesischen Eigenheiten. Die deutsche Brille lohnt sich nicht. Die Mehrheit der Chinesen hat mehr Angst vor Corona als vor der Regierung. Ganz wichtig. Noch immer. Noch immer. Sie wissen, es gäbe vielleicht eine Impfung. Ich habe aber keine Impfung. Es gab Proteste bei Foxconn, wo die iPhones hergestellt werden, weil es dort aus Sicht der Arbeiter zu wenig Schutz vor Corona gab. Nicht zu viel. Also diese Bilder müssen richtig gedeutet werden. Sie schreibt, das ist nun Xi Jinpings Dilemma. Bleibt er bei seiner Corona-Politik, brodelt die Wut weiter und es droht ein weiter, ein weit größerer Aufstand. Öffnet er, riskiert er, dass Millionen Chinesen ihm die Schuld für den Tod ihrer Angehörigen geben. Sie schließt dann, es ist nur fünf Wochen her, dass er seine Macht auf dem Parteitag verewigt zu haben schien. Jetzt kann er nicht mehr sicher sein, wie es weitergeht. Das ist ziemlich revolutionär. Also wenn in China gerade ein was revolutionär ist, dann ist es diese totale Ambivalenz, dass man mit Technokratie und Autokratie unlösbarer Dilemma vor sich hat, die man eigentlich, so wie wir es gemacht haben, in einem Streit innerhalb der Bevölkerung ausleben lassen müsste. Wir haben es auch ein bisschen übertrieben, indem Böhmermann auf der Bühne Hendrik Streeck und Kikole Menschenverachtung unterstellt hat. Das ist natürlich alles bescheuert. Aber es ist immerhin eine öffentliche Debatte gewesen, wo man weiß, egal was jetzt passiert, wir können nicht die Regierung schuld geben, weil die tut ja auch nur, was sie kann. Und es gibt eine Diskussion, die wir kennen. Hier alle Augen auf Qi. Und fünf Wochen nach seiner Verlebenszeitung da im Amt steht sozusagen alles auf dem Spiel, weil jetzt kommt es darauf an. Öffnet er das Land? Wenn ja, wann? Importiert er nochmal? Und es ist ja dann auch so ein Gesichtsverlust. Die westlichen Impfstoffe, die ja da sind, die hat sogar angepasst auf die neuen Corona-Varianten, die ja auch in China drücken und so. Also es ist alles ganz schwierig. Und ich will nur mal darauf hinweisen, ich habe im Manager-Magazin die Tage, die haben so einen Podcast, das Thema heißt er, und da haben die mit so einer Journalistin gesprochen, die irgendwie mit Biontech so im engeren Austausch ist. Und die meinte, Biontech hat jetzt 2021 10 Milliarden Euro reinen Gewinn gemacht. Nach Steuern, nachdem die Hälfte noch zu Pfizer ging und so weiter, 10 Milliarden Euro. Dieses Jahr liegen sie wieder auf diesem 10-Milliarden-Pfad. Amerika wurde von Moderna versorgt. Biontech hat Europa versorgt, also 350 Millionen Menschen und so ein bisschen exportiert. Jetzt schielen natürlich alle drauf, was ist mit Qi? Wird er China öffnen und dort sagen, ich brauche Impfung für 1,4 Milliarden Menschen? Ich bestelle entweder in Mainz oder bei Moderna in Amerika. Das ist quasi eine 30-Milliarden-Frage. Comanati, der Impfstoff von Biontech, ist mit Abstand das lukrativste, profitrechtigste Medikament aller Zeiten jetzt gerade, also mit mehreren Faktoren Abstand. Es gibt nichts, was irgendeinem Pharmaunternehmen so viel Profit verschaffte, wie der Impfstoff von Biontech im Biontech-Profit brachte. Und China muss noch eventuell geimpft werden. Also hier ist noch ganz schön Bewegung drin so insgesamt. Man muss sich das jetzt genau angucken, was da gerade passiert.
Meinst du, dass Scholz das mit Xi besprochen hat?
Keine Ahnung.
Dass es angesprochen wurde, wäre ja vorstellbar. Man muss ja erst immer sagen, wir haben auch über die Menschenrechte gesprochen. Und man stellt sich immer dann vor, wie wird das sein? Scholz sitzt dann Xi gegenüber. Auch möchte ich sie darauf hinweisen, dass wir durchaus mit Sorge die Menschenrechtssituation in ihrem Lande betrachten. Und Xi wird dann so etwas antworten wie, wir werden Sorge tragen, dass wir Missverständnisse schnellstmöglich aufklären können. Das ist ja dann so der Dialog zum Thema Menschenrechte. So darf man sich das gar nicht vorstellen. Und man kann dann ja übergehen zu der Frage, wir haben da so ein ganz schönes Unternehmen in Mainz, die sind da recht flott dabei, die Jungs und Mädels mit Impfstoffen. Also vielleicht könnte man, ich denke ja dann, ich blecke ja doch am Ende als Kaufmann auf die Welt und frage mich, ob man da nicht mit dieser Impfung nochmal so diplomatisch für Deutschland einiges rausholen kann, dass man den Chinesen sagt, also pass auf, wir machen da einen special price und wir demütigen euch auch nicht, dass ihr unseren Impfstoff nimmt, sondern das ist eine ganz tolle chinesische Kooperation eigentlich. Aber dafür müsst ihr jetzt Folgendes machen. Also man könnte das ja auch als Druckmittel einsetzen, wenn das irgendwie möglich ist, aber wahrscheinlich ist Qi da nicht so zugänglich.
Qi muss jetzt aber irgendwas machen. Weiterschließen im Sinne von nicht nur die Wut der Leute weiter, sondern auch die Wirtschaft weiter zusammenhalten. Er will ja eigentlich öffnen, nur er. Also es sind wirklich viele Dilemma, die jetzt mal da lösen muss. Und ich frag mich auch, wie das so ist, wenn du so dieser Shahi mit seiner Frau, die gründen da vor 20 Jahren dieses Unternehmen, verkaufen dann auch mal so das eine oder andere Unternehmen für eine Milliarde. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die so völlig außen vor waren damit. Diese MRR-Technologie hat ja funktioniert. Dann kommt plötzlich diese Corona-Pandemie. Sie entwickeln diesen Impfstoff innerhalb von zwei Tagen, testen den dann neun Monate lang durch. Alles geht genau nach Plan, es geht auf. Sie revolutionieren, also sie öffnen die Welt, revolutionieren die Wissenschaft hinter der ganzen Medizin. Haben jetzt gerade neunzehn laufende Studien zu neuen Krebsmedikamenten, alle auf dieser RNA-Entwicklung aufsitzend. Und dann kommt tatsächlich so ein Olaf Scholz aus China zurück und stellt sie sozusagen vor die größte Schicksalsfrage aller Zeiten. Wollt ihr mitverantwortlich sein, was mit China passiert? Und China hat eine 4000-jährige Geschichte, aber es könnte so einschneidend sein, dass es wirklich nochmal alles toppt so ungefähr. Das ist wie so, wollen wir jetzt die chinesische Mauer mal endgültig abbauen? Mit euch in der Hinterhand könnten wir das jetzt irgendwie clever managen, so wie du es jetzt irgendwie vorgeschlagen hast, dass man da so... Das ist wirklich irre, wie so eine kleine 20 Jahre lang, ja wir wissen nicht genau, ob es funktioniert. Bill Gates hat mal 20 Millionen gegeben, ob wir nochmal gucken.
Aber vielleicht wird es auch wieder nicht passieren. Also wir haben das ja damals schon ausgemalt, wie das hätte sein können, wenn Deutschland gesagt hätte, wir verschenken an die Länder die Impfstoffe. Und was hätte uns das nicht nur an Ansehen gebracht, sondern was hätten wir für Wege uns da eröffnet. Billiger hätte Diplomatie ja gar nicht sein können, als das Verschenken von Impfstoffen. Und wir hätten uns zugleich noch weiter bereichert, denn das fließt ja alles wieder in die Volkswirtschaft mit rein. Es ist ein... Also das sind eigentlich die Tage, die in der Geschichtsschreibung stehen müssen, was man versäumt hat, indem man solche Dinge nicht gemacht hat. Nun kommen wir mal zu etwas Positiven, was dann so in Europa passiert. Und das lese ich in der Zeitschrift Für kritische Sozialwissenschaft in der ProCLA. Da hat Felix Syrowatka über die Mindestlohnrichtlinie geschrieben, die jetzt auf dem Weg ist in der EU. Dieser Titel heißt abseits des neoliberalen Pfads. Da merkt man schon, aha, es tut sich offenbar etwas. Nun sind die Forderungen nach einem EU-weiten Mindestlohn so alt wie die EU selbst. Aber das alles ist immer sehr ins Schleppen, ins Trudeln gekommen. Jean-Claude Juncker hatte dann mal etwas vorgeschlagen. Auch da tat sich nichts. Jahrelang hat man nichts mehr davon gehört. Dann aber mit Ursula von der Leyen tat sich viel. Vor allem war es dann Corona, wo sich gezeigt hat, in welcher Ungleichheit man eigentlich lebte, wo die eigentlich wichtigen Jobs sind. Dass man jetzt über den Mindestlohn noch einmal anders nachdenkt und man hat da tatsächlich eine Richtlinie herausgebracht, die erstaunlich ist. Und der Autor des Artikels verfolgt diese Mindestlohn-Debatte schon sehr lange und war immer sehr pessimistisch eingestellt, dass da auf EU-Ebene wirklich etwas Ausschlaggebendes passiert. Aber man kann tatsächlich jetzt von einer neuen europäischen Arbeitspolitik sprechen. Man sollte jetzt nicht gleich jubeln, aber es tut sich viel. Die sozialen und vor allem arbeitspolitischen Kompetenzen der EU sind primärrechtlich stark begrenzt, sagt er. Aber es gibt dann doch einiges, was zu tun ist. Und es gibt ein gewisses Paradox. Nämlich die tiefe Legitimationskrise der EU und die geopolitischen Verschiebungen haben kurioserweise die Bedingungen für eine europäische Sozialpolitik verbessert. Nicht zuletzt der Wahlsieg der Faschisten und antieuropäischen Fratelli d'Italia und der Krieg in der Ukraine verdeutlichen eine neue Notwendigkeit europäischer Kohäsion. Als deren Bedingungsfaktor wird zunehmend auch die Sozialpolitik gezählt. Die sozialpolitische Offensive der EU mag daher primär einen stabilisierenden Effekt für die herrschende Integrationsweise besitzen, beinhaltet aber zugleich auch das Potenzial einer nachhaltigen Etablierung sozialer Instrumente auf EU-Ebene. Und genau so soll man diese Richtlinie bewerten. Das ist die Richtlinie für angemessene Mindestlöhne in Europa. Es geht also nicht darum, dass wir jetzt einen flächendeckenden Mindestlohn bekommen, denn dafür sind die Volkswirtschaften zu unterschiedlich. Das ist jedem klar. Der Autor sagt, es sei der bisher weitreichendste Versuch, sozial- und marktbegrenzende Dimensionen auf EU-Ebene zu verankern. Auch da frage ich mich, wenn das so ist, wo sind die Talkshows dazu? Es sei eine Kehrtwende in der EU-Arbeitspolitik. Lange war es auf dem Weg. Man hat lange überlegt, wie kann es funktionieren? Mit einem nominalen Mindestlohn kommt man nicht weiter. Dann wollte man eine Harmonisierung der relativen Mindestlohnsätze. Das ist ein Weg, den man auch weiterverfolgt. Es haben dann Forscher aus Frankreich und der Schweiz schon in den Nullerjahren gezeigt, wie man so einen europäischen Mindestlohn konzipieren könnte. Das wusste ich auch nicht, aber lange Zeit haben sich die Gewerkschaften ziemlich quer gestellt. Denn die hatten natürlich Angst um ihre Lohnsetzungsautonomie. Wenn die EU jetzt etwas festsetzt und dann den Gewerkschaften in ihre Arbeit reinfunkt, dann waren die auch erst mal nicht bereit. Das hat sich aber dann gegeben. Auch die Gewerkschaften haben erkannt, es ist dringend nötig, dass wir da auf der EU-Ebene etwas bekommen. Nun ist es so, dass diese Richtlinie erst mal nur eine Richtlinie ist. Die kann jetzt auch nicht alles festzurren. Aber es ist erstaunlich, was passiert. Im Vorfeld hatten verschiedene Beobachter, auch ich selbst schreibt der Autor, eine deutliche Verwässerung der Richtlinie durch den Rat im Trilog prognostiziert. Dies aber ist in dieser Form nicht eingetreten. Im Gegenteil konnte sich das Europaparlament mit seinen weitreichenden Forderungen in den wesentlichen Streitfragen durchsetzen, sodass die Richtlinie nicht nur ihre grundlegende Stoßrichtung bielt, sondern sogar in wesentlichen Kennzahlen und Bestimmungen erweitert wurde. Die Richtlinie zielt nämlich darauf ab, einen angemessenen Lebensstandard zu erreichen, das sei mit dem Mindestlohn zu bezwecken, die Armut trotz Erwerbstätigkeit zu verringern, und es geht um die soziale Aufwärtskonvergenz zu fördern und das geschlechterspezifische Lohngefälle zu verringern. Man hat also ein Rahmenwerk definiert, und das hat vier Kriterien. Konkret definiert das Rahmenwerk vier Kriterien für die Angemessenheit, die bei der Festlegung des nationalen Mindestlohns berücksichtigt werden müssen. Die sind neben der allgemeinen Lohnhöhe und ihrer Wachstumsraten auch die Kaufkraft der gesetzlichen Mindestlöhne und die nationale Produktivitätsentwicklung. Lange Zeit war es so, dass sich Länder dagegen gesträubt hatten, ohne Mindestlohn, und man fürchtete, dass nur wenn die Länder spezifische Mindestlöhne haben, können sie sich daran beteiligen. Das hat man aber jetzt erst einmal nicht gemacht, damit es funktioniert. Diese Regeln sind normativ gesetzt und sie schließen auch eine Rechtssicherheit für die Beschäftigten ein. Interessant sei nun, also ist der ganzen die Details gegangen, der Autor, dass es heißt, dass die Richtlinie wirksame, verhältnismäßige und abschreckende Sanktionen gegen Mindestlohn Verstöße beinhalten soll. Und ganz entscheidend, das Wort, das sonst in jeder EU-Richtlinie steht, Verhältnismäßigkeit, findet sich hier nicht. Denn sobald das Wort Verhältnismäßigkeit da steht, können natürlich dann immer die Gerichte kommen und sagen, naja, also das war nicht verhältnismäßig, das steht gar nicht erst hier drin. Das heißt, man hat hier nicht so viel Spielraum gelassen. Das ist noch ein Weg, bis sich das alles dann zum Positiven entwickeln wird. Aber zumindest ist ein wenig Optimismus spürbar, dass sich da auf der europäischen Ebene tatsächlich einiges tut und dass man offenbar erkannt hat, dass wenn Europa noch ein bisschen zusammenhalten soll weiterhin, man an solchen sozialpolitischen Maßnahmen nicht vorbeikommt.
Ja, zur Frage, warum wird das hier nicht diskutiert? Du weißt doch, selbst wenn Ursula von der Leyen die EU-Verträge neu als Generationenverträge schreiben möchte und das in ihrer State of the Union im Europaparlament öffentlich ansagt, wird es hier nicht diskutiert. Ja, der Ansicht wundern wir uns darüber nicht mehr, sondern nehmen es nur noch traurig zur Kenntnis. Wie auch dieses Thema, warum fällt es Männern so schwer, echte Freunde zu finden? Diese Frage hat in der New York Times Katharine Pearson aufgegriffen. Diese Frage wird derzeit so überall irgendwie behandelt. Bei CNN gibt es auch einen Text dazu, also auf der Webseite. Es läuft grundsätzlich unter die Einsamkeitsendemie oder so, wie auch immer. Es scheint jetzt so neue Konjunktur zu haben, finde ich auch gut. Wir bilden es hier nur kurz ab. Also, amerikanische Männer erleben die Friendship Recession. Die Freundschaftsrezension. Es ist nichts mehr los. Männer glauben nämlich, Familie und Arbeit, das reicht, um seine Biografie vor sich und anderen zu schmücken. Freundschaften zählen da irgendwie nicht so richtig als modernes Erfolgskriterium. Sollten sie aber. Das hat doch insbesondere Corona gezeigt, als die Pandemie wie ein Brennglas auf unseren sozialen Gefügen lag und man feststellte, er ist ganz schön langweilig, wenn man niemanden hat zum Anrufen. Und die Hälfte ist unzufrieden mit ihrem sozialen Umfeld, ergab eine Umfrage 2021. 15 Prozent der Amerikaner sagten, ich habe gar keine engen Freunde und es ist ein fünffach höherer Wert als 1990. Wir haben es also hier mit einer echten Entwicklung zu tun. Und jetzt hat sie vier Strategien dagegen. Erstens Verletzlichkeiten aufzeigen. Das sagt man natürlich immer so leicht. Verletzlichkeit auf Deutsch ist ja ein Begriff mit Konjunktur und in Amerikanischen dieses Vulnerability.
Vulnerabilität wird jetzt auch genug wieder gesagt.
Also hat gewisse Konjunktur. Sie verwendet es trotzdem nochmal. Nick Phaedger, ein Mental Health Counselor, sagt hier, ja, die Ursachen der Verschlossenheit ist häufig die männliche Sozialisation, kennt man soweit das Argument, stark stoisch kompetitiv. Das sind diese Persönlichkeitsmerkmale, die einer Freundschaft natürlich im Wege stehen. Diese eigentlich vorhandenen Wesenszüge der Kleinkinder sollte man mehr erhalten, statt wegerziehen. Also man sollte die Kinder so ein bisschen, naja, intuitiver nicht so sehr in so Rollen pressen. Findet aber, glaube ich, auch weniger statt. Also ich bin mal gespannt, wie die Jungs erwachsen werden, die jetzt so im Alter von meinem kleinen Sohn sind. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass da noch Männer draus werden, um es auf so eine Art zu sagen. Ähm, Übungen gibt es auch. Freunden sagen, wie man sich ihnen gegenüber fühlt. Und damit ist vor allem gemeint, wenn man einen tollen Tag hatte, einfach das auch sagen am Ende, sich einander. Dass man Freude und Bewunderung der anderen Person oder für die Situation, die man geteilt hat, einfach auch wirklich kommuniziert. Also entsprechende Verabschiedungen zum Beispiel ausschmückt. Oder sich Gesprächsgruppen anschließen, um dort dann ehrlich zu sagen, wie man sich selbst gegenüberfühlt. Also genau das Gegenteil davon. Den Freunden sagen, wie toll man sie findet. Oder vor Fremden plötzlich sagen, wie man sich selbst so findet. Und Marissa Franco, eine Psychologin, sagt nochmal, man kann auch durchaus den Mischmasch aus beiden machen, also bei einer Gelegenheit mit Freunden darüber sprechen, also eine Sache sich aussuchen, die einen eigentlich negativ beschäftigt. Und sie mal zum Thema machen. Zweitens, nicht länger einfach so davon ausgehen, dass sich Freundschaften von einfach bilden, wie im Kindesalter, wo man einfach viel Zeit mit vielen Kindern und dann hat sich das schon herauskristallisiert, sondern hier den Freundschaft als Wert an sich begreifen und dann auch sagen, die Aktivitäten, die ich mache, sind nicht nur sachdienlich, sondern sie haben auch eine soziale Dimension. Und vielleicht kann man sogar sagen, ich habe es ja auch mal vorgeschlagen, dass man einfach nur ein Begegnungsverein macht, wo man nicht inhaltlich nochmal drüber schreibt, warum. Also ein Skat, ein Kampfsport oder ein Schwimmverein, sondern in diesem Begegnungsverein, was man da dann tut, ist egal. Hauptsache, die Begegnung steht im Mittelpunkt. Drittens, Gelegenheiten nutzen, das kennt natürlich jeder. Umso mehr Aktivitäten man hat, hat man erstens umso mehr, um sie gemeinsam zu machen oder sich zu überlegen, ob man das nicht auch gemeinsam machen könnte, was man da tut. Also eigentlich alles super intuitiv, aber den Männern muss man es ja noch mal extra sagen. Und viertens, unerwartetes Nachfragen ist sehr beliebt. Wir hatten ja beim letzten Mal schon über das Fremdsein gesprochen, mit fremden Reden und so weiter. Hier geht es jetzt mehr in die Richtung mit bekannten Reden. Leute freuen sich doch sehr darüber, wenn mal nachgefragt wird, wie es einem so geht. So wie man auch sich darüber freut, wenn man selber mal, also wenn bei einem mal nachgefragt wird und der Rat der Psychologen ist hier, send the text, check in, haltet Kontakt. Und zwar, wir hatten da auch schon mal einen Text zu diesem Newslettern, die man sich so schreibt, wo der ganze Nonsens im Alltag drinsteht. Habe heute gegen meine Tochter schon wieder bei Mau Mau verloren. Nur damit man, wenn man das nächste Mal ein echtes Gespräch führt, weil man sich wieder sieht, nicht versucht, die Highlights der letzten halben Jahre zu erzählen, sondern einfach daran anschließt, wie es gestern bei Mau Mau spielen waren, weil man dann sehr viel schneller auf so einer Alltagsebene ist. Also in deren Sicht finde ich das gut, dass es jetzt so viele dieserartigen Texte gibt, die passen alle in so ein rentenrepublikanisches Bild. Und ich bin gespannt, wann das in Deutschland mal Konjunktur hat, denn bisher muss man immer noch bei New York Times unsere nachlesen. Vielleicht ist es noch ein zu uncooles Thema für unsere deutschen Alphajournalisten, aber könnte man doch mal jetzt machen.
Ich springe zum Thema Altern, aber auch in einer digitalen Weise oder auch Verjüngen. Disney hat ja ein eigenes Innovationszentrum und dort wird neueste Technologie entwickelt, damit zum Beispiel die Stars auf der Leinwand ewig jung sind. Jess Weatherbat berichtet darüber in The Verge. Sie schreibt, dass es jetzt ein neues KI-Tool gibt, das Disney produziert hat und damit kann man Schauspieler in Sekundenschnelle altern lassen. Also nun haben wir das ja in den vergangenen Jahren immer wieder gesehen, dass Schauspieler, die nicht mehr leben, auf der Leinwand auftauchen nochmal oder dass sie eine große Bandbreite von Altersstadien spielen, dass sie erst jünger sind als ihr wahres Alter, die Schauspieler aber dann noch viel älter mitunter aussehen. Das ist sehr aufwendig zu produzieren, denn wir haben es ja jetzt nicht einfach mal mit so einer Face-App zu tun, wo man das mal gerade so notdürftig machen kann, sondern wo sich Bilder bewegen, wo das auch natürlich realistisch aussehen soll. Da muss man händisch unglaublich viel tun. Und die Arbeiter der Spezialeffekte, da sind viele, die dort tätig sind. Man kann das ja mal beobachten, wenn man sich einen Marvel-Film oder so ansieht, wie lang ein Abspann ist, wer dort alles tätig ist. Oder man kann das auch bei IMDb nachvollziehen. Die ganze Crew ist nichts gegen das, was dort im Hintergrund digital gemacht wird. Und nun hat man so eine Phase-Reaging-App herausgebracht. Es gibt ein akademisches Papier, das man nun herausgebracht hat seitens Disney und hat jetzt vorgestellt, dass man dort ein neuronales Netzwerk entwickelt hat, das sich wie folgt verhalten kann. Es kann anhand einer großen Datenbank trainiert werden. Und es wurde auch so trainiert. Und die Paare von zufällig erzeugten synthetischen Gesichtern in verschiedenen Altersstufen sind in dieser Datenbank enthalten. Und dadurch wird dann die Notwendigkeit umgangen, Tausende von Bildern echter Menschen in verschiedenen Altersstufen zu finden, die denselben Gesichtsausdruck, dieselbe Pose und dieselbe Beleuchtung hat. Das heißt, man hat also synthetische Bilder, die es überhaupt nicht gibt, synthetische Gesichter. Und kann die dann entsprechend benutzen, diese synthetischen Gesichter, um den entsprechenden Star-Schauspieler nachzuformen, um entsprechende Alterungs- oder Verjüngungsprozesse dann in Szene zu setzen. Es ist also so, dass wir ja schon Apps vorgestellt bekommen haben, die einfach automatisch Bilder generieren, die es nicht gibt. Also nicht Stockfotos, sondern es werden Stockfotos produziert. Und etwas Ähnliches scheint Disney jetzt auf den Markt gebracht zu haben, dass man synthetische Gesichter hat, die zu Tausenden da zur Verfügung stehen. Diese Bilder werden von der KI produziert. Und so kann dann aus diesem unglaublichen Pool von Gesichtern eine möglichst realistische Alterung hergestellt werden. Definitiv heißt es dann hier, wird damit der Alterungsfilter von Snapchat in den Schatten gestellt. Es ist allerdings so, dass immer noch vieles trotzdem offen bleibt. Also man sieht dann doch, dass beispielsweise die Kopfhaare nicht richtig berücksichtigt werden, sie nicht entsprechend ergrauen oder weniger werden. Das heißt hier, die manuelle Bildbearbeitung, aber auch die Anwendung von Make-up wird nicht aussterben. Es ist nur jetzt ein weiteres Tool hinzugekommen, mit dem man gewisse Dinge vereinfachen kann. Aber es ist ein weiter Weg dorthin, dass man jetzt sagen könnte, das leucht vollkommen automatisiert. Auch ist noch unklar, ob die Disney Studios jetzt sagen werden, das machen wir der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich. Also man kann davon ausgehen, es wird eher nicht jetzt bald auch eine App, die wir alle auf unserem Handy haben können, damit wir dann Videos, in denen wir auftreten, verjüngen oder uns veralten können.
Ja, kann man eh nicht vorstellen, dass die künstliche Intelligenz in diesem, sie kreiert selber die Ästhetik. Am Ende wollen die es doch selber machen, oder? Also, ich meine, die Technik kann viel helfen bei der Filmproduktion. Aber diese Aspekte, die ein Schauspieler wird...
Bei den Marvel-Filmen wundert mich ja überhaupt noch, dass da Schauspieler zugegen sind. Dass man nicht einfach so eine Lizenz unterschreibt, wie wenn man jetzt sagen würde, Wolfgang, wir bringen mit dir ein Parfum raus, und ich sage, ja, dann nimm doch meinen Namen. Und ich gebe dann vielleicht noch so eine Unterschrift, die kommt dann auf die Flasche. Aber wenn ich mir die Marvel-Filme ansehe, das ist doch dann, wenn die dann mal zusammen wirklich drehen, das ist ja ganz selten. Also dass diese fünf, sechs, sieben Avengers mal zusammen drehen, geschieht dann an ein paar Tagen. Da werden auch direkt Fotos gemacht, damit man zeigen kann, hier wird noch ein richtiger Film gedreht. Aber eigentlich wurschtet da doch jeder im Studio selbst so rum.
Also es gibt ja diese Uncanny Valley Sache immer noch, die man ja zuletzt, würde ich sagen, so bei Mr. Smith in Matrix 2 oder sowas hatte, wo man so dachte, das sieht animiert aus. Und klar, die haben es auch darauf angelegt, dass es ein bisschen ist. Bei Marvel denke ich auch, warum erfinden die jetzt... Es gibt ja die ersten Influencer, die so komplett kreiert sind. Warum man das dann nicht auch... Es dauert bestimmt nicht mehr lange, bis die Filme da...
Denn es gibt ja keinen anderen Grund, warum werden die sonst besetzt. Also man muss ja extreme Budgets abrufen, um diese Superstars als Avengers zu haben. Da sind wir uns ja einig, das liegt ja nicht an schauspielerischen Leistungen. Das kann ja jeder vom Stadttheater ganz genau so spielen. Oder wahrscheinlich besser spielen als die üblichen Stars dort. Aber man braucht diese Stars als Marken.
Also ich war bei diesem Radionetzwerktag, wo die ganzen Radioleute zusammensaßen und hier so darüber gespekuliert haben, in welche Richtung entwickelt sich das denn so? Insgesamt zählt das Radio noch was. Da gab es auch eine Session von, wie heißt der denn vorne? Nico, glaube ich, Horn, so vom WDR, der so dieses Innovation Lab leitet und sowas. Synthetische Stimmen kann man einfach, einen Text, der am Indie-Innen vorgelesen wird, einfach einem Computer geben, dass der das halt vorträgt. Und es gibt da verschiedene Modelle, eine Stimme nachzuahmen. RTL hat einzelne Nachrichtensprecher schon darauf abgescannt und produziert akustische Nachrichtenlese, die nicht mehr von denen selber ist, aber erkennbar. Ach, das ist ja der und der. Und da habe ich, als ich das so hörte, mir auch gedacht, naja, aber das ist ja nur das Einfallstor an die Technik. Danach nimmt man ja sehr viel angenehmere Stimmen und nicht die, die man aufgrund biologischer Grundlage vorher vorgefunden hat. Und die Radioleute meinten aber alle so in die Richtung, naja, aber wenn das kein Mensch mehr vorträgt und so, das merken doch die Leute, wo ich dachte, naja, aber es ist doch egal, ob sie es klar merken, sie wollen es nicht merken oder es ist ihnen egal. Die waren jedenfalls alle total, die haben dann auch immer so einen Namen von irgendwelchen Moderatoren genannt, wo ich mir dachte, ne, das ist den Hörern nicht wichtig. Ein Radiohörer macht nicht das Radio an und weiß, wer da spricht, sondern da spricht halt jemand.
Nur bei manchen.
Also manche eine große Wiedererkennbarkeit und haben dann aber auch eine Show. Also es ist in der Regel nicht so, dass sie einfach nur den Wetterbericht vortragen oder dass sie die Verkehrsnachrichten ansagen, sondern die machen dann eine Unterhaltungsshow oder haben eine besondere Art, Witzchen zu machen oder Leute anzumoderieren.
Also das mag es geben an zwei, drei Stunden am Tag. Aber Radio besteht zu 90 Prozent aus Sendungen, die einfach nur gefahren werden. Da liegt dazu Text, da wird gelesen, da ist jemand im Studio, wenn der krank ist, ist jemand anders da. Da spielt alles keine Rolle. Und ich dachte mir dann die ganze Zeit, Texte, die sowieso gelesen werden, müssen nicht von den Menschen gelesen werden. Wenn jemand richtig moderiert und dann der Zufall usw.
Aber das liegt ja auch wieder bei den Gebrauchstexten. Also Gebrauchstexte, ja. Wer mir die Verkehrsnachrichten ansagt, ist mir egal. Aber ich würde mir jetzt nicht von einer künstlichen Intelligenz ein Hörbuch vorlesen lassen.
Ich schon.
Ich finde das auch zum Beispiel richtig furchtbar, dass jetzt sehr viele Sprecher wie künstliche Intelligenzen klingen. Also dass da nicht mehr der Charakter drin ist. Ich möchte ja einen Gerd Westphal. Ich möchte einen, sagen wir, Korinna Hafu haben. Diese Leute will ich ja hören, die besondere Stimmen haben und die mit dem Text etwas machen. Also ein literarischer Text oder auch ein Sachbuchtext muss ja in einer gewissen Art interpretiert werden. Das ist ja das Interessante. Wenn ich jetzt nur die Information haben will, Zug fällt aus oder Autobahn ist verstopft, dann brauche ich da nicht eine Interpretation. Aber ich brauche schon, sobald ich es mit einem Text zu tun habe, der mehr als reine Informationsvermittlung ist, eine Stimme, die irgendetwas macht. Also theoretisch kannst du alles auch spielen. Du brauchst auch nie mehr einen Pianisten engagieren. Die Noten kann jedes Gerät abspielen mit einem MIDI-Programm. Aber das hat natürlich mit Musik nichts zu tun. Und der Endliche gilt ja auch für die Stimmen.
Ja, also...
Also ich glaube nicht, um es ganz deutlich zu sagen, ich glaube nicht, dass der Neue Zwanziger Podcast funktionieren würde, wenn wir sagen, wir sind zwar nach wie vor inhaltlich für alles zuständig, aber wir wollen es eigentlich nicht mehr selbst vom Mikro machen, sondern wir haben da jetzt so zwei künstliche Stimmen gefunden. Es würde nicht funktionieren.
Es würde für uns auch mehr Arbeit bedeuten, weil wir dann die Texte aufschreiben müssen, die wir so spontan dahinreden.
Das kommt auch noch hinzu. Und da würde ich auch wieder glauben, dass das für RTL mal so eine kleine Probe ist. Und was kann man damit machen? Aber Radiomoderatoren sind ja günstig. Also warum sollte man jetzt da so einen großen Umweg machen?
Bei Audible, also mir geht es jetzt mal richtig um Massenproduktion. Bei Audible werden ja Bücher eingelesen. Ich wundere mich immer wieder, warum sie es wie Maschinen einlesen. Warum da eigentlich gar keine persönlichen Nuancen vorkommen. Es ist mir ja dann aufgefallen, als ich Obamas Buch von ihm selbst eingelesen gehört habe. Weil ich dachte, wow, so geht es halt auch. Also man kann tatsächlich seinen eigenen...
Was liegt an den Labels? Ich war zweimal auch angefragt für Hörbuchproduktion. Und das ist aber dann die Stimme, ist dann für, ah ja, klingt irgendwie so anders. Man hat bei dieser ganzen Hörbuchproduktion, auch bei der deutschen Literatur, sind das langweilige Stimmen, dass ich auch sagen würde, Alexa würde das nicht schlechter machen. Ich will diesen Leuten gar nichts böse, die das da sprechen, aber es ist stinklangweilig, sich das anzuhören. Es ist grauenhaft. Deswegen würde ich auch jedem Autor empfehlen, wenn man halbwegs lesen kann, dann sollte man den Text selbst lesen. Es hat überhaupt keinen Zweck, da dieses nüchterne Runterlesen. Aber das ist in der deutschen Literatur sowieso so ein Ding. Ich kann das nicht genug amerikanische Hörbücher, um das beurteilen zu können. Aber die deutsche Literatur zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass dann niemand vernünftig seinen eigenen Text interpretieren kann. Denk an den Bachmann-Preis. Dieses Runtergeleiere, diese permanente Laconie. Es ist nicht auszuhalten. Ich würde jedem empfehlen, sich mal ein Hörbuch zu kaufen. Martin Walzer liest seine eigenen Texte. Das ist ein Feuerwerk. Der fängt an und der holt aus. Aber dieses Stumpe... Sarah war traurig. Peter schaute sie an. Sollten sie noch Eis essen gehen? Es war nicht klar. Nur in diesem Ton wird das alles folgt.
Es ist entsetzlich. Mein King-of-Hörbuch ist immer noch Barack Obama. Er hat damit Maßstäbe gesetzt. Jeder sollte sich das anhören. Und da ist dann auch der Maßstab. Ich verstehe aber nicht, warum bei Audible es mit Absicht so langweilig gemacht wird. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Sie sich bei Audible denken, weckt mal keine großen Erwartungen. Wir sparen lieber in zwei Jahren richtig Geld ein. Weil so wie die Technik gerade ist, ist Audible so weit, in einem Jahr die Bücher automatisiert einlesen zu lassen, dass man sich dann auch wirklich die Stimme aussucht, mit der man es hören möchte. Oder die Intensität, mit der vorgelesen wird. Oder wie auch immer. Dass man es dem Hörer überlässt, was zu tun ist. Denn jedes Mal, wenn jemand, auch bei den Radioleuten, sagt, ich hätte das gerne mit Lebendigkeit und Werb vorgetragen, dann würde ich sagen, das ist eine Option in der Software. Also da keine falschen Vorstellungen. Dass da in so einem Text irgendwie komplizierter gelesen werden muss, als, ne, das wären am Ende schon die Werben oder die Substantive sein, die zu betonen sind. Und das kann man dem Computer auf jeden Fall sagen. Also das wird er lernen anhand von entweder Lesematerial, das ihm vorliegt oder sonstigen.
Also wir gehen mal bald häufiger ins Sprechtheater. Wir haben jetzt Oper viel gemacht, aber jetzt gehen wir mal ins Sprechtheater, damit du mal sehen kannst, wie man Texte unterschiedlich sprechen kann.
Ich habe ja Peter Schröder gesehen, wie er Friedman vorgelesen hat. Ich dachte mir dann, Friedman hat es besser vorgelesen. Peter Schröder hat sich Mühe gegeben. Es ist eine tolle Theaterstimme. Und ich bin ja selbst gerade in so einem kleinen Sprecherziehungsding drin und weiß auch, okay, da sind noch viele Spielräume, die wir alle nicht ausschöpfen. Aber keine falschen Vorstellungen. Das kann eine Maschine auch. Da werden wir noch überrascht sein, inwieweit wir auch dachten, Christian Brückner hätte eine coole Stimme, bis wir selber mal an Regler sitzen und uns die Stimme justieren können, der wir gerne zuhören. Und dann kommt mal noch ganz anderes Zeug raus. Es mangelt jedenfalls nicht an Material zum Lernen, was attraktive Stimme und Stimmeinsatz bedeutet.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Es wird nicht lange dauern, bis wir das überprüfen können. Das ist, glaube ich, schon nächstes Jahr. Das, was hier gerade so losgeht, ist schon beeindruckend. Ich bekenne, ich bin ein Fan. Und jetzt, wo ich zwei Drittel des Buches absolviert habe, es ist sehr lang, ich habe auch darauf gewartet, ohne es zu wissen, dass dieses Buch vorliegt. Denn es ist Jahr von Bono. Und wir kennen Bono soweit. Es ist aber vor allem, wie soll man sagen, über die Biografie hinaus eine Darstellung der Musikgeschichte, eines erheblichen Teils der Musikgeschichte, die von U2 mitgeprägt wurde und in der sich viele Wege kreuzten. So insgesamt. Und zwar über alle Genres hinweg. Also wir hören von Begegnungen mit Frank Sinatra, Anrufen von Pavarotti, Brian Enos übernachtet irgendwo und so weiter. Also der ganze Kram. Und ich habe es als Hörbuch gehört. Es war leider auf Deutsch und langweilig vorgelesen. Keine Ahnung, ich werde mir wahrscheinlich die englische Version dann auch nochmal zumindest mal reinhören, um zu hören, ob da noch was darüber hinaus ist. Jedes Kapitel beginnt mit einem Text aus einem Lied. Es sind laut Titel 40 Lieder, die hier aufgegriffen. Und dann, ja, also 40 Lieder eine Geschichte. Und dann wird ein großer, richtig, dann wird ein großer roter Faden. Das spielt natürlich auch eine große, große Rolle. Denn Bono hat oder Paul, wie er bürgerlich heißt, hat in der gleichen Woche YouTube gegründet, wie seine Ehefrau, mit der er bis heute zusammen ist, kennengelernt. Es ist also so eine Co-Evolution aus biografischer, das ist meine Family und das ist mein Beruf. Und beides große Eroberungsgeschichten. Inklusive so schöner Sätze wie, anstatt uns in die Liebe fallen zu lassen, kletterten wir zu ihr hinauf. Auf die Liebe bezogen. Oder bei der Musik. Sie wollten ja Punk machen. Sie wuchsen so in den 70er, 80er Jahren in diese Punk-Szene rein. Und während überall, wenn die Bands spielten, die Hölle losbrach, suchten wir den Himmel. Also du solltest es jetzt nicht lesen, Wolfgang, du würdest abkotzen.
Aber Stefan, du bist ja jemand geschult durch die Systemtheorie. Und ich weiß natürlich, die Systemtheorie kann einen nicht wärmen. Deswegen sucht man das mitunter woanders. Aber ich als Zyniker frage mich ja, meint der Mensch das ernst? Auch seine ganze Weltverbesserung gut. Der ist dann auch bei den Panama Papers zu finden. Da hat er nicht nur die Welt verbessert. Aber meint er das wirklich ernst? Also es gibt ja keine Benefitscaler. Es wird ja nicht irgendeine Spende in der Welt verteilt, wo nicht Bruno mit auf dem Foto steht.
Also ich sag mal so, die haben damals diese Live-Aid-Sachen gemacht. Bob Geldorf hat es angeleiert. Bruno hat eine Zeile bekommen. Sie haben dieses Lied gesungen und so weiter. Es gab dieses Konzert. Und sie haben damals festgestellt, krass wir haben jetzt so viel Geld gesammelt, wie die afrikanischen Länder, denen wir helfen wollen, innerhalb von einer Woche an den Westen bezahlen, weil irgendwelche Schuldenleistungen, Schuldendienste drücken. Und daraufhin wurde er politisiert, weil er dann rumgezogen ist. Er beschreibt dann so, wie er Bill Clinton schon kennenlernte, als er da noch Gouverneur war und so weiter. Und wie man sich so begegnet unter Rockstars. Und Bill Clinton ist ja irgendwie auch ein Rockstar und so. Und dann war er halt im Weißenhausen, hatte so einen 5-Minuten-Termin, Bono zugestanden. Und er kam dann und hat so diese Entschuldungskampagne vorgestellt. Merkt dann aber auch, ich bin ja gar nicht gut genug vorbereitet für dieses politische Gespräch. Ich bin einfach nur berühmt, da fehlt ja so ein bisschen was. Also hat er sich dann so reingearbeitet, ist halt so ein Politiker auch mitgeworden. Hängt dann bei diesen ganzen Konferenzen rum. Aber diese politische Dimension habe ich ja schon vor Jahren ausgeblendet. Man hört ja auch immer bei diesen Konzerten. Ich habe gestern erst wieder einen Konzertbericht gehört privat, wo jemand meinte, ne, die haben so gar nicht mit dem Publikum gesprochen. Die haben einfach nur ihr Ding abgeliefert, so als hätten sie halt einfach, man drückt auf Play und dann spielen sie es halt durch. Während Bono ja ansonsten, wenn er weiß, Fernsehkameras laufen und so weiter, immer ewig lange Vorträge. Und dann kommt noch mal Desmond Tutu und hat noch mal eine Videobotschaft und so, der ganze Kram. Also es ist alles sehr ambivalent, was ist wahrscheinlich dann wirklich so einfach Medientheater, das da abläuft. Deswegen hat mich diese politische Sache, außer wie trifft man Politiker und so, gar nicht weiter interessiert. Was ich dann interessant fand, war dieser religiöse Aspekt, den ich vorher gar nicht so vermutet hatte. Also sie suchen hier ständig diesen kosmischen Einklang oder sich im Einklang mit irgendwelchen übergeordneten Kräften. Es ist aber so eine ganz spielerische Spiritualität, während die ja da in Irland aufwachsen, wo es ja hoch hergeht, gerade zwischen den Religionen. Also es ist ja wirklich ein moderner Religionskrieg, der spielt da gar keine Rolle, außer Sande, Bloody Sande oder so, wo das noch mal kurz erwähnt wird, weil das für das Lied auch von Bedeutung ist. Spielt das da gar keine Rolle, sondern dieser Titel des Buches einfach, Surrender. Ich habe es ja schon, bevor ich es las, kurz genannt, dass ich das wirklich interessant finde, wenn jemand, der Milliarden verdient, dazu gleich noch ein Wort, Milliarden verdient und diesen super Erfolg mit Publikum hat. Also nicht wie, keine Ahnung, irgendwo im Hintergrund oder so, sondern einfach, er macht der Welt ein Angebot und sie nimmt es an. Dass der dann plötzlich sagt, ja, man muss sich auch mal ausliefern. Und das die ganze Zeit. Also Bono hat hier so eine Lebensphilosophie drin, die gar nicht groß ausbuchstabiert wird. Also er nennt jetzt keinen Lehrmeister, keinen Guru oder so, der ihm da, sondern einfach dieses, auf Gott kommt es an und Gott steckt in jedem Detail, in jeder Gelegenheit. Du darfst hier nichts verschenken. Du musst alles ernst nehmen und so. Bis hin zu, dass es dann auch wirklich quälend sein kann. Er beschreibt dann so, wie so Konzerte ablaufen, dass das eben von seinerseits, und das deckt sich dann gar nicht mit den Berichten, die man so hört, aber mit so manchen YouTube-Aufnahmen, die man sieht, wenn er weiß, jetzt kommt es drauf an. Ich komme hier nicht hin und halte einen Vortrag, sondern wir alle gemeinsam erleben jetzt Where the Streets Have No Name. Es gibt das Publikum und uns. Wir sagen dem Publikum, wir spielen das jetzt mal, aber am Ende spielt die Musik uns. Wir erleben jetzt alle gemeinsam, wie hier Gott durch die Arena läuft, weil die Melodie so toll ist oder so. Die nehmen eine totale Distanz zu ihrem eigenen Werk. Sie verschweigen nicht, dass sie das absolut mega reich gemacht hat. Aber sie nehmen von diesem künstlerischen Werk als Werk an sich, das sie dann auch immer noch aufführen, wirklich ein bisschen Abstand und sagen, das hat uns die Welt irgendwie geschenkt und wir sind auf der Seite, wo wir extrem davon profitieren, dass in so einem Stadion sehr viele Leute kommen und die meisten bezahlen Geld und ganz wenige verdienen Geld in dem Moment. Und das ergibt sich halt so, aber trotzdem ist es für den Moment so ein für die immer extrem aufgeladener Moment, wo immer ganz viel Religion eine Rolle spielt. Gerade wenn Bono immer mit seinem Ich will alles aufs Maximum trimmen und dann The Edge daneben, dem man das ja auch ansieht, der da totaler Minimalist ist und sich dann immer da zurückzieht und eigentlich mehr so, ja, ich hab mir das vor 30 Jahren so ausgedacht, das klingt eigentlich ganz cool, ne, und weil ich es selber so cool finde, spiel ich es euch nochmal so und so, also der da gar nicht groß Kontakt zum Publikum aufnimmt, während Bono schon ganz ehrlich darüber schreibt, wie er vor SuTV eine Tanzstunde nach der anderen genommen hat, um da einfach den McPisto auf der Bühne zu spielen, der dann so intuitiv aussieht, wie er das will, aber der halt trotzdem komplett einstudiert ist. Und sein Vater war ja Tenor und er sagt halt für sich, also U2 ist eigentlich Oper, wir spielen so Oper. Und das finde ich interessant, weil man von Rammstein auch hört, eigentlich machen wir hier Oper. Dort stimmt es in dieser Dimension, dass sie halt einfach so eine Setlist haben, die damit auch jeder Feuerball abgefeuert werden darf, aus Sicherheitsgründen, jeder weiß genau, was er wann machen muss und so. Also das ist sozusagen Regierarbeit und dann wird es einfach nur durchgezogen. Da ist es halt wirklich dann Oper, was das angeht. Aber bei U2, das ist halt auch so eine eigene Definition von Oper. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt zu Recht sehr enge Definition von Oper. Wir wissen, was ein Oper ist. Und ein U2-Konzert ist kein Oper, aber wir wissen ungefähr, was er meint. Und diese Bedeutung von Musik ist bei ihm auch so interessant beschrieben, weil er halt sagt, wir als irische Familie, der Vater wollte irgendwie so Hochkultur machen, dem fehlte aber die finanziellen Mittel und dann starb die Mutter früh. Und dann wollte man die Trauer nicht zulassen. Also hat man gar nicht mehr über die Mutter geredet. Die war dann auch gar kein Thema mehr. Sie ist mit 14 einfach gestorben, also als er 14 war. Und der einzige emotionale Ausflucht innerhalb der Familie war die Musik. Und Bono sitzt halt als junger Teenager so da und hört nicht nur sein Vater Musik machen, sondern ist auch ganz oft dabei, einfach wenn der Vater Musik hört und hört, wie der Vater Musik hört. Ein bisschen intensiver halt, als es so nebenbei dudeln zu lassen, weil er dann auch so seine Lieblingssachen kennt. Dann natürlich die ganze Literatur, die er so selber singt als Tenor und so. Und dann wechselt er halt so rein in dieses, ja Musik ist irgendwie die Antwort auf alles Mögliche. Und dann geht das halt los. Und es ist halt relativ zügig dann so der Erfolgsgeschichte. Klar auch mit allen Anfangs hier, wir kriegen keinen Vertrag hier, wir dürfen da nicht auftreten und nichts klappt und so.
Aber sonst ja sehr solide gelebt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die es jetzt haben groß krachen lassen können.
Ja, also Adam Clayton, der Bassspieler, ist wohl damals bei der SuTV Tour, als auch Klaver in Sydney. Jetzt machen wir die großen, also das ist jetzt fürs Fernsehen und die Ewigkeit. Da waren die alle 33, das ist wirklich verrückt, wie jung die da waren. Aber die hatten das Öfre quasi schon da und wollten es dann da aufführen. Und plötzlich war Adam Clayton verschwunden, weil er sich mal wieder weggesoffen hat. Und auch Klaver, der kommt heute nicht zum Auftritt. Also da muss sein Spezi, der ihm eigentlich die Bässe reicht, dann ran auf die Bühne, der wird es auch spielen können. Aber er muss dann am Tag drauf liefern, weil alle Videoausschnitte, die ihn später zeigen, können wir nur aus dem zweiten Konzert nehmen, weil er beim ersten ausfällt. Und das ist aber auch das Extremste, was man da hört. Alles andere ist, wir sind YouTube, wir machen das hier wie so vier Professoren irgendwie. Wir verstehen uns, wir streiten uns auch manchmal, aber eigentlich steht es nie alles irgendwie auf der Kippe. Und dann zieht man das halt durch. Es ist ein bisschen besonders, finde ich, wie er noch mal beschreibt, wie man auch in etwas höherem Alter, sagen wir mal jenseits von 25, sich musikalische Kreativität behält und auch Kontakt zu jungen Publikum. Da leiden ja alle drunter. Auch Oasis gibt ja von Gallagher und so diese Erklärung, wo er so gefragt wird, will sie nicht mal politisch engagieren? Und er sagt, ich erreiche die Jungen doch eh nicht mehr. Nur weil ihr glaubt, ich sei ein cooler Typ. Nee, die 25-Jährigen kennen mich nicht. Also ganz ehrliches Eingeständnis. Bei Yotu haben die immer versucht, dran zu bleiben und deswegen auch diese großen Genresprünge, die dann drin sind, so ein Popalbum oder der ganze Kram. Dadurch dann auch, dass man wirklich auf 40 Lieder kommt und dann beim Hören immer denkt, ja genau, also ich kenne den Text, ich kenne das Lied und am Ende stellt man so fest, ja, ich kenne tatsächlich 30, 40 Lieder von denen. Einfach nur, weil kurz Zeilen aus dem Text so genannt werden. Also in der Hinsicht super interessant. Nun ist das letzte Trippel noch offen.
Und damit ist vor allem er ja dann reich geworden, oder ist das darüber was?
Also er ist der Leader der Band, hat aber gleichzeitig ein ganz liebesvolles Verhältnis, schreibt das jetzt auch so rückblickend ganz, wie er sich mit jedem auf seine Art und Weise besonders versteht. Nur, und ich bin sehr gespannt, das letzte Trippel ist ja noch offen im Buch, ich werde es noch hören. Bono ist Milliardär nicht wegen seiner Musik, sondern weil er sehr früh in Facebook investiert hat und mit Facebook Investments sehr viel mehr Geld verdient hat als mit seiner eigenen Musikgeschichte. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob das noch reflektiert wird oder ob das einfach als Thema unter den Tisch fällt. Das Buch ist ein bisschen so angelegt, dass es diese Frage eigentlich nicht zulassen darf, weil hier 40 Lieder eine Geschichte von Bono erzählt, aber wenn man das Buch liest, manche Sätze sind so auf Stil getrimmt, dass man genau weiß, das sind ungefähr 17 Lektorrunden, die hier liefen, um die einzelnen Kapitel wirklich, also selten so ein durchgestyltes Buch gelesen, wo auch jeder Text von der Länge her genau hinhaut und so. Also es ist eine große Freude, wenn man sich dafür inhaltlich interessiert, dem zu folgen, weil man kennt ja die Hälfte der Geschichte, nämlich immer diese musikalische Seite, und dann erfährt man so den ganzen Rest, der so drangebaut wurde, und man wird auch nicht gelangweilt davon, weil sie es schon an dieses Publikum wie mich richten, weil man so ein bisschen die ganzen Alben und Musik kennt und auch den einen oder anderen auftritt, gerade SU-TV damals. Und es ergänzt sich ganz wunderbar. Aber es bleiben doch ein paar Fragen wahrscheinlich dann offen. Gerade kann man so auf sein Leben blicken und dann diese politischen Sachen, die vielleicht auch ein bisschen peinlich sind. Es sind große Erzählungen drin, wie er so im Flüchtlingscamp rumhängt und da auch eine Woche mitarbeitet und die ganzen Erfahrungen macht und so im Wartezimmer sitzt vor den Büros der Politiker. Also der ganze Kram. Aber dieses Facebook-Investment und wie sich so Facebook entwickelt hat und wie das eigentlich so gar nicht zu seiner Linie passt und auch zu seiner Spiritualität und so. Also ich bin mal gespannt, ob es das im Finale dann noch gibt. Es gibt hier am Ende, will ich nochmal so, als unter anderem zu seinen Freundinnen zählt Naomi Campbell. Sie tritt auf, alle in der Band sind sofort in sie verliebt. Und er beschreibt sie als Stummfilm-Star unserer Zeit. Und das fand ich mal eine sehr gute Formulierung irgendwie. Der Stummfilm-Star unserer Zeit. Also ich kann das sehr empfehlen, das Buch. Das ist für die, die sich interessieren. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das gewinnträchtig ist, so ein Buch zu schreiben. Ich glaube, hier ist ganz schön viel Investition reingeflossen, um das wirklich auf Bonus-Anspruchsniveau zu heben.
Es wird ein Weltbestseller, ich glaube.
Es wird ein paar Millionen einspielen.
Ein paar Lektoren verschleißen.
Und ich kann auch sehr empfehlen, diese Interviews, die Bono jetzt rundherum so gibt, weil er sich dann doch jetzt immer schon als der Denker, der... und so, ich muss hier mit meinem Arm wedeln, ich bin eine Orchidee. Also er spielt das sehr durch. Er versucht, es aber so ganz originell aussehen zu lassen. Aber wenn man im Buch nachliest, wie er damals seine McPisto-Rolle gelernt hat und dann auch ganz bewusst auf der Bühne so spielte, aber einmal so tun wollte, ich bin wirklich eine McPisto. Ich bin halt so, ich bin so ein Jack Sparrow, bevor es Jack Sparrow gab sozusagen. Und jetzt gerade bei diesen Interviews sehen wir im Grunde wieder so eine Show, bei denen wieder diese Reflektionsschleife wahrscheinlich erst in zehn Jahren wieder mitgedreht wird, wenn dann dieses Kapitel, und jetzt habe ich meine Geschichte auch noch aufgeschrieben, nochmal ergänzt wird als Geschichte, die dann wieder aufgeschrieben wird. Also in der Ansicht ist das eine ganz schöne, ein ganz schönes Hineinstechen in so einen Teil Musikgeschichte, der ja wirklich von Bedeutung ist. Das muss man ja echt mal sagen.
Zum Schluss eine Romanempfehlung von mir. Jahre mit Martha von Martin Kordic. Dies ist ein Roman, der mich sehr fasziniert hat. Er handelt von einem 15-Jährigen, der ursprünglich aus Bosnien-Herzegowina kommt. Seine Mutter ist Putzfrau, sein Vater Hausmeister und Bauarbeiter. Einfach ärmliche Verhältnisse, die Klassengesellschaft ist spürbar täglich, aber auch der Alltagsrassismus der deutschen Gesellschaft, auch die Hürden, die einem in den Weg gelegt werden. Wenn man den Aufstieg möchte, so hat er zwar lauter Einsen in der 10. Klasse, und dennoch rät man ihn im Berufsinformationszentrum, mach doch mal eine Gärtner-Ausbildung. Und dieser Ich-Erzähler flippt dann aus und sagt, ihr Fragebogen ist kaputt. Und was man eigentlich von ihm will, ist ja, dass er Respekt vor Deutschland hat und sich dann diesen Institutionen beugt. Er ist es dann, der seinem Bruder sagt, wir müssen besser sein, wir müssen die Besten sein, um zu bestehen in diesem System. Und der Bruder sagt dann etwas sehr Hartes zu ihm, das ist, also das Studium ist nichts für Kinder wie uns. Und es ist aber die Geschichte eines jungen Mannes, der mit großem Fleiß, mit Energie, mit Trotz und Glück es schafft, an die Universität zu gehen. Und eine entscheidende Rolle dabei spielt diese Martha, oder wie er sie zunächst nennt, Frau Gruber. Sie ist Professorin, sie ist verheiratet, sie hat eine Tochter und irgendwie kommen sie sich näher. Irgendwie merken sie gleich, dass da etwas zwischen ihnen ist, etwas Unaussprechliches. Als er 15 ist und sie schon Professorin ist, da gehen sie in die Oper gemeinsam. Was sehen sie sich an? Die Zauberflöte in Heidelberg. Sie verrät ihnen ein bisschen, wie man sich zu verhalten hat in der Oper. Was man tun soll, was man trinkt, ein Sekt und so weiter. Das ist dann eine gemeinsame Nacht, die sie verleben, die zwar erotisch aufgeladen ist, die aber nicht sexuell ausbuchstabiert wird. Sie sind an einem Badesee und danach treffen sie sich erst einmal nicht wieder. Er beginnt dann zu studieren bei einem Professor, der auch das Kind italienischer Gastarbeiter ist. Und er erkennt gleich diesen jungen Mann, der auch anders ist als er, der auch nicht aus der deutschen Mittelschichtsgesellschaft stammt. Dieser Professor sagt an dem Ich-Erzähler, die reichen Leute erkennen uns am Weichspüler. Man kann unsere Armut immer riechen. Es sind also sehr harte Sätze, die da auch fallen. Dieser Professor fördert ihn vielleicht nicht ganz uneigennützig. Es ist eine Freundschaft, es ist ein väterliches Verhältnis, vielleicht auch einseitig etwas amorös. Aber da ist immer Martha im Hintergrund und irgendwann meldet sie sich wieder bei ihm. Sie führen per SMS Kommunikation ganz kurz, wenige Worte, aber hoch erotisch aufgeladen. Und sie treffen sich dann, sie kommen einander näher. Aber es ist nicht einfach so ein Techtel-Mächdel dann, sondern es ist eine innige Beziehung, die immer auf Spannung gehalten wird. Die Spannung besteht auch daraus, nicht gleich jeder Lust nachzugehen. Es ist sehr beeindruckend, wie er die ganze Kompliziertheit einer solchen Verbindung, wo ja auch einige Jahre dazwischen liegen, zwischen den beiden, schildert. Wie das auch verknüpft wird dann mit der deutschen Gesellschaft. Wie dieser Aufstiegswunsch bei ihm vorhanden ist und wie er geschildert wird. Wie er versucht, alles zu lesen, was es nur gibt. Aus einem Altpapier sich die Zeitungen herausfischt, um sich bilden zu können. Und wie die Professorin natürlich immer in einer hieratischen Position zu ihm steht. Schon deshalb, weil sie viel Geld verdient und auch noch Geld geerbt hat. Und damit das Geld nicht mehr zwischen ihnen stehen muss, schenkt sie ihm dann eine American Express-Card, damit er sich auch nicht zu sehr um das finanzielle Sorgen machen muss. Aber natürlich ist diese Konstellation der Ungleichheit immer da, aber auch reizvoll. Und diese Vielschichtigkeit einer solchen Beziehung lotet der Autor grandios aus. Und man lernt auch nochmal sehr viel über die deutsche Gesellschaft mit dem Blick eines Einwanderers. Ich kann diesen Roman Jahre mit Martha von Martin Kordic sehr empfehlen.
Dann haben wir alles besprochen.
Am Ende mit unserem Salon wollen noch ganz kurz darauf hinweisen, weil manche ja den Teaser nicht hören und nur den Salon hören. Wir haben im Teaser schon darauf hingewiesen, dass man den Salon auch verschenken kann, zum Beispiel zu Weihnachten oder anderen Festtagen, wann immer man möchte. Das ist möglich über Steady. Und man kann diesen Salon, so ist es angedacht, an Menschen verschenken. Die müssen nicht bei Steady auch sein, sondern man kann, wenn man selbst einen Steady-Account hat, was ja jetzt fast alle haben, die uns jetzt hier zuhören, manche hören über Apple oder Patreons, die meisten über Steady, die können jetzt den Salon verschenken, indem sie dann die E-Mail-Adresse der gewünschten Person eintragen und den Namen, das ist relativ leicht erklärt. Und sonst kann man auch den Support fragen, wer einen Weihnachtsgeschenk sucht, kann das tun. Und wir hören uns dann ja nicht erst am Ende des Monats zur regulären Folge wieder, sondern am 20. haben wir unseren Live-Auftritt. Und dann wird sehr bald, wahrscheinlich einen Tag, zwei Tage später, wird dann dieser Auftritt auch hier im Salon zu hören sein.
Genau.
Bis dahin eine gute Zeit.
Und ich möchte nur inhaltlich, weil ich vorhin anfing mit Bundesverfassungsgericht erlaubt Beteiligung am E-Corona-Aufbaufonds. Da habe ich ja gesagt, vor vier Stunden oder so, wir werden die ersten inhaltlichen Kommentare heute bekommen. Ulf Poschart twittert in dieser Sekunde, Merkels Verfassungsrichter verändert Karlsruhe auf bedauerliche Art.
Das ist doch wunderbar.
Wir kommen Ende des Monats darauf zurück. Haut rein, bis denn.